Get closer.
Heat. Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
It's
Heat.
Hey
everybody.
Don't up.
Heat.
Hey, Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
I feel
is rising united and vibing.
Whatever is next, we riding. Got the
whole unit. We sliding tonight. No
turning back. Don't cut no slack. Nobody
surviving. Could be any minute. If we
can do what we do, then we can win it.
Or this is the end. Like a light
sentence. Move like a general. Keep it
consistent. Don't let them up till they
are finished. We're going in like we
back for vengeance.
>> Tension is rising.
Tension is rising.
>> Get on your feet. Whatever we do,
repeat. It's time to take to the
streets. We won't accept defeat cuz this
is the danger danger danger zone. Danger
danger danger zone.
Whatever we do, repeat. and take to the
streets cuz we will accept defeat cuz
this is the danger
danger zone. Danger danger danger zone.
hand.
I want you.
Monster.
Heat. Heat. N.
I can't be right.
I want to be
dream.
Heat. Heat.
beat.
Beat.
back. Hey
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Yeah.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Heat. Heat.
N.
Hey. Hey.
Good morning
and everybody watching at home here for
our third European Ian regional
qualifier. James and Bandit here to take
you through with all of the fans here in
the venue and all of the players cuz
we've got a lot of people still in the
runningings for our tournament. Of
course, we are looking not only to crown
a top 64, a top eight, but it's going to
be all about that third regional
qualifier champion here in Europe.
Bandit, your first day at the RQ circuit
yesterday here for Riftbound. Uh how how
was it for you?
>> It was exhilarating. It was memorable
and honestly it's almost sad to think
that this is the last day already.
>> The last day but of the first event.
We're gonna have I hope plenty plenty
more as we continue and we've got a lot
on today. We have so much Rick Bband. We
had plenty yesterday, plenty today. It's
going to be as you've seen it Swiss play
for the first five rounds of the day
followed by a top eight cut all the way
through to our finals which uh always
has been excited. And our champions are
still undefeated. We'll get to that
later on in the day. So, a long day of
of Riftman, but but a great day.
Honestly, yesterday felt short in
comparison. I I I I could have squeezed
in a few more rounds.
>> Yeah, I just keep keep going. We'll do
more. Well, like more rounds, more
rounds and more important things to play
for is always the case here at the
regional qualifiers. Of course, we
mentioned it coming into today. We're
looking at top 64 is the first kind of
benchmark moment for people. You've made
day two. Now you want to get that top 64
spot. Yeah. If you if you want to
qualify for the eventual regional
championship, that is that is the
hallmark that you have to pass through.
Top 64 and we will be seeing you once
more. Then if you want to make a name
for yourself, top eight is that all
important moment where people are like,
hang on a moment. This player is
somebody we need to keep our eyes on.
Top eight always a massive
accomplishment. And of course, the
champion of the event will get the
unique prizing of the champion promo and
playmat. And of course, we've got best
off prizing to give out today. Uh lots
of great players still in the running
for their best ofves. And of course, the
top eight as well. Here are our top 10
ranked players. You can see nine eight
nos currently. And then bias just
sneaking in there with the 701 that that
draw putting them in the top 10. Um,
this is a laundry list of of players,
but also uh you know, some some familiar
faces. We've got, of course, Squirtle,
our previous regional winner over in in
Le, still undefeated for the first day
of the tournament. Honestly, when when
you're going through the list, it is
always stunning that the same names over
and over seem to make it really hard for
all the rest to get a spot in any top 10
whatsoever. But this time around,
honestly, I'm just excited at the sheer
variety that we're seeing. Some Rexai
leaking through over from from China.
The aggro is starting to bloom and
blossom. And Colin, we saw on stream uh
yesterday, undefeated on the set, eight
and zero. We know how good Colin is. We
know the best of us have been picked up
multiple times by Colin. So, no
surprises to see that performance so
far. Um, so many players to keep our
eyes on Allen undefeated still. No
surprises there. Um, but he he lost the
game yesterday to Silvin.
>> But here's the thing, that is such a
wild thing to be putting out that the
expectations upon these players are so
incredibly high to the point where going
8 on 0 is almost expected and going 7-1
is hm is he having an off day? Is he?
Well, that match up was the Diana versus
E match up. And okay, um this next stat
people are going to clip and be like,
"Okay, what's wrong with the meta?" Hold
on.
>> Let's take a look at our conversion
rates for day two, cuz this is insane. A
59%
conversion rate for Master Yi. Uh that
means of the 184 players that queued
into the event with Mari, 108 of them
have made day two. That is the mad part,
right? If Gee was a legend that had 11
players, that had 10 players. All right,
you can easily sway the conversion rate.
This is the most played legend at the
event and it's still smashing any and
all expectations. For context, Bolognia,
League of Draven.
>> Uhhuh.
>> What was it? 38% 38% conversion rate of
the boogeyman of the meta.
>> Uh Aurelia likewise with with Draven and
Le were kind of like 28 29%. I do want
to give a little bit of context to this
um because the overall percentage of Ye
played was around about 10%. It means
this sounds really bad. It means there
were fewer unsuccessful Ye whereas in a
meta where we had like 20% meta share of
like Draven, that's kind of a um we're
eyeballing it.
>> Yeah, exactly. A rough rough statistic.
you had more players that weren't quite
making it there. So yes, this does mean
that Ye is a strong deck, but look at
how high the conversion rates down the
rest of it. We had a 46% for Diana.
>> Those are all so we had a Civ
particularly high. So I think one thing
>> as an additional level to this, yes, of
course, Marci is one of the decks to
beat and that is not something I'm going
to going to kind of paste over.
>> It's undeniable.
>> People are starting to really delve deep
into like, hey, I'm I'm refining how I
play on this deck. my matchups are
getting better. We we're doing more
events, so people are a lot more
confident, especially in these early
rounds where you you know, you hit a
whole bunch of different matchups. And
you got to keep in mind, we are nearing
the tail end of Unleashed here. So,
people are getting more comfortable. We
are nearing the peak of knowledge
available, of experience gained with the
cards available at this moment. Take
into account in that that he has such an
incredibly high floor. Yeah. So reliant,
so consistent to do at least that
can lead to dazzling numbers like 59%.
>> Yes. So I still my prediction yesterday
on Ye doing really well of getting to
day two but then crumbling a little bit
today. Uh like we've seen from Urelia I
hope comes to fruition because otherwise
I'm going to look really stupid. But
that's why I have Diana here because I'm
like these high like ceiling high skill
ceiling champions and legends I think
can quite handedly deal with the Ye.
>> And the stats don't lie. Yeah. Diana is
one of the few decks that actually does
have a positive win percentage into the
Yei. So, you're really going to have to
try duck and dodge, get the matchups
that favor you, and when you don't, keep
a cool head and make that top cut
anyway.
>> Meanwhile, you got to feel happy with uh
Colin still being in this.
>> Oh, that old thing.
>> To be honest, you only need one set to
make it through to look like a god.
>> That that is the thing. I really do
believe that with set in its current
position, it can do incredibly well into
the Y. It can do incredibly well into
the more reactive decks like the Annie
like we saw yesterday. That can leave a
Annie completely powerless.
I believe still this is the one for
Colin.
>> The one for Colin. Um and of course we
have talked a lot about the the names,
the players that are here in the venue
this weekend. And of course, we always
appreciate the fans and the community
that come out to our regional
qualifiers. Let's take a look at a few
more of the fans here at RQ Ut.
>> Hi B here with RQ. Joining me is Silvin,
frontman for our Polish delegation. I
will say Riftbound super fan Hassar hype
beast. How are we feeling today,
>> bro? I'm right now I'm flattered, you
know, very good. The overall feeling
here is insane. A lot of people like I
would say this weekend we'll have what
3,000 4,000 people in this venue. It's
insane. It's insane. It
>> is absolutely crowded. Everyone is
bringing their agame not just to this
event. You've been bringing your agame
for a while starting in Bologn from day
one. From day one
>> from day one.
>> Now just to kind of what what drives
that passion to join all of these events
with all the passion that you have? I
can speak just for me that I I've been a
shortcaster for League of Legends. For
me, League of Legends was my whole life
to be fair. Uh my current situation in
life is because I was so close with
League of Legends. So when I see Rebound
coming, I just decided like I I love
card games, I love League of Legends.
It's the two best things for me to be
connected. So I just love the people,
love the energy, love the game,
everything here.
>> And it's not only coming from you
because every time we see you, you are
surrounded by Pro's brethren and sisters
bringing all of the energy. Is that
something inherent to just the Polish
community in itself?
>> Okay, give me this microphone. Give me
Give me I'm not gonna lie. I'm not going
to lie. In Poland, Reebound is like the
biggest thing. Everyone's so hyped. We
have local tournaments with 100 people.
Uh we love to be competitive. We love to
play casually. And the fact that I'm
surrounded with these people, it's just
because they love to come here and have
fun. It's just because of that. But the
point is since day one, we heard that
Rebound is coming. Rebound was hyped up
in Poland. We just love that. I mean it
it shows so clearly from the energy you
bring the energy that everyone brings to
each and every single event. Now I mean
whenever you bring opponent you have to
talk Allan and you were there in
Bolognia when he lifted his very first
trophy. How did that feel as a spectator
to see to see that happen right in front
of you? No matter the sport, let's say
rebound is this sport, right? No matter
the sport, we love rooting for our
representatives and seeing this goat
playing in the tournaments. It just give
us this this this dopamine rush every
time. And not only him, we have many
talented players. We have Barek, we have
Sho, we have Sebic that come second in
Bologna as well. So Alan is just very
prominent tip of tip of the an iceberg.
So now that he has not only acquired his
first trophy but his second trophy and
is now hunting for his third,
does he will he get it in Utre? His
third trophy.
>> Hear me out. Hear me out. Not only UT
from this spot I can say that Alan will
be the first world champion of rebound.
Right. Right.
>> I can tell you that. I can tell you
that.
>> I think it's very clear. He clearly has
the support not only from you but
everyone around us. Now I'm going to
have to ask how many of your friends did
you bring along for today?
>> 200 people I think in total here is like
I don't know maybe 100 there a lot of
people still waiting for the on demand
at this point coming to the venue but I
think easily like what
200 people from Poland at least at
least.
>> And are they just as passionate as you
are?
And are they just as passionate about
cheering on a potential threetime
champion?
>> But of course, other players as well as
well. You know, you know,
>> we're we're cheering for everyone in top
eight. However, there can be absolutely
no doubt about the passion that the
Polish delegations bring in. I'm going
to bring it up one more time, guys.
Wait, wait, wait, wait,
>> guys.
>> Magic.
>> Just one last thing. One last thing. One
last thing.
>> One last thing.
>> In Poland right now, we have this thing
ontopia. If you are not going to have a
great weekend, not a good tournament,
you are going n. But if you are feel, if
you are feeling lock in, if you feeling
prepared, you are going to pack past.
And this weekend we are definitely going
to Park Park. Let's go.
>> Thank you very much. Thank you very much
>> everyone. Thank you so much for showing
up. Absolutely wonderful experience.
Best of luck today.
>> All right. Over 1,800
players entered the rift here in Utre.
Last chance dreams of winning those best
of legends from Origins having a chance
at $6,000
and a chance at the elusive regional
championship. Now only 300 remain.
Conquest points glory. That is what our
rift bounders will be battling for. And
I Burton along with Leo will be your
tour guides through the biggest regional
qualifier to date. And we're getting
straight into the action here. Leo with
an allstar star studed match here.
>> Yeah, you were speaking of some of the
greatest players ever and Alan ZQ,
former Rune Terror World Champion, of
course, two times regional qualifier
winner already, still undefeated here in
he
none other than Colin the boss who is
going to play set. So that is a very
very interesting matchup because with
unleashed this deck has finally received
something that is a counter spell is the
repulse. Yeah,
>> that is going to be a key card in that
matchup because otherwise you know set
is a really really clunky deck. You have
your units that are going to be buffed
up strong almost unkillable but they can
be bounced.
>> Yeah. And it just lets you recur you
know those high might characters units
that you can put down put them back to
base with your legend ability. But it
looks like we are getting started here
in our Swiss round nine feature match
here at the UK regional qualifier. We
are in day two. Both players currently
at that perfect 8 and zero record and
Colin is starting us off that set the
boss deck
>> already has a cyria of Cloudfield. Very
very nice throwback that card as well to
run Terra Times. Diana is being played.
Of course, that is the nicest thing
about playing Diana is, you know, you're
going second and usually with every deck
you're like, ah, I would have liked to
go first. But with Diana, you are not
worried at all. You're just playing your
incredibly powerful value three
>> good looks like for just going to see
that champion unit come down. Going to
get a buff as well. And it is back over
to Allan as you do say can play from
first or second here. Diana, one of the
reasons why it is terrifying our meta
game right now.
Looks like we've got some decisions to
make here. Leo, what we thinking?
>> Oh, we're developing a Vex as seems I
>> already thought.
>> Yep.
>> That this might be a good time to
immediately bounce that set, but no.
Alan says, "Yep, I am just going to
develop the Vex and see what you are
doing." Doesn't have to be afraid of any
sort of ambushing on the side of the
Rockfall path. But I would not assume
that this is the battlefield that Colin
wants to play in anyway since he has the
Monastery of Hana, which is one of the
most powerful battlefields in Riftbound,
I want to say. However, very
underutilized because just quite as
simply not as many decks can play on it.
You need to constantly be able to
generate buffs.
But that is exactly what Colin's deck
loves to do. This deck is all about
buffing and that legend ability can come
in the clutch when a buffed unit would
get killed. You can expend the buff and
it will just come back to your base. And
these units, these are all pretty big
already. But looks like we are going to
see a straight conquest into that
monastery.
Oh, into a stat deck. Okay, I thought we
was going to see something quite cool
there. But the stat deck let Allan
filter through that deck
and it's going to be a very clash of two
different play styles here. You know the
down a very trixy deck reduce might win
those showdowns of course but then Colin
with those buffs that might can get
rather high. So will he will Alan be
able to
>> I need to judge. I had one card flipped
in my deck that was uh uh I need to
check if there is no more flipped cards.
You would think that a deck like set is
very straightforward, you know, very
very clunky,
>> very low decisions, much punching.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, that's just like the spirit of
set. No,
>> but
>> there's very few players who succeed
with set and it's basically only Colin
all the time who runs away with set now
spends a buff gets to draw another card.
So, he must know something that all of
the others don't.
>> Well, it's been working quite well for
him currently at that 8 and0 record. get
that first mate now so you can ready up
that champion unit. Gets that buff back
to the ability there. And you can sort
of see the synergy, right? You spend
your buffs. Pit rookie. That's another
boss buff now I should say on the boss.
And then and we're back over and look at
that board. It's looking quite scary. Is
over to Allen now though.
>> Vex is significantly less strong when
your opponent is already developed in
base. on the rune.
>> It's not the strongest of all the cards
out there. Diana now just going for a
little bit of extra value. Checking top
card. Didn't find a spell. This one is
going to be a Kha'Zix as well. We're
going to leave that on top of the deck,
of course. However,
that card loses a lot of value when your
opponent knows that you have it.
>> For sure.
>> Yeah, the ambush card can go up to six
if it is slamming into a
>> marked. Can you fix it? It's just like
jutting out of the sleeve.
>> I do say yes.
>> Deeper.
>> When a when you know an ambush card is
coming, you can play around it rather
well,
>> especially with the rockfall path on the
battlefield one of the battlefields. But
knowing that a Ka'Zix can come down, you
can perfectly just play around the
entire time saying, "Hey, my units that
couldn't get Kha'Zix, I'm going to play
those into the rockfall path and the
monastery of Hana." You have the option
to always go in with like two units
>> of course to negate that ability there
that the card that gets the extra two
tie turner coming down. We are going to
swap the down around
two.
>> Titan often times in this deck works not
only as something that utilizes the way.
>> Yeah. Yeah, but it is a little bit of a
sacrificial lamp sometimes when you're
trying to conquer with cards like your
Diana or Vex and then you try to pull
them out of those battlefields to later
on generate more value or some value at
all because the first time Alan ZQ used
the Diana ability this turn he just
revealed a Kha'Zix so not trying to find
or trying to find spells but just not
being able to do that. He still has five
runes up. He's up in one point. However,
the development that Colin has is quite
strong. And now a sabotage might force
out a reaction immediately. That is
going to be a star cross.
>> You bounce the Vex.
>> Yep. To return that boss to Oh,
>> do we have No, we have a spot though.
So, that boss is going to put back to
hand that champion unit and the tie
turner will be getting sent back to hand
as well. And then a flash to preserve
that Vex that is going to go through. as
you do rightfully save Vex isn't as
impactful when your opponent has as a
ball state develops
>> and sabotage looks like we're going to
send August to the bottom of the deck.
>> Now, this might have all looked rather
impressive, right? But this sabotage
completely tapped out Alen's Q
immediately and ripped three cards off
the hand.
>> Yes,
>> you took away a Gust. Flash was used
immediately because people see Flash as
this amazing bailout card, right? You
can conquer po score for points and then
you can still use your flash. But in the
end, it is still an unfavorable trade if
your opponent pushes into a battlefield
and you have to flash to preserve your
units if you do not have a way there or
Stellacon herder. You're still going to
go negative one. And this is also what
happened here. Yes, we preserve the vex
into the base. Yes, we use starcross to
put the set kingpin back to hand,
>> but those are cards that we have just
used. So Alan's EQ all of a sudden down
to three cards in hand just after one
sabotage when he was at
>> four or five before
>> even you know removing that star cross
I'm sure Alan would love to have saved
that you know for arguably a better time
right but that is going to go oh we are
going to see four runes being used here
it's going to be a champion unit coming
back down
that champion unit is rather scary gains
one extra might for every other friendly
unit out of battlefield
>> it's already quite huge with five might
for
>> Yeah, exactly. That is
>> for Fiora coming down as well when it's
mighty gaining a whole multitude of
keywords. Deflect and ganking and
shield. Obviously very easy to get to
that mighty. Just needs a singular buff.
And there it is getting played to that
battlefield. That is a stack looking
battlefield there. Leo Colin having a
very devastating looking board. It's
over to Allan now though. We know the
contents of the hand already from that
sabotage.
Wonder what that top deck was there.
>> That is eight might on the battlefield
already and you have already gotten out
that star cross. You have full
information because we quite frankly
remember it's Ka'Zix mutating horror on
top of the deck because
so full information on set side on
Colin's side which is also why he played
that Fiora into the monastery
>> of course. Yes.
>> So just two steps ahead at all times.
It's a fantastic example of one of the
best rift bounders in the world trying
to not let get his opponent out of this
choke hold that he has on him when it
comes to might on board.
Got a stack deck decision there.
Gust pit rookie.
>> Oh, gusting a pit rookie. Not the best
target in the world.
>> That does open up the Ka'Zix for the
extra damage now though. So, we are
going to see is that Vex and the Ka'Zix
slamming in. Kha'Zix obviously swinging
for six with that ability there. Ambush.
>> Does Colin have a response? Does he need
one is the bigger question because you
have six might on that Fiora. You trade
away possibly the Kha'Zix or the Vex
honestly both are great targets.
>> We do know that Colin does have a Rengar
in the hand
>> and he you could just set save your
Fiora. I don't think he's losing too
much. Yeah, he's paying the power cost
spending the buff. Oh,
>> I'm just spending the buff and just
recall the recall it with that legend
ability.
>> I don't mind that. Yeah,
>> cuz that's going to that's going to play
around Vex cuz it is still in play. You
can just charge it in next turn.
>> So, we are just debating exactly what to
do here.
>> The Kha'Zix
>> takes out the Kha'Zix says, "Hey, I have
everything developed that I need
anyways. I don't want you having six
might unit.
>> Leave the vex there. I am looking
strong already." However, if you're
looking at the just the board state,
Alen ZQ currently controlling both
battlefields at four might. Still has
two runes up, but he has used the flash
already.
>> That would be the bailout. And that only
works once if you only play one. I don't
even know if he's only playing one.
Yeah, he is. But
>> this is something I want to draw
attention to a little bit here. This
dino deck is used to just removing these
threats as we are going to see a hidden
card come down. But with that legend
ability from set, the threats aren't
being removed. You saw the Fiora just
get combed. It's almost like he just got
flashed, right?
>> So, I'm intrigued to see if Allan can
sort of win this attrition of war. Was
that a repulse off the top?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> That is a great card. That's going to be
amazing into the diner in any showdowns.
Just removing any threats that Allan can
throw back towards you. One of the
premier cards from the unleash set for
us body players out there.
We love a cheeky repulse.
>> Yeah.
>> Look at the options. We got the pit
rookie. We have a Rengar.
Have a set as well. Pit rookie going to
instantly give that thor buff. I imagine
it could. There is a world in which you
buff the first mate. So it just attacks
over the Diana for one more might. But
of course that is a lot more sensible
getting that deflect, getting that
shield and ganking. I mean those two
keywords really don't help you right now
if you're sitting in base waiting for
the offense.
>> But if the Foria sticks Yeah. And it you
just become that wrecking ball going
battlefield to battlefield.
>> So where are we pushing with Fiora?
>> Hey
>> going into the
Vex battlefield immediately together
with the first maze.
>> Any backup? Are we going to send anyone
else in? There is a hidden card there.
Could be a Titan. Most likely a Titan.
We did see the hand. There was quite a
few titan and we did get the hand
knowledge from the sabotage. But here we
go.
>> Seven versus four.
>> He has so many cards and so many runes
up and so much might developed already.
I really doubt that there is something
that
>> uh Alanic you can do to completely
surprise him.
>> So this is 6v7 with the focus passed.
>> Yeah,
>> that's what's happening. Are you ready?
>> Shall go back to base again. Such a
favorable trade. And we draw a card of
the monastery by using the buff on the
Sytheria.
a two drop that doesn't constantly push
for points. It's just sitting there
generating value in monastery again.
>> You can just see the value of that
legend ability that Fiora has
essentially been killed twice and it
just comes back to base and the next
turn is going to go charging in again.
You get the draw power for the
monastery.
This is it. This is what the D isn't
used to dealing. You think, well, I deal
with these threats. You're going to have
to try and develop more. Colin can just
say, well, you can deal with it. It's
back here. It's coming straight at you
next turn again. Bear in mind, we still
have to repulse. Oh, here's that
signature spell as well. That
showstopper buff a friendly unit and
then you can send it into a battlefield.
>> This can go straight into the other one.
>> Yeah, that is a really, really good
card. When I read it first, I thought,
hey, this doesn't really do too much.
However, when you have your recalled
unit that just basically died and then
didn't, it really does a lot of work on
the offense. Fra pushing into the
rockfall path now. very hard to respond
to that with one left open. You can see
it in the body language of Alen ZQ right
now. He's not happy how this game is
going.
>> Super fight to dig four more cards.
You're not going to use that on Fiora.
That's going to cost you a power now.
Wow. And the Fiora is just going to go
through. I think the name Fiora
victorious here is very apt living up to
its key word in there. Absolutely
incredible value
and the Fair coming down to get a buff
as well. You can just see the synergy
here. We're drawing power with buffs.
We're recalling with buffs as well. Is
over to Alan now though.
>> We have some options there.
>> When was the last time you saw Adana
outvalued like this by a deck that is
order and body?
>> Yeah, I know. Traditionally, you know,
two domains together haven't had the
greatest amount of success, but looking
at this, it's quite honestly, I think
it's poetry and motion watching these
units just dance around. high might and
if you're Allen, you've been board
wiped.
But you have a moonfall, but you've got
nothing, you know, to threaten at least
this turn.
>> And there's so much might, so much
pressure, especially with the
irresistible faith hoke as well. Devil
can just push up into the rockfall path
from base, drag a unit, whatever unit
Alen wants to play in.
>> And it is just going to be the
concession. Allan realizes there's no
way out of this. Colin takes our game
one.
>> Yeah, he had it coming. There was no way
out of that scenario. No way in the
world. Maybe a Houe from the top could
have helped him there, but developing
that would have taken another turn.
That's a double hold. You're suddenly on
to six. And how are you holding against
this many units with an irresistible fay
fog in base with Fiora victorious?
>> Yeah, I think you're right. Even if he
did get the way down, Colin had the
faith folk there could just, you know,
develop another unit or a couple units,
drag it in, send it to the send it to
the trash. And I think you're right,
Colin got too far ahead. Too many big
units. And with that legend ability,
those leg those units weren't going
anywhere. So, we are in our siding
process here. What do you think our
player What do you think Allan will be
siding in here after that game? Because
you saw a lot of the dep. You saw the
tips and tricks as it were. What do you
think he can respond with to help even
out this game too?
>> I think you need a lot of bouncy cards
to to stop this
>> for sure.
>> The the advantage that set has when it
comes to sideboards is the deck doesn't
really use equipments. So all the gear
hate that people play versus Aurora,
it's not really in there. People play
invert timelines to stop the Lux loop.
That also really won't help you because
most of the time, especially after
Monastery of Hiama is out, you're not
going to have like 20 cards in hand. So
I I think it's going to be super hard. I
we have seen him side singularity
before. I reckon that's a card that
works because I think Alen is also
running some equipment removal in the
main deck and that's going to go out for
sure. That's an interesting thing. I
like to attention to the fact you talked
about the bouncy cars cuz the legend
doesn't work on bouncing. It only works
if a unit was to die.
>> So you can't, you know, I think how
Colin was able to win that game. You saw
the Fura just never leave the field. It
just come slamming into after turn. If
you can just remove that even for one
turn so you can stabilize could be a
very different game there for Allen.
>> But maybe the key was that sabotage
though. Just removing that star cross
and saying now the the field will be
mine.
Can Colin do it again? Cuz quite
honestly, that looked like a very
one-sided affair.
>> Yeah, that sabotage just came in the
right moment. You had to you forced out
the flash 100% because you really needed
that otherwise you use all of your
units.
>> The star cross. I mean, the gust is so
low value in that matchup that I think
it was also very correct of Valenc to
throw that star cross immediately down
to that as well. But then again, you
have just completely lost your entire
turn. You passed on a lot of runes that
were open just from a sabotage. You
exhausted four runes and you lost two
cards in hand. That was crucial.
>> And that is why I think we can see Colin
is currently what eight and0 right now.
You can just see the deck works. But if
anyone can win a game two and a game
three, I think Allen's EQ is high up on
that list. Finds a two. Dropped the
Raven Bloom student is back over to
Colin. three body runes to play with and
it is going to be that Lucian.
>> I
>> You love that card, don't you?
>> Love myself. I'm very happy to see it.
And this card is even crazier in the
monastery of Irana because you can empty
that battlefield every single time. You
never hold it basically. And you just
keep drawing. Now, Raven Bloom pushes
into the Tagon's Peak. And of course,
that is Diana's favorite battlefield to
play in, even more than the Raven Bloom
Conservatory, just because this
battlefield gives you so much temper.
when you go first, you will have access
to that first. So, it is going to be
rather easy for you to actually defend
this now. Of course.
>> Wow. Okay. Got the double ambushes in
the hands.
>> That is not
>> No, it's not ideal. We're not really
generating our buffs here. We actually
>> Oh, no. No VI peacekeeper. We have five.
>> Yeah, I was about to say I was literally
about to say we have can't use the VI.
>> Yeah,
>> we haven't got any order runes for that
one. And that means our champion unit is
also locked out. That requires one order
as well. Yeah. And it feels like
ah it is so hard to tell. It it feels
all there is
>> there is a repulse in hand I believe.
>> But do you want to say it's only a one
of I believe. Do you want to use that
now?
>> I there is a world in which you just
accept it and then replay the Lucian.
Just say I don't care about that point.
>> I I think I agree
>> because if you play Oranga from hand now
you're going to be completely tapped
out. If you give Ellen's a Q a turn
where he just taps out where you where
you're completely tapped out and you
just have a Rengar on board.
>> I can tell you that is not going to end
well.
>> But what are the options though? Or just
putting down illusion again and leaving
free open. Yeah,
>> you have to find some of the order runes
and then again afterwards you have to
find some more answers because if you're
playing those cards on five, any little
thing that could happen to you is going
to tip you over. And if you lose tempo
against Diana, especially with a pilot
like Alensq, it's not going to end well.
>> The Vex apathetic is in hand. When the
board hasn't been developed, this could
be very impactful. Would be very costly
to use now though. Wouldn't have many
runes open,
>> but this feels like a very different
game to game one. Right. In game one,
Colin was off to the races. Buff unit
straight away as well. I can see Diana
charging in there.
>> Quite curious to see if Allan is just
going to leave at Diana. Oh, that's a
nice pick. That's a good pick up right
there.
>> That Diana in the Valley of Idols
>> just because in the last turn Colin did
not push the Lucian into that Targon's
Peak signalizing. Okay, we're completely
passing with our
>> got some order.
>> We got one order rune.
>> It's big.
>> You could even push your Vex apathetic
into the valley of idols and buff it as
well if you want to make it a little bit
harder. We are going to see Lucian go
charging in. It looks like that's
currently a trade on a 33. We know
stupify is in hand though for Allen.
Didn't have a chance to have any runes
he has open though.
>> Is that going to become an even trade?
Alan just wants to go for the da predict
ability. Finds another stupify.
>> Now we could play your ambusher there.
Oh, we are we are going to get that V
peacekeeper. That would stun the Diana
as well.
I'll start across to
>> Oh, but here comes the star cost. Leo,
>> do you bounce the Lucian here? Because
VIP peacekeeper has a valuable resource
in hand. Of course, it wouldn't be that
energy efficient.
>> Oh, no. We're going to see the Repulse
come down. That's going to stop that
since the Star Cross does target one
unit. Repulse will just stop that right
there in its tracks. Two runes open for
Alan. We know there's another ST. We
know the stupifier is in hand.
It's going to be a stat deck. It's
looking like
there's that one-off repulse held off
earlier from that Lucian coming in a
much better time, much more value
>> actually about Starcross. I had to read
that up. It targets two units. It's one
friendly and one of the opponent and
Repuls just says
>> one unit and no more friendly units.
>> Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah, you are
correct. Yeah. Yeah.
>> But it still absolutely does protect you
from Starcross. now puts away the
illusion here. Keeps it in base. But
Alensq, even though he lost that trade,
that is two runes gone for Colin.
>> Yeah, still no order runes for what it's
worth. I mean, I guess you kind of have
to get him next turn though. But
>> he is still sitting on a lot of runes.
He's ahead in points. That might be the
perfect moment to retreat the Raven
Bloom student and then develop the Vex
Cheerless. Exactly. Goes wide in base.
That's the great thing about Diana and
the patience of these pro players. When
you have a
>> solid advantage in points,
>> you can give points away and use this
time that you are giving your opponent
where they have to go on aggression. You
use that to build up your base and then
go for even bigger pushes. You don't
need to win a game with eight victory
points to zero. That is quite frankly
going to be super hard. Possible in some
matchups, less possible in others. You
just need to win by 87. Everyone you get
like that is good enough.
>> Here's something I want to draw some
attention to. Some cyborg there from
Colin. Only had access to one repulse in
game one. Now has a second. So he
realizes this is a matchup. I need those
repulse.
>> This is
>> basically what Master Yi wants to do
versus Diana as well. You want to have
Defies for
>> Y
>> for Moonfall and for Starrust and
Repulse does just that.
>> Yes.
So now if you're Colin, technically you
can go charging in. You imagine that's
going to go through. Yeah, Lucian will
ready when he conquers the battlefield.
So we can uh
can just go back to base if he likes.
>> I just kind of wish it was high noon
Lucian.
>> Oh, are we going to see champion unit? I
think we might be.
It is coming in with that buff as well.
if it goes in
>> has the tank keyword
>> and gets one extra might for each
friendly unit at the battlefield. That's
currently what is that 67.
>> That was unintentional.
>> I think
Colin with the amount of runes he has at
least he does never have to worry about
resolving a punch first anymore.
>> That is that is going to absolutely be
possible for him for the rest of this
game. And also having the repulse. So he
has two runes open. can counter spell
one targeting card and he can still plus
five might one of his cards with two
runes open. That is about the strongest
position you can be in. However, if you
are behind in points like that
>> still
>> tough position to be in if Allen decides
to go on the offense.
>> See the VI peacekeeper coming back. I
like that cuz you can sort of reuse it
abilities to stun a unit when it is
attacking. Oo, what are we what are we
what are we gasping about? Oh, that is
singularity. That is a card that targets
two.
>> Oh, so you can't repulse that one.
>> Yeah. And I think that that set might be
sitting at six. No, that would be juicy
juicy.
>> Set is at six cuz the vault
>> gets plus one for each friendly unit,
not each other friendly unit.
>> Oh, it counts itself.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. So, the set is
currently out of range. VI peacekeeper
is at six. That is in range. And
obviously Lucian sitting there at three.
But I mean we have picked up 20
stupifies so far that we haven't used.
So you can just singularity and then
later on.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> How many runes are we at? This is three,
six, eight. So that would mean that you
could actually repulse through through
stupify through a repulse because you
have two
>> if that is something that Colin wanted
to do. And that might be the point where
the DA utility runs away.
>> I think this is going to be a very
impactful turn. You're right. There's a
lot of things we can do here for Alan.
touching hand. I have
>> How much time do we have left on the
clock?
>> I'm sorry. Thank you.
>> Sorry. Heard their turn.
>> No, it's okay. We have 35 minutes left.
I was just double checking for us.
>> This is a very impactful turn.
Maybe contemplating if there is a big
punishment for something like a
singularity or do you want to play
without it? Because in the end set is
still going to be able to save one of
those units. You cannot forget about
that set legend.
>> That is true. has already seen one
repulse. So Alan could be bringing him.
Is there any more? Only saw one last
game.
>> Things you can also just really in a
chill way go into combat with the Vex
cheerless because it is going to make it
so much harder for your opponent.
Moonfall is going to be cast now. And
that kind of screams repulse me. No,
Colin just lets it happen.
>> Yeah, I think if it is just going to be
on the um on the Lucian have to just let
that one go.
direction.
Not us.
>> We are going to see poverty getting
passed over now.
Currently 5 to four. Yep. Five to four.
We make that
>> total of six now. Right. Correct.
>> Six.
>> Eclipse. Set. Eclipse
>> down four right
>> actually very good point I've seen
brought up now repulse can only protect
units at battlefields so therefore
moonfall doesn't really
>> apply to that most of the time unless
you try to drag one unit from one
battlefield into the Huh?
>> So, who has that eclipse targeted then?
That's going to give minus four to a
unit.
>> I would say this eclipse is trying to
target that set. I mean, Lucian is
already in only one might. Taking four
more away from it seems a little bit
excessive.
You have to imagine that we'll get a
target from that legend ability though
to just bring it back to base.
Of course, singularity
is still an option at some point as
well.
Sure.
That actually resolves
that. Looks like Colin might be
trying to just take that trade
and profit off of the set legend
ability.
>> Oh, wait. Singularity isn't an option
now. That's a six cost.
>> Only five open
>> comat.
>> Yeah, we're saving the set kingpin while
Lucian dies.
>> He did a valiant effort to be fair,
didn't he, Lucian? He got stuck in.
>> Yeah. Bloom student going to conquest up
there. The Targon's pick that will open
up two runes at the end of the turn as
well.
>> Lucian got a point and eight a gust.
That's more than most free drops do.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So Allan at six points the magical
number having a bunch of cards and have
five runes still open. Targon's Peak is
going to open up two more runes at the
end of the turn. He still has a bunch of
cards in hand. However, the backline
that Colin has built up over the last
couple of turns still
>> quite scary actually with the set and
the Vi, especially Vi on the offense is
such a powerhouse.
>> Even more so when she is buffed, when
she gets in with that set, the boss
protection.
>> Yeah,
>> that
>> now she's minus seven. Okay,
>> sounds like another moonfall
that has been cast by the Fizz
>> taking in that set unless we have just
can't repulse that.
>> Can't repulse that one as you say.
>> Wow, this is strong. We do know that
Colin does have a Rengar in the hand so
can go charging without very costly
but yeah, when you're at that six point
mark,
>> this is looking quite scary.
Totally different to game one, right?
It's the reverse reverse fortunes in
regards to board state value units.
>> I mean, having two units stuck at
battlefields versus a VI that can just
attack
is a little bit scary, especially when
cards like Shieldstopper come in.
>> True. Good point, actually.
Is that in hand? Oh, it is in hand as
well. Okay. But the showstopper can only
push units from base into the
battlefield. So that is a whole
different scenario. However, I think we
do have the irresistible fay folk. So
that is something you can play to your
base and then push into the battlefield
that you have just conquered with a VI.
Are we trying to conquer the Targon's
peak now? Trying to deny it from Allen
in the opposing turn or are we going to
push into that Vex? Because Allen is
already at six points. You have to
tackle this problem at some point.
>> Yeah, you are Rory. It's a tough
situation.
>> I think Vi might be your best shot at
tackling that. You also we have seen a
Rengar in hand.
>> Yeah,
>> but
>> so costly though. That kind of limits a
lot of your other options.
>> Is Rengar going to be equipped to handle
a Vex cheerless? Because you're not
going to stun that one.
No. Vi pushes into the Vex. Let's see if
Vi can do this on her own or if she
needs support from Oranga. Firsty is
being cast. That is totally fine for the
moment because it only levels the
playing field when it comes to might. So
we're at 55 while Vex shield is stunned.
That is not a problem for the Vex. But
the second stupify is hitting
immediately down to two runes already.
Now it seems like
>> whatever Colin wants to do, he may.
>> So Moonfall picked up might be huge.
Wow. Remember
that Vex will increase enemy spells here
as well while it's in combat. It's going
to make trying to get over those stupid
fires even harder. Punch first is an
option. That's in hand though. That
would cost two,
but when your opponent's at six points,
Leo, it's
>> Yeah, you you kind of have to, right?
You you haven't got any time. You have
to start trying to develop this ball
state and get Allan off it. Your runes
really don't help you anymore when you
have lost the game. Frozen Renga trophy
hunter.
>> Okay, that does get around the Vex
cheerless increasing enemy spells.
That's a massive might swing.
>> Now that does follow to this
battlefield.
>> Oh, the move was going to move off the
Renar.
>> That is incredible. But now that the
Rena is on that battlefield,
are you going to be able to repulse
that?
>> Surely.
>> Wait a second.
>> I think Repulse would work. Yeah,
repulse does work.
>> That's going to prevent the Moonfall.
And it looks like the Repulse has saved
that showdown and Colin has finally
moved that Vex off.
>> But out of runes, out of option for the
next turn is going to hold to seven. And
for the moment it looks a little bit
difficult to actually
>> singularity.
>> That is huge. Fizz on your base.
>> Have the call to glory.
>> I do not next.
>> That's it then. Yeah, that's going to
clear off the battlefield and then the
Fizz can just charge in and Allan
>> will win game two. We're going all the
way to a game three now. Both players
are that 8 and0 record. Who will be
advancing to that 9 and0? We're going to
a game three.
Phenomenal patience from Alen really
showing why he's one of the best of the
best.
>> That was incredible. You know, we've
seen a really good singularity angle
that gets a lot of value in a turn
before. But he knows, hey, if I
singularity your big units, they just
recall. They go to base. So, you're
holding this big aggressive swing from
that singularity that is going to push
back units to base for the winning turn.
>> Yeah, so patient. We mentioned a
singularity a few turns ago, I think.
Well, I definitely forgot about it. And
then yeah, just being so patient and the
second the Rengar came down, you knew
there were no runes open. You saw the
second repulse. Not that repulse would
have mattered, of course, but and said,
"Right, I have a feeling this
singularity is going to stick. It stuck.
And now we're going to a game three."
Perfect timing, perfect play. Alan doing
everything he can to force a game three.
Now the last battlefields will be
played. You're seeing one of those very
interesting battlefields that Diana is
really rocking with doing all the work
in there. So that might be a tough one
for Colin to overcome. However, Colin
with a little bit of a surprising one.
One that we haven't seen too many times
except for in decks like Ahri or Vex.
>> All of those whole decks, you know.
>> Yeah. All the whole decks. But
>> true. But it kind it makes sense in this
deck though, right? cuz you're throwing
big units, chunky units, buffed units.
So you can just say, "Right, I most of
the time I can hold." So that go grove
of the god hollow willow can be very
helpful cuz I mean draw power in this
deck. I mean I get outside of the um the
monastery from last game. Draw power
actually isn't the highest in this deck.
I'll be fair. So
>> no, if we're checking out the deck list,
let's let's see how many cards draw
cards. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This one. Yes. One of Hidden Blade. No,
no, no, no, no, no. And no, you're spot
on.
>> Well, so there you go.
But we did see in game one he was able
to really use that monitor to draw and
that could have been a factor to be
honest. And then and the one draw card
you were putting at a hidden blade a bit
costly. You kind of have to kill your
own unit to do so. So sometimes you
don't really want to have to do that. So
yeah,
>> I like the Valley of Vitals together
with the Vi and Rena as these ambush
units. Of course, the card is naturally
designed for ambush units, but the
ability to just buff them up for one
extra energy can, I think, change some
scenarios quite drastically.
>> Yeah, and it's sort of another cheeky
way of getting a buff in play that you
can then use for your legend as well,
right? Cuz sometimes getting those buffs
in play if you don't develop your pit
rookies or anything like this can be
that not easy to come by. That's a very
easy way to ambush. pay one now you're
buffed.
>> But I mean that basically says that if
you have a pitch rookie in base, you can
versus for example Master Yi play a Vive
from hand and then just kill it off with
one extra energy. So you have eight
might in total and you can kill off the
rea without any consequences for you not
losing any kind of units. So I think
Valley of Idols has some specific use
cases. One of those could be like pitch
and V together to be a Renga trophy
hunter from a master.
I would really like to hear which
specifics Colin has looked at during
deck building with the value of idols
which for which exact use cases this
card is utilized because with these pro
players there's rarely a case of yeah I
just play this card because it's good
but it is I play this card because it is
good in X situation.
>> There's going to be certain break points
of might that you need certain card
combinations. You're so right. It isn't
just going to be a case of well my deck
likes to buff and this buff so it's not
going to be as simple as that when you
are 8.
>> I mean maybe
>> there's also there's also
>> that's how that that's how I approach
debt building. I'll be honest with you.
We are in our mulligan phase here and
our game three here. Our round nine
feature match here at EJ regional
qualifiers. If you just joined us,
you've joined us at a good time. We're
going to a game three and it looks like
Colin is kicking us off. Here we go.
>> Interesting. Mulligan choice from Alen
ZQ. You've seen that he is on the rune.
So he has three for his first turn.
Mulliganing away a traveling merchant.
So one of the two drops saying I do need
more value in this matchup. Not a lot of
units to combat stuff. Least of all the
traveling merchant because I'm going to
develop my Diana in turn one anyways.
Most likely at least. I can still be
proven wrong, but I would I would think
that's a very fast
>> Colin had the opportunity to put the pit
wiki down. Obviously wouldn't be able to
use his ability to buff some things.
opted not to. Well, let's consult this
hand then. Leo, it's just going to be
Diana champion coming down. Okay,
there's definitely some options in that
hand. Here comes the Fiora, though, and
it's just going to be the pass back
over. We saw that Fiora be an absolute
wrecking ball in game one.
>> Oh, is that the option for a big Huay
already? is one of the centerpieces of
the Tiana strategy, but sometimes it is
really hard to develop. If you get the
chance to play away into a more or less
open field with little punishes, I think
that could be a strong strong choice
because what card? Oh, there is one card
that punishes it. A card that has found
its way out of many Master Yi deck list.
The challenge is waiting for the Fiora.
I think if you have pit rookie, you can
buff the Fiora, push into the abandoned
hall, use the challenge.
>> Yeah, that all seems rather good to me.
>> No, no, no, no. Abandoned hall resolves
after the challenge has resolved. No.
>> So, I think that would still be a five
on five. You have to be very careful
with this.
You can potentially punch first and then
have to do it that way around. That
makes sense. I think if your opponent if
especially Ellen's a Q, but I think
Diana in general
is tapped out on a HU that was
developed.
>> I kind of like just getting rid of it. I
think you're right. But it looks like
>> Hey, I'm not going to say that I would
have played this better than Colin. No
way. That is that is 100% the right
choice.
>> This man knows what to do with set, but
he does not respect the way. Potentially
not finding a way to get rid of it. Ex
that was not intentional but he didn't
want to invest the punch first and I
understand that because that's three
runes that you were just throwing away
to get rid of a qu
>> I think you're right there many ways to
skin a cat as it were is over to Allan
now did get the way in obviously has
that ability when it moves draw a card
discard a card depending on what you
discard you get a different effect
>> and with the tie turner on hand I think
he's also going to find a way out of
that battlefield
>> that one that one was intentional
So we are going to get Alan's first
points on the board there. Discarding
hard. Vargon really really strong in
that scenario because this most like
this has some applications in the
matchup when a Rengar is being played
for hand or a VI and a punch first is
added. Sometimes there's not enough
runes open for the set to still pay for
hard bargain.
But I don't think he's in the scenario
where he really needs to worry about
this because this is a Hay game and the
Huay is running away with card
advantage. So you can pay a little bit
less attention to reacting to Colin
stuff but push your own agenda and that
is going to be a tight turner swapping
the tides with keep in mind we are
sitting in an abandoned hall. That means
that this tight turner can actually
throw hands.
And this is an interesting one because
the way wasn't a factor in games one and
two. So, we're going to see just how
impactful it is in this matchup cuz as
you say, it can also just become a
wrecking ball and just start doing a lot
of damage. And sure, Collins deck has a
lot of might, but can get out of hand
silly fast. Now, could this be a turn in
which you utilize some challenge
shenanigans?
>> It's a different deck when you have the
way.
>> Yes, it is a completely different deck.
You can a
weird statement to make when I say you
can just play a little more risky with
it because you have to make sure that it
is either super secure on your board or
your opponent would have to invest silly
amounts of cards to just get rid of it
immediately like this punch first
challenge combination.
I think there's an argument to be made
that you have to remove it on site the
quay before it draws especially when
your opponent is tapped out but going
three runes down when also not being
ahead in cards.
>> Oh wow.
>> Yikes.
>> As you do say when the ty turner is at
the abandoned hall is currently going to
trade right now with this fa after that
stupify. Bear in mind Allan has drawn a
lot of cards over these last two turns
by the way
>> and that is going to be a wow it's going
to go through. No buff to expend. So we
can't use the legend ability to keep the
Fiora around.
>> I was going to say this stupify already
did a job because it forced Colin to use
another card. So this superfy would
trade up immediately. But trading with a
Fiora victorious is madness. That is an
insane spot for Lenzq. If this is one of
your first games of Riftbounds that
you're ever watching and you're
thinking, hey, both of these players are
at one victory point. That was a massive
sign that Ellen's Q is ahead in this
game
>> for sure. Absolutely ridiculous thing to
think about. Tie Turner squaring up to
Fura and actually well I say winning
that for all intents and purposes that
was winning there.
>> Colin still has all his runes to play
with. Allan still has four open as well.
>> What? Have a chance to consult Colin's
hand. What do we have here? I see a
first M. I see another four. I see is
there a pit rookie there as well?
Here we go. Thank you for that
production staff. Right on time for a
first mate. First mate V. Not
>> double first mate coming down. So you
can ready up your pit rookie and your
champion unit and just send them back to
base.
>> Pseudo flash with hands and legs.
>> Flash with hands and and three might
each as well.
>> Yeah, but also almost being completely
exhausted here. The world in which Allen
just pushes those in and then flashes
out. However, flash such a huge card
against combat based decks. I do not
think you were to just use it
preemptively. There we find our hard
bargain back again. So, this is an
example. If you were to have a moonfall
somewhere around, this would be a
scenario where if Colin was to use punch
first, you would have the hard bargain
ready and would actually get tremendous
value out of it.
>> And AlenzQ just passes it back. No need
to go fast. No need to waste a flash. No
need to risk a flash.
doesn't put the way into the
battlefield. Now with two units, one of
them Raven Bloom Student in Abandoned
Hall, you have infinite might. Infinite
might.
>> That Raven Bloom Student Quite honestly,
it looks like it's only a two miter gets
one might for each bell you play this
turn out abandoned hall that becomes
two. So that can get rather silly. This
is a big important turn for Colin here.
I feel as if throughout this game Alan
is definitely favored. If this turn
Colin doesn't start to bring that penny
of power back his way Dana with a way
developed Raven Bloom student developed
a big hand I don't see a way back Colin
has to try and even it up here
>> you know what else has big hands punch
first but where are you going to use it
you can push something into the
abandoned hall but you don't want to be
forced to use double punch first
especially not versus a deck that runs
star cross and possibly a rebuke it has
vex chill in it so it's not completely
out of the picture that that card is
being played. Even though I do not think
that is going to be the case, but there
is so much might adjustment. Abandoned
Hall is absolutely correct against stuff
like this. Colin goes for a push and
that is already 6 to5. Now with a stack
deck, just a stack deck that gets you
even more cards, you are going to turn
it over. Raven Bloom trigger, abandoned
Hall trigger,
>> just from a stat deck. And you get and
you get card advantage from that as
well. But we still know that hard
bargain as well is in the mix. So you
know if the punch first go by
peacekeeper though can't hard bargain
that and that would obviously stun the
raven bloom student as well or whatever
one is swinging for more. And there we
are going to see the defensive flash.
That was a really good trade there I
feel for Alan. Forced the resources out
and has flashed but the vibe peacekeeper
is still going to hang around though.
That is amazing. See, last turn there
was a
small thought in me that thought, hey,
maybe you're conquering both and then
you're flashing out of those
immediately. Also, because you're not
threatened by any sort of counter spell,
so you can actually hold that.
>> But just forcing your opponent in
abandoned hall to invest a VIP
peacekeeper, which is one of the biggest
offensive pushes that the deck has.
>> Mhm.
just retreating everything back in and
then next turn having an offensive push
with a Raven Bloom student into the
abandoned hall is a setup for success
even though you're going down in points.
>> Yeah, and you still got your way as well
just chilling at some point that's going
to we are going to see the pit rookie
getting moved up there as well. So we
are threatening a double hold here but
as you say Raven Bloom's doing in
abandoned hall still got way we still
got hard bargain to counter any punch
first or anything like this as well.
Oh, look at the cards in.
>> A lot of cards in hand there, Leo. This
is I think this is going to get a bit
silly this get this turn.
>> Also, the buff generation of Colin is
just not there in this game. But he
still has four runes open and he has
double punch first in hand so he can
fight back.
Give all the card advantage in the world
you want to Allen Q. Colin has four
points if he somehow gets to double hold
this. If Alan does not find star cross
or cards to utilize the way multiple
times or has a moonfall
>> and this could get dicey. If you give
your opponent a hold to six and then
they push everything they still have out
there's a good chance that over two
turns.
>> Yeah,
>> they can find their way into those
battlefields again and double conquer.
>> And I think there's something to be said
as well. You said Colin's at four
points. He has also just more might on
his side as well. Punch first can just
get that up to astronomical levels.
Allan has to do some tips and tricks,
you know, abandon hall, moon falls,
dupify, eclipse, all that good stuff,
but has to have those. So, yeah, this is
going to be a very interesting turn
here. I think Colin's on a fantastic job
at stabilizing. This is a very, you
know, sizable board that Allan will need
to break through. And I think that's why
we can see Allan just really thinking,
how do I get around this? does have some
options. You know, Raven Bloom Student
Way
>> is screen
>> a world in which you play around punch f
repulse by pushing a, for example, Raven
room student into the abandoned hall and
then just using your moonfall there
without dragging a unit in. If you're
not targeting one of the unit,
then you won't get repulsed.
So we
>> or I mean you have the hot bargain that
you could pay up for.
>> Well, we do see the moonfall coming down
here. The raven blooms doing the abandon
the hall. That can get silly. I think
that was targeting a first mate. I saw
it sort of, you know.
>> No, you don't have to target anything.
That resolves and he did not push
anything in to play around the repulse
masterfully.
Guys, you I think you were right there.
Yeah, you called that perfectly.
>> Stop it.
>> Okay, so now we are now 7 to five.
>> And this is the thing. If you force out
punch first, the hard bargains in hand.
We know that.
I up a challenge. What could this be?
What we eyeing up with this then?
Is it going to be your champion unit
targeting something?
>> Oh, challenge sets us down to two runes
for a potential hard bargain. I mean,
Colin has seen a hard bargain discarded
earlier. That's the
>> earliest card in the
>> throws the hard bargain and gives him
the option to just pay up. He says,
"Hey,
>> can just pay for it. You can do that.
But if you do that and resolve the
challenge,
>> you're not going to punch first me this
turn.
>> Yep. And Allan has a cornucopia of runes
open. Can then start, you know,
stupifying all that silly business
>> as well.
Do you pay that hard bargain? I think
you kind you kind of have to. I think
you have to. You have to keep your units
around here. You can't afford to let
that Raven Oh, no.
>> That's a result. I think he has double
punch first in hand with two runes open.
If you just let that challenge resolve
here, I think Allan still finds a way to
just turn the tides here because he's
still an abandoned hall with eight cards
in hand, right? So, if you just let this
go through, you take out the Ravenum
student. Big whoop. Stupify is going to
immediately push that Diana to a higher
might than all of the other units
combined if you use it on that V. First
punch first.
That's a five might swing.
But we have a smoke screen on the side
of Alen EQ that would for way less cost
in terms of power double the cost in
terms of energy just almost level the
playing field. Don't forget that also
Colin can profit off of the abandoned
hall. So that is going to be a six.
>> Yes, good point. Actually
>> also challenge has boosted up something.
>> I don't think the challenge resolved
right cuz it got hard bargained. It
didn't pay the price.
>> That is a good point. Yeah. Thank you.
>> So now what can Allan He say we know he
has the answers in hand.
Just debating on what to do here. Going
to be a stupify first.
Stupifying abandon hall. Honestly such a
big might swing for one cost as well.
And you get to draw.
Just keep an eye on this one then. So VI
is currently at plus one. Plus two, I
should say. First mate minus one. Other
first mate minus two. Raven Bloom Tuded
plus five.
>> Oo, Starcross pick up. Don't get me
wrong, I'm really happy we have the
dice. It's still really really tough for
me to keep track here right now.
Star cross found off the stupify draw as
well. So Alan has that sort of emergency
button. If all else goes wrong, just hit
that star cross button. He up the second
punch first.
>> Punch first and punch second as well.
Colin not asking any questions here.
>> Just throwing hands. Now
>> this is where the star cross would be
absolutely brutal. Or you might even
need to use it. The multitude of cards
in Allen's hand though. Alan has
prepared for a star cross by always
buffing up this raven gloom. Almost
always buffing it up. So just using a
star cross to bounce that V if you even
want to do that.
>> Uh here.
>> Oh spreading the punch first.
>> You go plus six.
>> I just the abandoned hall trigger was
first made.
>> So that is tell you what that is a
stacked V right there.
That star cross be so sad.
>> I mean, you don't want to starcross a
VI, but then again, when your opponent
has just used four body runes for two
punch first onto that V, it also doesn't
feel that bad. Look at the rune
>> management here. The economy of both
players is so misaligned.
And
>> you forced out so many offensive options
here from Colin.
One card in hand.
>> That's something you got to consider as
well. Only one card in hand for Colin.
Make it two.
>> Star crossed. Has to be the V surely,
right? Stay on the V. Oh,
>> and that Leo is so brutal. After
investing two punch first in a VA, you
just return it to the hand.
And that challenge will end with Colin
being unsuccessful.
>> Trigger.
>> And now Hay going in as well, picking up
a car. Can boost itself up to eight.
That wouldn't quite be enough here
because currently the set with its own
effect because it counts itself should
be at nine
>> if I'm not completely mistaken.
>> Five six.
>> Yeah, eight nine. I make that. But there
is a smoke screen. That's going to bring
it down by four. And that's going to be
a concession there. Oh no, it's not.
Sorry, I got I got a little bit excited
there. Chill.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean to be fair, this is
looking quite scary. Okay, we are going
to use the legend ability to preserve
the set. That is what I was getting
excited about there.
>> Oh, you can't even play VI peacekeeper
anymore because you saved the set
because otherwise you couldn't play it
either.
>> Only into base set is still going strong
at four points. But now Lensq is
threatening a double hold a hidden card.
Eight runes for the next turn. Kingpin
is pushing into that way. That is public
enemy number one right here.
>> Just trading
Alan gives up the way.
>> Gives up the way. But I think you're
farming your opponent as what a two card
hand only has four runes. All of which
are closed now after Fiora coming down.
Alan ZQ weathered the storm. Has turned
the tides here in this game. Now
definitely in the driver's seat.
Is that going to be for Star Cross?
Colin preemptively picking up. I imagine
it would be. I'm surprised that I think
the hidden card is a tie turner that we
haven't seen the tie turner onto the way
to preserve it and then next turn to get
more value. But I just assume that Ellen
doesn't want Colin to get any points.
>> No, Leo, you wouldn't. You wouldn't. The
Vex apathetic. If there's any card you
want when you're trying to stay ahead of
the game, that Vex apathetic. We know
that the vise in hand and Vex says wags
its tail on that one. Says not today.
>> Colin just picked up a potential out of
this scenario. He just found the third
punch first in his deck. That is a card
that Allan is less and less likely to
play around. This is a card that can get
you into those battlefields again. I
think we're almost out of
>> two cards. first mates as well after
they just all got traded away with a big
moonfall turn because otherwise you can
just punch first your Fiora push into
one battlefield and then ready to gank.
I was going to say, yeah, let's Colin
has got above Fiora now. We know that
gets what the shield the ganking keyword
as well.
>> But Allan, he knows he's in an abandoned
hall. He needs to hold once. Has a Vex a
hidden card. Raven Bloom student in
abandoned hall. That is again infinite
might. We have seen how this turned out
before. He could go so far up. But there
is a VIP peacekeeper in hand. There is
another punch first in hand. That is as
many pushes as the deck can have
offensively. It is on Colin now to push
into both of those battlefields. The
thing is if you're pushing the piti for
the double kill into the Raven Bloom
Student, any card would really stop you
there. Any stupify could also boost up
the Raven Bloom Student on the abandoned
hall for a later moment in the turn.
>> Passing priority. It's going to be a big
turn here. Raven Bloom student in
abandoned hall do everything it can to
hold the fort.
Do you even do something here?
>> Yes, you do. 100%.
>> Surely you got the stupify.
>> What is that? That's like a what? A
three might swing. All right. In
abandoned hall with Raven Bloom student.
>> That is really strange. And we are
recycling the runes because this might
be the last turn of the game. So no
reason to keep your rune economy up. And
in the grove of the god Willow, the
>> there's the punch first
>> rises.
Colin needs to do everything he can. Has
no wiggle room. Has no room for failure.
Will need to win this showdown.
>> Two cards in hand. Punch for a punch
first will resolve.
>> So no reaction answer to this punch
first. I mean you wouldn't want to throw
a hard bargain into this anyways. But
>> how much is she now? Total 11.
>> Yeah.
>> Alan has so many runes. is uh -1 plus
isn't it?
>> Oh
>> uh
>> yeah - 55.
>> Okay.
>> I mean I reckon you could just start
with a stack deck in this scenario. Try
to find another spell and just rack up
some might on both battlefields. Keep in
mind you only need to hold one if there
is the vice peacekeeper in hand which we
know it is. Kha'Zix Kha'Zix ambush
>> that will get his plus two boost as
well.
>> So that's a six might swing
>> and some XP
>> and some XP.
I think I haven't had a chance to
consult Colin's hands but I think that
might be
>> Oshiro
can't use VI peacekeeper Vex apathetic
is there? We know that's in hand. We
know and signature spell is the other
card in hand.
So I think unless I'm missing something
that could be this showdown.
>> Even if you're throwing in the VI
peacekeeper here, which can win you that
showdown, the VI peacekeeper is needed
for the growth of the God Willow. There
is no chance that you are conquering in
that other battlefield. Getting that
point back and stopping the hole from
Ellen. Keep in mind, it is not only
about the abandoned hall, but that one
doesn't make it any easier. stack deck
as a combat trick for plus two might
spread amongst units as well.
>> Just gets out of hand that abandoned
hall, doesn't it, for these exact
scenarios,
especially with the Raven Bloom student.
The card has some applications in the
meta.
>> Yeah, has a few niche uses, let's say.
>> Boosting up the Kha'Zix as well. Kha'Zix
in situations like this also is so so
strong. Very valuable to keep around
boosting it up. us.
>> So, keep in mind Vex is on the
battlefield. So, the vice peacekeeper
doesn't even kill anything. It can't
just stun.
>> Just debating whether to use that V.
It's looking like
>> this is time.
>> This is time for what it's worth.
>> Like 14 minutes left. Okay. So, I'm 10.
So, I kill
these two.
So that is going to resolve
Raven Bloom student and Vex apathetic.
Is that legend ability? We use our
signature spell now though.
>> That is true. That is true.
Showstopper
abusing one of those strong units that
have been buffed before.
And then since Vex Apathetic is gone
now,
>> the VIP peacekeeper can push
>> gets his buff as well. So, we'll get his
keywords back.
>> Oh, you have no mana for V.
>> Actually, it's you have one floating.
>> I have two floating.
>> Okay.
>> Um,
>> it's 10 again.
>> Uh, 11
>> because of abandoned hall.
>> No, you were on a bundle hole when you
casted Sher. It's
>> the same thing as right the wind.
>> Oh,
>> it's
>> Oh, that's a fair point. Okay.
>> Uh, Kazix trigger.
>> Yep. And showstopper resolved. After it
resolves, the Fiora is at the abandoned
hall. gets a plus one
>> from abandoned hall.
>> One rune open for Allan for what it's
worth.
>> Don't think he has anything to play.
>> I don't think so either. He's a lot of
resources on the previous showdown.
>> Is Colin winning this?
>> Ty Turner.
>> Wait.
>> Oh, and I think that Ty Turner was
enough.
>> Mhm. Tide corner made them trade.
Doesn't win him the game automatically,
but it also doesn't really lose it for
Allen because now only one conquer point
for Colin. He's now at five, not at six.
>> Singularity is in hand now. So you can
just clear both of these away. Yeah,
there it is. Right on Q. The reverse
board wipe again from Allen. The big
singularity. Get a unit down there. Oh
no, Leo.
>> That merchant is threatening so much.
It's threatening a whole point. Colin is
now sitting on a top deck. does not find
a unit to play
>> seven to five.
>> The singularity by the way is entreion
the concession of Colin.
>> Fantastic game there from Alan.
>> I'm winning on the because of the it's
my last turn and then I can finish the
game anyway. I see
>> Alan able to pull off the reverse. I did
say after game one anyone can win a game
two in a game three. Allen is high up on
that list weathering the set storm as it
were going to that 90
record. But I didn't know set had it in
him like that. That was really insane.
The comebacks from this one. The Fiora.
Didn't think that the might from the
Titaner would make the big difference
pushing this Fiora to a trade. If that
Fiora hung on in that battlefield. Wow.
So super well played by Allen's EQ
knowing that if there is a showstopper,
I want to have this Kha'Zix around. My
opponent is going to have to trade away
the Vex because otherwise the V that was
public knowledge couldn't be played for
any effect basically.
And that that was so so interesting how
he just kept the Kha'Zix around, buffed
it up a little bit and then that
precision marvelous
>> it was. And this was our game one,
right? No, it's our game two I should
say. Game one was so interesting. So
this the set was just super off to the
races. In game two though, you know,
Singularity was coming down. Really just
evened it up. And this game three was
very interesting. Yeah. Who would have
thought at the end after that big long
showdown exchange at the abandoned hall,
it would be the tie turner of all things
that would even it up. Expending so many
resources from both players. And then
Alanu as soon as the the the the the
bottom battlefield conquest at the grove
all he had to do was just singularity
out put down a two drop and after Colin
expended so many resources there's that
singularity I just mentioned and then
the two drop came down and that's all
needed to close that game three out.
That is something to note for Udiana
players out there. Allen won both of
those games, keeping the singularity up
until the very last turn. So, always
after this big heavy fight for resources
in those games, after using all of those
combat tricks, abusing the abandoned
hall in game three as well, he found his
way to the singularity that then took
the last units from his opponent to
close out the games. I mean, in one
game, he just conquered for the victory
point, but in the other one, he took
everything away and then started
redeveloping when Colin had no chance
after keeping up the tempo the entire
game. It was absolute masterclass. So,
let's kick it down for our winners
interview with Allan and Barrett.
>> Thank you so much for that excellent
cast of two titans of our game. Not only
finding that singularity, closing out,
but in a close fashion. Allen ZQ,
welcome back to the chairs that I feel
like you're so familiar with at this
point. That was an incredible match
against two Titans to start off your day
two, but it's got to feel pretty good
probably locking in that win against
Colin specifically because he has to
continue out with today and of course
with four more rounds. How are you
feeling?
>> Amazing. Thank you for having me again
here, Barrett. Uh the games, game one,
game two was pretty much one-sided. Game
one for the Colin, I drew too much
bounces and uh I missed my Diana
trigger, so I just didn't have enough
value to play the game. had to try to
tempo and that just was catastrophic
when he could uh draw multiple cards.
So, it was just scoop. Game two, I
pretty much happened to me exactly what
happened to him last uh game. And then
game three was the one that was a very
exciting uh to play and a lot of math uh
with the abanon hole. I did misplay
heavily with Fizz. I forgot. Uh I meant
to do Moonfall, but I already when I
announced Starcross instead of Moonfall,
he already said, "Okay, I'm I cannot
take it back." So it's uh on Fiora was
this big combat where I can clear Fiora
and I can't lose from there. Uh I star
cross Moonfall which was just like
pretty much like I was thinking about
the next 10 star cross and I wanted to
moonfall this turn and just uh yeah
bumbles myself but overall a great great
uh last game. I think that the the last
one is worth highlighting because game
one game two was pretty much just like
one versus one-sided. No, and even
still, I'm glad we can have it those
highlights for those game threes because
the fact that, you know, I'm waiting
here on turn four for each of you and no
one's got a victory point yet. You know,
I'm watching you both, you know, set up
yourself but remove each other's stuff
and then, you know, you get the hoe set
up early, get all that card draw. We're
getting rid of these spells early on to
just get the extra card advantage like
you said when game one and two was that
sort of key to success for each of the
respective players. But then in game
three, finding a way back in as Colin,
you know, claws, removes each of these
units, makes the strategic plays. It's
that is to me the peak riftbound and
players like you and Colin are so
excellently showcase that. So, I mean,
you got four more rounds to go, Allan.
You're currently still undefeated. There
was only a couple of y'all coming into
today. Is there maybe someone I mean,
I'm excited to potentially hopefully see
maybe you have to go against, you know,
Pedro or Squirtle, one of our our
reigning European other regional
qualifier champion. That's something
that's on my radar that I would love to
see. So, but going in for the rest of
the tournament. Obviously, I I can I
can't really ask you if you're afraid of
anything cuz I feel like you're not
really,
you know, fearing any sort of matchup,
but is there a player maybe that you're
still trying to look out for that you
don't want to go against?
>> I mean, not so much of a player, but
like I was feeling a bit uh heavy on the
stomach going into the early runs. It
was more due to the what I ate
yesterday, but once I started playing it
completely go away. It's crazy. and
wonderful how mind can just shut down
any issues with the body and just focus
on the game play where it's actually you
just cure yourself you just heal
meanwhile playing and you just forget
the about the issue that there was
before the game but going forward I'm
looking forward to just playing there's
so many strong players coming from the
other regionals and I consider Europe
being the strongest region given that
not everybody travel across the sea uh
like I do and from competing across all
the regions uh I feel like Europe
definitely He has the strongest foot.
>> I have heard from multiple people that
this may be the most rigorous regional
qualifier yet and I feel it in this room
as well as I think everyone is leveling
each other up in Riftbound. Thank Allan.
Thank you so much and congrats again on
your win. Moving on still X and O but
we've got a round 10 and more to come.
We'll send it back.
>> Thank you so much for that Barrett. It's
always great. It's always awesome to
hear from one of the greats of our game,
Alan ZQ, and his thought process going
through. But actually, Barrett, we we
got a little bit more of round nine to
come. We're not going straight into
round 10. We can hop straight into our
feature match B where we're going to get
the last seven minutes where we have
Volibear versus Draven. And whoa, that
is a board state from the Volibear.
>> Play my Nus again. But also quite the B
state from
>> HXN loon sitting on a huge Draven
showboat that is with the 10mite over 10
points running away but it's an Aurora
deck. It's tough to run away in points
versus Aurora.
>> That is going to be
>> tough to stop though. Let's see what
Villionaire can do here to
>> No Elder Dragon developed for what it's
worth. So,
we're going to start a turn off with a
sabotage.
>> Uh, Star Quest is a target there. Or
rebuke.
>> That's a good sabotage, though.
>> It's a very good sabotage.
>> Taking out one of those cards. Lon with
really nice rune management as well,
leaving up five runes, especially after
developing to keep up those two cards.
Now, after the sabotage,
>> then I'm just going to
>> Would have wished to have played all of
those units in there as well, but then
you couldn't have cast the rebuke. So,
>> still absolutely golden. in that
scenario
>> and hopefully
>> this is interesting. I must say first of
all is a deck I play so I'm very excited
I get to see this but then only one
point away from Lon Villionaire needs to
actually do something about this I'm
trying to see what
>> do we have elder dragon plus skys
spplitter would no you got quite a few
units there actually what options do we
have here
>> I think he has quite a few oh get
excited that's what we're doing here
>> going
>> yes bottom of deck
>> oh I but I didn't
I did. It's another one.
>> That's the one she played last turn.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Going to discard a card. Targeting the
Draven. Okay. Deal 12.
>> Targeting something. Discarding
>> the elder dragon to kill that Draven
showboat that was at 10 might. So that's
I would say fairly good tradeoff. And
now we start with the first challenge.
Volibear so incredibly set up already.
>> 9 to seven. Yes,
>> that is going to take care of Kaiser.
>> And the axe back to base.
>> Spinning axe goes back to base. Now,
what other options do we have? Two more
units to get rid of there.
I think I saw a star fall in the hand,
actually.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. I can see that there's another
challenge. Challenge obviously a lot
less well less costly.
>> And just remove those threat. Well,
moves one of those threats. Then you can
star the last one.
>> That is an easy clear.
>> There we go. This is exactly what you
needed to do though. By the way, if
you're Lon, I'm thinking, "Oh, come on."
Can something just stick? And no,
there's going to be the falling star
clearing off that battlefield. And we
still have the Aurora at the end of this
turn as well.
>> It's funny to see an Aurora deck with so
many different units now going out of
the paper tree a little bit. Not too
much though. Trying still a little bit
afraid of being ran out of both
battlefields all of a sudden.
>> Elder dragon. Oh, it's going to be that
dragon. All right, there. The gentle
gemstone. It reduces when you play
another dragon, you can ready two of
your runes. And that stacks, by the way,
so if you have like two or three of
those, you could end your turn with like
six runes open when you play dragons.
But the end of the day right now, eight
cost, eight bite is over to Lon now
at seven points.
What can we do? always a bit dangerous,
but I mean in this situation it looks
like it is one of those games where
Aurora has completely taken over
>> in base with two big units having the
paper tree filled up to the brim with
huge defenders having four runes open.
This is almost impossible to get through
for Draven has a really really tough
time against Aurora now trying to just
grasp for this last point. really hoping
>> and I hit it.
>> Maybe that hidden card can change
something. Currently at seven might in
target.
>> We know the rebuke in hand.
>> That is going to be helpful. And I don't
think we know the last card because
there was a draw for turn and of course
a draw for the seven.
>> I already had you drawish point.
>> Oh, okay. Hold two five. My bad. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Well, we did draw the Carrian there.
That would let you draw a ton of cards
if you to put that in play. draw one for
each mighty card you have in play and
then you'd ready up two of your runes
cuz your gentle gemstone your your
gentle gemstone dragon as well. and a
hidden.
>> Wonder if there's an argument for
billionaire last time moving back more
units though just you can just charge
them in currently what 14 might with the
gemstone dragon and the ren. It's not
bad to be fair is it?
>> I think that is actually a lot of might.
That might also be another ranga trophy
hunter in hand.
>> Okay, that makes sense. Here we go. So
they're charging in. What is this hidden
card then?
I would assume perhaps they through,
>> but we're going to see the rebuke first.
>> This guy
>> taking two of those runes to get this
card away from B.
>> I also didn't know the name.
>> Oh, there you go. There's the Rengar as
you rightfully said that trophy hunter.
>> Oh, that the Rengar will win it. And
Villionaire, the Volibear player, my
hero, will win our feature match B here
in round nine. doing it with probably
one of the scariest BS I've seen all
weekend. There was a ton of might there.
>> Yeah, I like the way Volbear plays
Aurora. I will not lie because some of
the Aurora decks just play like four
units. It's Elder Dragon every turn. You
don't know what you're getting. This
deck actually plays a little bit more
with your opponent. You have Renga
trophy hunter. You have those mid-range
unit like the first forunner. None of
these units are completely gamechanging
when you hit them off of Aurora, but
they're also not dead in hand, right?
You can just drop them occasionally. you
can play a little bit more with your
opponent then you have skysplitter cards
that interact a little bit more. So I
think
>> volbear is the coolest Aurora deck
because it utilizes Aurora is just like
an add-on to your volar strategy you
know. Yeah, I love playing Volar. It's a
deck I play the most of and it's just so
much fun as you say. So many options.
You got a carrian to draw cards for us
for runner as well. But how about we
don't want to hear from this mediocre
Volibear player. Let's hear from
Billionaire who just won our feature
match for our winners interview.
Barry here joined with our other feature
match winner C challenger TCG
villionaire the Mr. Volibar himself as
you have locked in your fourth bear now
but fifth best of overall. How does it
feel not only to have that best of
basically already locked in today but
you're actually now because of this win
still X in one you're in top cut
contention as well with only four more
Switch rounds to go. How do you feel
right now man?
>> Uh it's feeling great. I mean I love
Bola Bear so much. I got in the same
position in Sydney but um man I just
bombed day two. I played sold out.
Obviously, he got all the way to the
finals. I played him like round one in
Sydney, so wasn't great. But, I mean, I
had I locked my bear at that event, so
that was cool. But, you know, it's it's
definitely been uh like in the back of
my mind of like, yeah, I could be the
first bear to ever make Top Cut. I'm
pretty sure it's never made Top Cut in a
China event. Definitely never in an NA
or or Western event. So, um yeah, I
mean, it's exciting. Um I would really
love to I need to win the next three and
draw my last round, and I I could do it.
>> You definitely could. And it it it's so
exciting to think about that because it
I I just always continue to bring up
these storylines of these people that
become so specialized with the deck. I
mean, I I'm literally backstage talking
with my people and like in game one, you
know, uh I I don't know if we get to see
it on stream, but in game one, it's like
the point values go all the way to your
opponent and you come back because
that's just what the deck does. You
know, the limitations. You have been
playing this deck now for months and
months and months. you know, you already
have your championship invite from back
when you played Master Ye, of course, in
Las Vegas. So, like you're you're very
much like aiming for these best ofs and
with Hartford coming up, you know, I
would assume you're still going to
probably play the bear there to try and
maybe steal that last one as well.
>> Yeah, that's going to be um the the last
event where we can get set one best from
my current understanding at least. So, I
would like to just get the last bear. Uh
do the five for five. That would be
really awesome. But yeah, more than
anything, it would it would mean the
world to me to make Top Cut with the
bear.
>> My last question is because I have to
ask you as a as a herald of, you know,
the the Stormbringer.
>> Yes.
>> How many people like look up to you or
message you and ask for advice because I
I think of these legends from Origins
that are maybe like not seeing as much
play anymore, but the deck is still
powerful. You know, Aurora is obviously
very strong, but it's not the only way
to play the game. And there must be
people out there that are probably like
looking and messaging you and asking you
like, "How do I do such a thing?" So, is
there any advice that you could give to
the players out there that want to just
play their favorite deck and then can be
just like you making day two, taking
home multiple best of like what do you
think is the best piece of advice you
would give?
>> Yeah, I think like actually specializing
is really important in this game. We
have currently in the current format we
have 40 legends that's only going to
keep expanding. So like the and because
of the best of system, like it is a
jungle meta. Like you just do not know
what you're going to play against. So
you need to just know the ins and outs
of your deck. And if you're picking a
deck like Volibar or say for instance my
teammate Colin on set, uh a big
advantage is also just that people
haven't really played against these
decks. So when you're playing these off
meta picks, you know what you're doing,
you know what your game plan is, but
your opponents often do not. So, if you
just put the time in and you really
understand your deck, uh I think that
you could take it really far. I would
say um like you mentioned earlier, I got
a a Master Yi to the first question. Uh
I did get a Master Yi in Vegas. That was
my very first best of and I was playing
Aurora Yi, which was like not very
common back then. Um and I did get a
little bit of attention for that. I
mean, people loved the sand soldier tech
and stuff, but it it I would definitely
say when I started performing on
Volibar, I got way more attention. And I
mean, you know, this this legend was
very underrepresented. And honestly, the
list when I started seeing the original
best of, no offense to the the people
out there, but I thought I could
optimize these lists way better. I
really understand Aurora, I've been
playing it since set one. Uh my teammate
Daniel, who got all the way to the
finals, was on my Aurora Ye list that I
put him on and in the very first
regional at Houston. And so, I've just
been playing Aurora decks for a really
long time. But I don't really like the
Aurora decks like Civer where like
you're all in on Aurora. If you don't
see the Aurora, you're just your deck
just dies. Volibar and Yei were really
good at playing without it. You don't
even need to see it. Volibar, I'd say,
is even way way better at playing
without it. If you just curve like
Rengar into Forerunner into Kadrian,
draw three cards ramping every single
time you're playing these guys. Like
that's just a really strong curve. Not a
lot of decks can deal with that much
might. And Ferrer is still a monster
even with Star Cross running around. So
yeah, I would say just lock in on your
favorite guy and uh really just
understand what your game plan is into
the rest of the field, but just know
that like you're not always just going
to play meta. You could play against
anything. So just specialize on your
thing. Special specialization is key and
practice makes perfect just as you have
perfected the art of the bear and volar
I think is not going anywhere at least
when I think of you specifically
billionaire. So thank you so much.
Congratulations on your win here and
good luck with the rest of the four
rounds that you have. But we're going to
send it back.
>> Welcome back and to quick decks here at
the Riftbound RQ in the format where
players have 30 seconds of time to tell
me what their deck does. Next to me is
Nexus. Why did you choose your deck and
what did you choose to play? I chose to
play Kha'Zix, the best buck in the whole
game. He's awesome and I play him
because he his play style is very
unique. I love it.
>> All right. Very unique play style. We
like to hear that. You have 30 seconds.
Are you ready?
>> Sure.
>> Always.
>> Go. So, first of all, we have our
signature ability. It's basically a
charm that we can use and it's a ride
the wind. It's one of the most broken
cards in the whole game. I have only 30
seconds, right? Okay, we got to go fast.
Irresistible faith. It's a two drop.
That's basically a charm. It's really,
really good. Uh you can oppress your
opponent really good with it. And that's
the whole ability with Kha'Zix. And I've
almost forgotten his legend ability. It
makes you uh capable of moving your
unit, your exhausted unit back to the
base and it's also capable of buffing.
So, and we are done. Thank you so much.
So, to summarize this, everything in
your deck charms and you're taking away
the main strategy of your opponent by
just pushing everything into your
battlefields,
>> right? Exactly. Uh 30 seconds were
really quick. All right. Thank you so
much, Nick. Yep. That's how Kha'Zix
does. It just lurs you in, gets you
singled out, and then wins the game
versus you. Thank you so much. We're
going back to the broadcast with haste.
>> Thank you very much, Leonard. As we
close in on round 10 for RQ, Utract
James and Bandit here to take you
through the action. And in some players
minds, you might think we have a treat
for you. And in other players minds, you
might go, "Ooh, I've been trying to
avoid this deck all week long." Uh, I
think our matchup will feature the
infinite lux loop. So, we'll walk you
through what that means. If you're not
paying attention, if you're not
terminally online like us, we'll get you
through the action
>> here. When they say that somebody is
cooking,
>> right? Oh, it's a little spicy. Looplux
is higher gastronomy.
>> And you It is an acquired taste.
>> It It certainly is. Are we cooking with
lasers? I've heard that.
>> No, no, no, no. It's It's foam.
Everything is foam.
>> Everything's foam. Okay. Uh so we'll get
into it um as we progress to to peel
back the curtain a little bit. We were
like, let's see if any make it because
it has been the boogeyman of the weekend
where people are like, oh, how many
people are going to be playing the
infinite loop lux um quite frankly don't
know that that we've had enough time
really to refine the deck for most
players. So we were saying, hey, we only
saw it for the first time last week in
in China. Now people have had a little
bit of time. So if any make day two and
start looking like they might actually
progress towards top 64 and top eight,
we will pick it up uh and take a look.
And that is the moment that we find
ourselves in as of course round 10 means
we are determining our undefeated
players, our top eight players. So um
Bandit, do you want to give us the the
like one line on the infinite lux loop
as we take a look in a moment? In fact,
you know what? Let's wait for the the
deck list. Ah, I'm actually really
surprised and happy to see a player I
know as well, Pentastag from Rift Labs.
Uh, one of Jib's teammates. We had Jibs
yesterday. Pentag up on stage now for a
feature match too.
>> Once again, and we've already been
impressed before by those who are more
well acquainted with Jim. So, is that
are you directly influencing them or do
they have a good role model? What's the
deal there?
>> It's actually a surprise right now for
me, which is nice. Uh, as at some point
>> Nice. No, I I I mean a surprise that I
didn't I didn't know we were getting uh
getting this on stage. Oh, I see a new
card. I see Fura in my list.
>> Yeah, I think we may I talking about
Lux, I think we may end up seeing that
perhaps as a a later match up. This is a
master, of course, um that we're looking
at. I I'll just get confirmation exactly
of the match up that we're going into
yet, but as you said, uh Fiora
in this deck list, not something that we
see very often. No, it's it's the it's
the one spice. There's a main deck
disarming rake for all that that gear
hate that you want to push through. And
in general, not too many things. I think
the one outlier here is the rune split
and the fact that they are running in
fact zon warren where usually uh arena's
greatest or something of the like would
have taken the preference. Now very
important that you have to keep your eye
on. We are playing overnumbered puros
that pleases me. Now, I will say that is
all good to keep in mind, but we're in a
moment where I'm like, this is the the
one time where I'm like, I do know the
player on stage and that's not their
username and I know that they're not
playing Lux. So, I think we need to
we're keeping it easy.
>> We may come back around and revisit
that. So, we we we were talking about
the Lux. So, I if you mind me don't mind
me jumping in as we as we make sure that
we're in the right place. So the way
that the infinite lux uh archetype works
is essentially you're trying to create a
game state where you can produce at
least two and if not three loops of
infinite creation. First of all you end
up creating uh infinite energy. Then you
create infinite power with a lot of
recruit tokens. And then eventually one
of the ways of winning the game uh is
with Ranata Glass the the one that taps
to score a point. And the way your hand
and deck is set up is like you can
continue to replay it, score a point,
replay it again, score a point, and it
comes in ready and you win the game.
Basically,
>> exactly. One shot, one shot, you win the
game. I will say players have been
cooking, looking for other ways of
winning, and we'll jump into that when
we do end up seeing the deck list
because uh there's there's a couple of
tricky little ways. So, that's the
really quick way of telling you how it
works.
>> Yeah. Uh, ironically, unlike the Lux
deck itself, which is not quick at all.
No, no, it it is a little bit solitary
where you're like, I just need to draw
through my entire deck in the first
three turns
>> and you need to be it's very fragile in
in the sense of if you you need to
establish the loop first and if you fail
to do so, right, that is the way your
opponent can now kind of have to punish
you. Yeah. Be like, all right, are you
really going through all the steps in
the right way? And is there any moment
for me to gunk up the gear? So,
>> yeah. and there's minimal interaction in
the early game. So, a lot of people
wonder, can you go quicker than it and
come out ahead? There are a few
different tools that people have been,
you know, hypothesizing on ways to deal
with it. If you're in purple, you can
play invert timelines, for instance.
Like, that's a way that it comes out.
So, it's it's not it's not um it's not
unstoppable. It's not the the point
where it's like, hey, you have to worry
about this and everybody's going to be
playing this deck because there's quite
a window in the first few turns where
the the deck just says, yeah, I I just
I'm drawing cards. That's all I'm doing.
All I'm doing is I draw cards. I play
cards that just fill my hand and then
suddenly, okay, cool. Now I can do the
thing on like turn four or turn five.
>> And there is that momentum that it
carried with us where it really became
very notorious in a very short timeline
where people were like, oh, should I be
main decking interaction for this
potential matchup?
>> I'm going to tell you straight up no.
>> But that that is the the emotion that
runs wild, right? because it was
everything that everyone was talking
about. Have you seen the Lux Infinite?
Have you seen the Lux Infinite?
>> So, does that take into account the fact
that we do have 2,000 players? Well, for
day two, it's around 300
>> that are still remaining. The decks the
the matches are only going to get harder
with players that are more savvy.
>> Yeah, that's fair. And I think the
counterpart to that though is that any
player that has made it this far is now
very refined with the loop. Um, one of
the other things at competitive level
that people that maybe have been trying
this deck at home, uh, if you, as I
said, if you're terminally online, um,
you may not quite be familiar with the
idea of presenting a loop because you
actually don't have to play the loop out
at a competitive level. You
>> have to establish it.
>> Exactly. You establish it and you
clarify with your opponent like, hey,
this loop will end at this point. Like,
this is the the moment at which I will
win the game. Uh, and we we're not going
to force you to go through the motions
of every single thing to end up winning
the game. just have to present the loop
and then present your win condition. And
at this stage, everybody knows once you
season the loop, you're like, "Yeah,
cool. That's fine. Let's go to the next
game."
>> It's part one. It's Yeah, it's part one.
Getting the loop is uh another factor.
We'll talk about exactly the way that it
works uh as we go into the game. I see a
players are drawing their opening hands
and mulligan. So, we may end up um going
directly into the action
as I I'm I'm tentatively excited about
this as yeah, we're in to the game. San
on the Lux against Pensag on the Masti.
Uh Yei does have a decent amount of
early game tempo. It's like you want to
see a two drop, you want to see it get
out onto the board. And this is why I
really like San's battlefield selection
by running the paper tree that that
ramps both of you up. You both get to uh
channel a rune when you when you hold
it. Really goes for it.
>> And all right. Do you want to score
early points? Well, that will mean
you're ramping me up as well.
>> So, of course, has access to like color
week and and that type of of thing as uh
I'm interested now to see which version
of the Lux deck this is cuz I have seen
a couple players in here. So, we'll find
another two drop as Pentag Oh, even
finds another early unit. So, this is
one of the ways that you can go under
the loop and uh and really talk about
it. So, I want to take a moment, if you
don't mind, Bandit, of introducing the
the main cards that we're watching for
in the Lux uh loop. So, you're obviously
looking for forge of the future as the
first big key part. You essentially need
a forge of the future in the trash and
then you need a second one in hand and
one is in hand. the other card. The next
card sacrifice is a really important way
of not only drawing your way through the
deck, but allows you to establish things
back uh into hand. You're essentially
getting all the way through your deck
and refilling your hand to get this very
specific cards. Shadows,
>> most importantly, very you can't really
react to it.
>> Yes, exactly. It's very quick. Shadows
call is the next one. It's going to
allow you to again draw more cards and
also that temporary trigger is going to
allow you when uh units end up dying,
you're able to to get a little bit more
from doing everything within one turn.
And then the last one on top of that as
I am going through my notes, it is echo
of course is the last part because you
need to be able to untap all of your
runes, get your your energy back and
just keep looping cuz in Riftbound if
you run out of energy, you basically run
out of the ability to do things. So
those are the cards that we're looking
to establish in hand. And there is a
very specific board state later on that
we will look for. Sabotage on the
progress day could very well be one of
the things which as it's not one of the
cards I talked about seems strange but
you have to be able to loop the cards I
was talking about which means you need
no other cards really in your deck other
than one or two just so that you don't
end up drawing your deck out
>> and because once you do and you start
you keep continue to draw cards you're
just donating points to your opponent
>> and importantly your deck would then get
your trash shuffled into your deck and
you can't continue the loop.
>> Exactly. So you re That's why you really
have to prioritize the forge of the
future because that makes it so you can
select which cards are going back in
your deck.
>> Oh play.
>> Yes, exactly that. So
>> apologies
>> if it happens, which I will say having a
progress day now put to the bottom of
the deck does make the ability for the
Lux to to play as quickly as you'd like.
It makes it really quite tricky,
>> but Yei is just going to be happy to
tick the points up, keep going, keep
moving forward. um and keep the pressure
on San.
>> So what you have to prioritize on the
Luxe is it's all about you. It's all
about how you manage the early game with
your resources. So investing an early
calling the week to slow down your
opponent. You really have to ponder
that. Make sure that all right, how many
victory points would he gain from having
that one turn earlier and mle over your
options like that. So the card sharp
here,
>> single sleeve,
>> introducing more and more gold,
safeguarding your runes available to you
are key pieces for the early game to
kind of make sure you are reaching that
9 to 12 rune power spike. I'm going to
call it. Yeah, of course. Which then
turns into infinite energy power spike.
Because essentially the way that the
infinite part comes through is every
time you're trading like one recycle
with the fact that you're going to end
up channeling a rune like that that that
kind of turnound ends up being
important. So every single time you're
just neutral on those resources but
getting a recruit token for it and just
generating constant recycle recycle
recycle lots of power into lots of
energy sorry energy into power then into
uh one of the ways out is a Ronaldo
glass. There are a couple other win
conditions that if we see them I'll talk
about them. So, it's all about getting
to that point
>> and managing your gold will mean we're
going to reach that a little bit faster.
Now,
>> it's up to the Ye to already mount the
pressure and we are sitting scoring both
of the battlefields as quickly as we
possibly can. Now, it is a a little bit
tricky to start leaving battlefields
open cuz in the loop that is what they
need also. Yeah. Yeah, that is true. Is
this is the first time we're getting it
on a featured match, so I'm interested
to see uh the way through. So, sprite
burst is another card that can of course
be a way out. It is another way of
ending the loop uh by creating infinite
units and just kind of like saying pass.
One of the other ways that people have
been playing it uh is around hand
disruption as well of saying like, hey,
if I can just take all the cards out of
your hand infinite times with the likes
of Ash. That is a way uh to just say I'm
I'm going to pass and I'm going to say I
have 3,000 tokens on board and I will
just do it again the next turn and then
do a lot of temporary triggers.
>> H it is. But you can do it every turn.
You can just keep going. Just go again.
Go again. So from the yeast point of
view, you're going into this matchup.
a matchup that you might have practiced
here and there, but it's it's not your
Diana matchup.
>> No, it's it's not the the Ye mirror
which you have grinded till oblivion.
>> Keeping your head cool. What are the
keys that you are looking out for? The
key cards for a Ye to really ramp up
that tempo, not give a moment's rest to
his opponent. I mean, uh the sabotage
has to be one of them in the moment that
we've seen already. uh just destroying
the the hand draw as as much as uh the
hand size and the ability to draw as
much as possible. Um this is quite a
stacked battlefield. So you can see that
San is having to to scrap for this. Um I
have to feel like San probably hit a
couple of Yees on the way here as well.
So the amount of Yees that are in the
room, you have to feel like probably it
feels okay in this match. I think
outside of that, the Lux isn't a deck
that really wants to fight you very
much. So, I think there's a lot of
things like the uh the pump spells, that
type of thing. That probably I will say
we haven't had enough time to to be
totally experts on on this, but I feel
like you probably don't care too much of
your lux about like ye having things
like discipline in hand or or you know,
anything like a punch first. You're
probably not in most situations unless
you're only slowing the down like in
this scenario. You probably don't mind
too too much.
>> Not really. Lux is really in in this
iteration a deck that
>> walks to the beat of her own drum,
>> I believe,
>> and will be
>> trying to maintain that throughout the
entirety.
>> Maybe not.
>> I'm going to send in
two and I'll play
on guard to give it plus two.
Pence are just trying to go through the
battlefield.
>> I have to pay for the unguard. There we
go. I saw one rune ded. I was confused.
Uh, pass action.
>> Sure.
>> Uh, let's kill your car shop and scout,
please.
>> Yep. Just clearing out the permanent
units so that the temporary ones will
end up falling at the beginning of the
next turn.
>> Is there an argument to be made here?
>> Cool. to let you kind of want to score
as much as you can.
>> But when they can reconquer it, that
means that is another card they're
seeing. It is very minor, but that is
the the the scale of skill expression
where you have to keep in mind is that
one extra card really going to bring it
all down.
>> It's a good question and it this some
map is a card that I opened so many from
this set. Uh and I was like, ah, I'm not
going to play that card. Now I might end
up playing that card. Uh but it's it's
one of the many tools that San uh has in
order to continue to draw. So
>> an echo
>> two sabotages
>> and now is a very critical moment
because Lux is not at terminal velocity
>> and far from it to be totally fair.
>> Yei is starting to threaten game one
when he gets the turn back from SA.
So, Rally the Troops goes
as uh that is one of the parts necessary
later on. I mean, this deck once you do
get to the end of your deck, you're
like, I've drawn everything I need.
>> And and that is that point. It can get
out of hand so quickly.
>> And then
>> when you leave the Lux to be
>> hit rookie and I'll buff my master
and I will end turn there. No cards in
hand. You're up
>> to six. I feel like San
has so too much work to do at this point
with two sacrifices in hand. Uh six
points for Pentag already. This is one
of the problems with this Lux uh loop
decks is if you can't
draw your entire deck,
it's really hard to establish the loop.
You you relying on cards. I didn't see
the top deck, but I'm seeing ruination
in the bottom right.
>> Yeah, they're dirty.
>> It did get drawn. There's no such thing
as a little bit infinite in
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. The ruination being
drawn into hand is uh
>> pretty important here. Sacrifice is
going to end up taking out the echo give
card draw plus also of course ready the
rest of the the runes. So has Sanan
drawn the option just in the nick of
time with that ruination
>> everything before these results. You
really have to you really have to to
>> cuz the win is on the board currently
>> okay.
>> Yeah.
One of the
>> first real board wipes
that hits everything uh in is ruination
>> stify over there minus one might
>> needs a target in order to to stupify.
So doing it now before the ruination is
played.
3 6
>> one and two.
>> Not even waiting for a response.
>> Defeated. All right. There they all go.
Yeah. I mean, no chance there's a wind
wall in the in the main deck for for
Pentis Stag. So, that is getting uh
taken completely. So, Sanan, is that
enough? Is that enough? Because I
haven't seen Pentis hand in a little
while. Two quick units would keep the
game in Pentag,
but it's going to be another sacrifice
on the Echo.
And this is how the snowball starts
rolling.
>> Now we are not looping just yet.
>> No. So the the we are burning through
our cards right now.
>> If we cannot stabilize kind of like uh
nuclear fishision, right? Where the
>> where the explosion keeps itself going.
Yeah,
>> it's a forge. It's a race to the bottom
right now
>> into one draw. I saw the other one was
singularity that came out. So that's not
what you want at this stage. You need to
keep drawing.
This point might be helpful next turn
>> this four.
>> Sure.
>> Sacrifice two uh shadow call
shadow and this for watch. Okay. So,
those are some of the important points
of the combo. And there is still a forge
of the future in the trash, which is
necessary because of course, one now
goes to it. Uh, you need to be able to
loop them. One one recycles the other,
which recycles the first one when you
draw it again and play. Exactly. That's
that's one of the key parts of the loop
is you need that one there.
>> Making sure they're the the right way
around. We'll when two sacrifices come
out, we'll know that we're at the bottom
of the deck regardless. But uh diligence
in play is uh
>> pass.
>> Oh, that is not what you want.
>> But that does reek of Rengar. This reeks
of Rengar from a mile away.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. Sprite burst.
>> But we know there's also a singularity
in hand for San. So this could end up
being if you move to the battlefield, is
it just a bait?
Oh, I mean if there's a price defender
there at they're at eight, right?
>> But then uh you are just fine losing
your unit and you just say, "Okay, I'm
going to singularity you after the the
combat, right?" So you're just like,
"Hey, I want to bait the the unit out of
your hands so you don't have it for for
any time." And this is the the the
moment where it can get a little harder
to deal with it because Ye hasn't been
spending the combat tricks at any point
in the game. You can only assume that
that hand is filled to the brim with
steroids. Uh, I mean at this point it
looked like it was so good for Pent, but
San drawing that ruination at the right
time.
>> Um,
thinking about it.
So, this really kind of highlights the
dire straits that Pentag is in cuz I
believe it's his turn currently.
>> It is. It is. We are in Pentag's
priority in Pentag's turn and clearly
did not draw an option that is viable at
this point. Pass.
>> It really felt like the Rengar,
>> but he's not just he's not getting
there. No discipline's coming out either
to see more cards.
>> The the problem is you you know San has
seen so many cards since. So playing a
Rengar to base is going to get killed.
You've already seen a color weak. You
know that there's things Oh, and a
progress day is going to be enough.
to draw more of the deck is just going
to finally resolve. There's a ruination.
Wow. That ruination top deck for San.
The perfect time to absolutely turn this
game around. New players might say,
"Hey, six points to one point." Like
this looks so favored for Yei. And maybe
there's a a narrow narrow window to
sneak through, but look at how much
control San has on the turn where you
sacrifice again. And we know that the
sacrifices have been put back into the
deck. So San suddenly now has drawn like
10 cards since we thought it was a dire
situation and this is that terminal
velocity that we talked about where it
is
>> really close to self sustaining and
where they just keep drawing the answers
even if they're not looping just yet.
They can efficiently address any threats
that are coming out whilst giving
minimal openings for the ye to take
advantage of.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. I'm interested to see
the end of the loop main board for this
deck
because I I think it's just a board
state that says I have
>> a crazy number of tokens and I'm going
to pass to you and they're on a
battlefield and you can't do anything
about it and then the next turn I'm
going to do it again and then the next
turn I'm going to do it again. And when
I say crazy, when you when you define a
loop,
>> generally players will say, "Yeah, I'll
make a thousand or or like however many.
It doesn't matter. You'll make infinite.
You'll make infinite." But you have to
basically like
>> define a number of like, "Hey, this is
how many I can make."
>> And I know you can't beat that.
>> And you know, there have been there have
been moments where a lack of
>> imagination
>> have cost the players the game. So don't
be humble and say, "Oh, I'll do 100."
No, no, no. Please go for the 4 million.
um into the Rengar takes out the card
shop. If there was a way to get to the
other battlefield, there's going to be a
Zorn Warren draw discard. Is there
anything
>> um and trigger the Zorn Warren
discarding my primal
>> discard draw? Apologies in that order.
Is there anything
>> that can take one power to hide a card
and end my turn?
>> Okay, so Zas
Zas will save
the Rengar once,
>> but we've seen Sanan having multiple
options. Color week, if it's in hand,
which I I'm assuming it will be, eats
the scuttle crab if if you use it first.
There's a ruination ruination in hand.
>> Call the week in hand, but you need to
be able to so you can singularity call
the week is is the way to clear the
board. And you look at the number of
cards in hand. You're you're
>> like that that is your problem right
there. The options available right now
are staggering. And even if only 20% of
the cards in hand are not direct combo
related, that's still got to be five to
six options available to you.
>> Yeah. And now it's just a case of of of
looping into the the end state of of the
game for San can't quite see how many
cards are left in deck. um
>> results two
>> and that is an important part part.
Sanan at some point will if you can't
already see it will count just to make
sure that as you draw for the loop you
don't end up decking out
>> cuz being a single point away the
slightest misstep here
>> that would be
>> not to take away from any of these
players but I don't think pansack will
be giving a backseat on that one
six Okay,
six and six.
>> Respond with zombies.
>> I will trigger my school crab for the
biggest note-taking session you've ever
seen in real life.
>> Draw a card from Lux.
>> Uh, wait, wait, wait. What happens
first? Death now or death now or draw?
>> Say again.
>> Which happens first? The death nail or
the draw?
>> Uh, draw first.
>> Okay.
>> So, of course with skull the crab.
>> All right. falling
will be a reveal as Pence is going to
look through. I wouldn't be surprised to
see a concession here as soon as he sees
a call a week.
>> Uh
counting the uh amount of removal that's
left.
>> Understood.
>> Oh, look. It's It doesn't end. It
doesn't. I thought for a moment he was
looking at his trash.
>> I Yeah. Not going to even begin to write
that down. It's like you okay you have
your whole board.
>> Yeah. Doesn't doesn't even do it. You're
like yeah fine. It's We also saw
Pennistag uh count the number of cards
left in Sanan's deck. So saying okay I
know that this turn right this second
you aren't there but I get one more
turn.
Don't really know what options
are left.
pass. And now it's just up to San to
demonstrate the position to be in the
loop
>> because how many more opportunities will
San be given
>> and that
>> how many more does he need?
>> You know, I know it sounds I mean it
doesn't matter, but uh I was going to
say this won't end the game this turn.
Of course, we are limited by the uh
having to score both battlefields every
single game. But once Sanan demonstrates
it once, uh I I'm pretty sure Pentag is
just going to say, "Yeah, there's
literally nothing in this deck that is
going to bypass infinite
um infinite sprites." And as Pentac, you
also kind of have to keep in mind that
you are on the clock.
>> Ah yeah. Yeah. If you if you want to
another game to be be clutching here,
you kind of don't want to stay too long
in a losing game.
>> Uhhuh.
just the Sanan's like near perfect
amount of interaction in the early game
of just to take out a couple of units
and slow pent stag down into that
ruination.
>> And now
>> rally the troops triggers and buffs. I'd
like to react.
>> Sure.
>> Discipline echo, please.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, one more draw. Didn't see it,
but don't think there's too much little
help from this situation.
>> Flo two.
>> Okay.
>> Top 12
>> float one float the power.
>> Okay. So,
whilst son is moving things along,
>> I think like the one miracul miraculous
out is like a double Rengar turn. Uh I I
don't think we're here. I think we are
actually into the first loop as uh
typically when you see the float the
float the rune, float the power
is pretty much the moment without
knowing the exact number of cards. It's
rally the troops again.
>> Yeah. Cool.
>> Y
>> then it should be forge, right? Is is
the next step because you recycle back
in. Oh, it's okay. Lecturing your
Uh yeah,
>> and that was the last card.
>> So Forge has to come. You have to
recycle uh back into the deck at this
point.
>> Make a guy. Use the forge.
>> And oh uh James, I'm not feeling too
well.
>> I'm going to return this three.
>> I'll check with you, but I'm feeling a
bit loopy. Uh, I'll let son
>> walk us through.
>> Okay. And I'm going to explain the loop
to you.
>> Yes, I would like you to. So, I'm just
making sure that I get it right. So,
forge puts back uh forge,
>> shadow core,
and sacrifice.
Uh, just shuffle that.
Um, if you don't mind, just I'm going to
draw all of them. Can we show them so
it's going to be more clear for
everyone?
>> If you're going to draw anyway, just do
it.
>> Okay.
>> Five for echo.
>> Mhm.
>> Sacrifice.
>> Yep.
going to float one.
>> Going to float another one.
>> Float the power.
>> Okay.
>> Channel
two.
>> All right.
And then I will use shadow call here to
draw the other two.
>> All right.
>> Okay.
>> And from here just repeat.
>> Mhm.
>> Do this again. Make another guy.
Use it. Return the same three.
>> Okay.
Then play echo which is five
and the power
play go to shadow colon echo that's
going to be draw me two cards and then
sacrifice aftera on echo which is going
to draw me the other two cards which are
going to be these four.
>> Okay, so I'll draw these four.
Get to untap everything.
There is a point to this because you
generate infinite energy.
>> Rinse and repeat for infinite energy.
>> A second loop of generating infinite
power uh by you have copies typically
>> loop every time is going to
>> this is loop one of three. Yeah, I I I
heard the sequel is not as great as the
first one, but the the third part makes
it all up for
>> the important part is then you make
power by retreating your recruits or
electron
echo this and this to draw the four
which is echo plus the other three and
these two are played go there
and every time I do this loop I will
generate one energy.
>> Mhm.
>> Is that okay?
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah,
>> that is correct. generate a million
energy.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Conservative. Just a million.
Yeah. A million.
>> He has the token.
>> San. Oh, that is perfect. It's not an
arbitrary number. It's written on the
card. So, 1 million energy.
>> Retreat this guy.
>> Load the power.
>> Then you do the loop and you
>> I can't wait for this.
>> Infinite of these guys as well. Okay.
There's there's 1 million of them.
>> 1 million tokens. Understood.
>> There's 1 million tokens.
>> Now, that is what I call a power play.
>> And and because you're floating
eventually that
>> Yeah. Cuz you'll channel rune every
single like at the end. You see you
float one at the end of the loop and
then you'll generate
>> Okay.
>> an additional power for each time the
loop happens. I wonder what number San
has picked for infinite power.
>> 1 million power.
>> It is another loop. I'll show it to you.
Oh,
>> would you like to
>> u I mean demonstrate. Yeah, please.
>> Okay. You're going to draw three cards
with this. This on one of the 1 million
tokens and this to make two sprites
which is going to draw me another card.
>> Oh,
>> okay.
>> Okay. It It's important. Sorry. Yeah. Uh
the power version is the Renata version.
>> Yeah. Sure.
>> This is just to make sprites uh and
take control of the battlefield.
Apologies.
>> I'll retreat on the order.
>> All right.
>> Floating a power.
>> Mhm.
>> No, it is okay.
>> That's going to make me another power.
Yeah,
>> this is used. This goes to my hand.
>> Yeah.
>> Then I will use porch.
>> Return this, this, and this.
>> Yes.
>> Play yord and shadow call on the yord to
draw three.
>> Yeah.
>> I'll draw these three.
>> Okay.
>> I'll play on the on the yord and make a
power. So I I can do this infinite
times.
>> Yes. Yep.
>> I'll make 1 million.
>> Yep. 1 million power. One. There it is.
>> Power.
>> There it is. A million power. Unlimited
power.
>> But actually a million.
>> Millionaires at this point. Um,
now demonstrate the third loop. And this
is going to be the most important one.
and check power
>> cuz what is incoming will be
>> demonstrative of the killing block.
>> Yeah, that's what you need to see. At
the end of any loop, you have to show
how the game ends.
>> Shadow call one of the tokens.
>> Sure.
>> To draw three
>> cuz if if if you were to keep going like
this, the Yei is up in points. So that
>> we got this this
>> which to be fair to Penta Stackag, he
hasn't seen the Renata Glass in this
deck list cuz it's not main board. So
you must demonstrate a game-winning
loop.
>> One of the tokens, draw three cards from
Lux. Draw these three.
>> Mhm.
>> And then repeat this a million times
with the same three cards.
>> Yeah, sure. Sure.
>> So I make infinite of those
>> tokens. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> The thing is
>> like a thousand. Sure.
>> If Penta
>> spots at the end of the loop results in
San having no cards in deck and Sanan
passes and comes back to turn, that
would therefore attempt to draw a card,
right? If you're not winning this turn,
>> is there a window to deck out? If
>> I mean, if you have
>> does not structure the deck at the right
way at the end, you have to imagine he
will, right?
>> If you have a fort of the future, you're
good to go.
>> As long as you end the loop in that
state
>> is my point. You have to pass at some
point. But you have to be mindful.
>> Exactly. Exactly. There's no room for
error.
>> Fourth card of my choice, which could be
any.
>> Let's say this one.
>> Then I'll use this on two of my tokens
to draw four.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So I have an extra card that I
don't need. Plus three.
>> Mhm.
>> This is that.
>> Then I can do the same. This forge
returns these three.
>> Yeah.
>> And these two cards draw me these three.
>> Mhm. And then when I do it, I can return
as many cards as I want from my trash to
my hand.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> So, I'll return everything.
>> Sure.
>> Except for any three cards.
This goes to my hand.
>> There's a white card in there.
>> Yeah. Oh, looks of course.
>> So, at this point, I think this purely
comes from the iteration and not having
the Renata Glas in the main deck. Uh
because I'm I'm sure Penta Stag is
familiar with the original loop that we
saw. Uh I know people have been talking
about it a lot. People have been
adapting and trying to innovate
>> and despite the fact that the RNA
version is very
I
>> I will just say TCG historians know that
players have won games
>> by presenting an infinite loop and not
having the winning condition
accidentally in their
historically. So I don't blame Pentis
for saying I haven't seen your win
condition yet.
>> They are just making Salon play by the
rules set out. The judges are next to it
vigilant on exactly that.
>> I think if Penta had seen a Renata Glask
this the concede would have happened
>> but they haven't presented a game
ending.
>> Exactly. You've presented an impossible
board state.
Apologies for talking over. I didn't see
how many sprites actually ended up
>> right
>> up 900,9
99.
>> Well, it's every unit at this point now.
The noded head from Penta saying, "Okay,
so you are just going to stack."
>> All right. And this is the thing is the
the the turn has passed. There are cards
in deck. So San is going to be able to
lock this up. Uh but stop the time. I
think we had a 14minut turn. We
>> not quite 1 million, but it's getting up
there.
>> Um
>> how many million recruits?
>> Well,
>> I mean surely there's no
>> out, right?
Temporar dice.
>> Yep.
>> Cuz now the recruits just like 500,000
move to one battlefield, 500,000 move to
the other.
>> Yes.
Temporary dice.
>> I guess if we're being pedantic,
a few have been retreated.
>> Yeah, that that's that's not a clear
game state anymore, is it?
>> We kid. We kid. We kid. Obviously.
>> Get this three back. I will say um but
aren't you getting nervous as you just
with the time remaining
>> or are we really banking on a slight
misstep
>> 10,000 of those there
>> five
>> I think it's important to note what's on
the line here
>> and 10,000
here
>> top 64 is on the line
um and being 8 and one at this moment
means you are still alive for it
definitely
>> I will play a discipline run and draw
card.
>> And the problem is Sanan has not
demonstrated a gamewinning loop. It is
an impossible board state.
>> But a game win right now. It is not. You
still need another of Sanan's turns to
happen, which is fine. You just move the
units and pass. But
>> yeah, like like that's the point.
>> The extra fireworks of winning in a
single turn are nice and all, but like
we said before, it doesn't matter if you
win in a 100 turns in two.
>> Yeah, there we go. We are going to game
two from Pentax. So yeah, getting to the
point at which the the game actually was
over. Um, San does have options in the
sideboard of uh of ways to end the game
on that turn. It it is a little bit of
the the the the
clunkiness of a loop that does not end
the game is if you're not presenting a
demonstrable game winning loop, your
opponent to some extent is able to say,
"Yeah, show me." Yeah,
>> keep going. Like get there.
>> Okay. you you have the units and you're
just going to win through a holding that
is fine, but you're going to have to go
through every step. There's no shortcuts
here.
>> Many players would scoop uh if you're
like, "Hey, I just don't want to." Sure,
you you've got it. Um you are within
your right to to see the end of of the
game come through. We knew there's
nothing in Pentis Stack that will
actually turn that back around.
>> Pentag is just keeping anonymous. Just
like, "All right, just show me show me
that you can win the game." I I did and
now we're moving.
>> I don't think we need not so fast
>> flavor text in this deck just as the
name of the card cuz if that was fast I
don't want to see slow.
>> That was blistering speed. I'm not sure
about you but
>> yeah the sabotage is likely to come in
you would imagine. Again I I felt like
the start from Penta was almost as good
as it was going to get. Things like
sabotaging the progress day initially
out of hand. Removing it from there was
an important moment. despite running
into an early call the week, right? And
we saw how I mean in the end, despite
the fact that Son did snatch back that
game, the margin was thin. Yeah.
>> On seven points, if you break a single
turn or that call the week at the very
beginning wasn't played, that is the
margin of error you're working on.
>> Uhhuh. And in those early turns where
Lux hasn't acquired all of the options
yet of interaction, not all of the runes
in his hand yet, that is the time where
you have to capitalize on a restrained
Damasian pupil.
>> Yeah, that's uh that is fair to say. Uh
thank you everyone for joining us on uh
this beautiful Sunday morning on Loop
Watch. Uh so yeah, loop loop lots of
cards. I will say uh it's a deck that
we've only really seen for a week. we
here in you know Europe and North
America haven't really seen it at a
competitive level. This is the first
opportunity for it to actually come out.
So uh we are also learning the different
variations with you alongside we hear
from testing partners, we hear from the
teams, we we hear little snippets of
things, but actually seeing it happen in
a in a day two scenario is a very
different beast where people are running
different variations and unlike many of
other iterations, I feel like the loop
player have been playing their cards
relatively close to the chest. Lots of
foreboing statements out there, but none
of them really keen to tip their hand
too early. Yeah, this element of
surprise which is diminished a little
bit with all the exposure it had before.
But these new iterations,
>> you do want to verify what you're
working with and the fact that we
haven't seen just yet. Could that be a
tip off for for entertaining?
>> So, a lot of a lot of people are running
it in the sideboard just for like, hey,
I'm going to run out of time, so I've
got to I I need to end the game. So,
walk me through why don't we just main
deck it turn for the first one?
>> That is a great question. Uh, I'm
assuming it's something to do with like
the reliability of it. Um, I know
people, for instance, are Yeah, you know
what? I actually don't have an answer to
that. I'm not even going to try and make
one up. Uh, no, no, no. It's it's it's
totally fine. This is one of the things
I was thinking through of like is it
that you don't it's vulnerable if it's a
one-off and then I'm like no because it
just goes back in the deck and you just
draw it and you loop into it again. Um
yeah, it's a really good question. Um I
would love to hear potentially from San.
>> Yeah. Well, now I'm kind of wanting to
win so Barrett can ask
>> variation. I was talking to some of the
the the team at Challenger who have a
different variation on on this as well.
Um, I I will say it's not an easy loop
>> to uh appreciate if it's a different
variation or something like that and
you're seeing it for the first time.
Once you have it in your head, you're
like, "Okay, I kind of understand."
Explaining it is another thing. Um, but
of course, being at this level, you have
to be able to explain it to your
opponent uh and demonstrate it. But it
it's not intuitive to say, "Yes, I'm
going to win the game from this
position."
I think at the point where you're like,
"Oh, I'll create a million energy."
>> I have two gigantic cannons now.
>> And they're not cannons, but they're two
progress days in hand. That is good for
the card draw, but
a little too soon.
>> Got to get there.
>> And get there.
>> You don't necessarily want to put them
on the bottom either.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, no, it's okay. Two. I did you did we
catch a look at what went out of hand? I
know there was a promising future which
is a card we don't see too much uh in
the hand of San which if we see it we
will end up getting. Of course
we'll be looking for that sabotage in
hand early on. Y
>> the window
to interfere with Sanan's plans is
small.
>> It comes in the early game and you're
not really closing it delaying it. No
two drop from Pente.
>> Both progress days a kept in hand. Uh
Sanh
must have drawn it off. Uh Sanan
ends up with some supervis
utilize them on Sanan's turn.
So we're essentially like half a turn
behind for Penta from where you'd want
to be.
And we saw how it ended when he did find
the turn one play. So needed every
little boost he could get in the early
game. So this
>> will definitely leave a bit air taste.
Once again, we are lacking a bit of the
extra
>> card rotation through Ajan's warrants.
Uh-huh.
>> So the amount of cards you will see will
be limited. and first mate on the lonely
parro
>> first mate star spring combination
however is going to get lonely parro
over to the treasure horde in order to
score to the second
>> let me just think about this
>> point
>> uh no I won't
>> and san's next turn is likely to just be
progress day
>> or at least it is an option there is a
sabotage in hand
>> a challenge
>> and your looks please
>> played
and damage
>> just pushing son back whenever they can.
>> No, you're not getting that extra
energy.
>> There is the sabotage. Uh, one of those
progress is likely hitting the uh the
recycle.
>> This is the moment where you really wish
you weren't seeing a second progress
day.
Echo,
>> do you at this point
>> scout
>> try and defend your own progress by
taking out the call so you can keep
holding on? You can keep the tempo going
at the very least.
>> I I think you might be more scared of
progress day into the following turn.
Singularity or ruination like call the
week on its own. It's a little bit
slowing down pentag
you need to cut that card draw. You need
to keep Sanan's options. To be frank,
and I maybe it's not as definite as I'm
saying it. If San had not drawn into
ruination in the last game, the very
last opportunity to to play it, Penta
Stack basically had that game wrapped
up, right? That had to be exactly like
the ability to clear both boards. So
maybe there was like another singularity
there, but the card draw is so key in
this early game. And San, will it be
like card sharp which came off the top
or will it be progress day? It could
just be stupify into double check the
option just in case it was a
singularity. Then it's progress day um
with the remaining energy. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Let's draw five, shall we?
>> So saying, "Yeah, okay. My opponent's
going to go up to four now." Pence is in
a an awkward situation.
>> Elaborate. So
you want to play out more units to
protect from a singularity, but if you
play out all your units and ruination
has come off the top, you're one turn
away after that. San cannot ruination on
the next turn. Um unless he's got a way
of killing Ekko and going neutral and
getting one extra energy. Maybe I would
have to take a look exactly
>> are thin though.
>> Yeah, they're very very thin. It would
have to be an exact way of weaving
together cards.
That would mean that Sonat is really
fearful.
>> Penta and they have time passes,
>> has the two units, did not develop a
board into it. So potentially playing
around the same thing, but then you're
hedging your bets at that point. You're
like, if my opponent has this exact
answer,
how do I play? And you know, I mentioned
I I joked about not so fast not being an
option. Actually, if you're protecting
against singularity, that might be one
way in as singularity would be a way of
of preventing that.
>> You are not it doesn't equat
this iteration of Lux. So, every small
little bit of help you can get can be
the difference maker. We saw how close
it was in the previous one.
>> Yeah. Kop car chop into Swork's map.
When an opponent scores, draw one. And I
think the question is going to be, are
you drawing one or drawing two?
>> On the hold.
>> I'll draw two.
>> Um,
>> there. I mean, they're they're two.
>> I know. I'm just saying that it's a No,
I was just going to say that was like
the question that Pente is going to ask
and Salan says, "I'll draw two." Uh,
it's one of those things where
>> Yeah, it's I draw two.
>> It just goes to show that I thought it's
always about me.
I'll leave it there.
>> Leaving it there. Is that potentially a
sign of like saying, "Hey, if you do
contest this battlefield, I'm going to
Rengar is is one option.
The harder you make it for your
opponent, the more possible game states
they have to take into account,
the better your position is going to be.
But despite
pentack sitting on six points, I am not
confident. You are not comfortable right
now. We were in this stage in the last
game. If this is ruination off the top,
that's heartbreaking.
If
you are rooting against
Is there one in hand?
trying to
>> I didn't quite catch that, but it looked
like there might have been one in hand
actually for San already.
>> And shuffle more nervously, please.
>> I mean, usually at the table, uh I'm not
a fan of hand shuffling, but
>> cool, calm, and collected.
>> There's already one there.
I think that that means at this point
it's it's tricky to play out from here.
San I think is trying maybe to bait out
the Rengar, bait out the options.
Penta's like, oh, plays into it as well.
And I think that's exactly what San
wants because it's like,
>> sure, you can uh you can go to seven.
>> You can score this this battlefield.
That's fine because seven does not win
you the game. Ruination, is there a wind
wall or anything that's come in? No,
it's not.
And there's no way of of taking that
down. And three units will fall to the
ruination. And it's a repeat of game
number one as Dejan is going to crush
through the units of Pentastag and now
have full control on the board despite
having zero points. Pentag
is facing is that almost winning is also
fully losing at this point. Now are
there options? Are there enough ways
of finishing either his turn or San's
turn with units on board to hold for a
point? There is a disarming rake in
hand. That is another unit. So Pentis is
saying, I'm going to force you to have
another ruination or another
singularity. The Mi of course in hand as
well.
Has a a pit rookie,
an axan, a disarming rake. Like there
are units here. This is a little bit
better than the last game, but they have
to stick. And the problem is Sanan has
been drawing into options to to take
them out.
>> They have been acquiring more and more
cards throughout
>> looking for where the border ends, what
the limits are. And he'd been walking a
fine line, but like a tightroppe walker,
never losing balance.
>> How long left?
And that does show what's on the mind.
>> That does
>> looking for for what's already been
used, what's been
churned through. So, Singularity
obviously does enough to to prevent
Pentag from from outright
conquering both battlefields on the
following turn. some point of the map.
It's a lot of the pieces of the puzzle,
but not a lot of removal. So, now it's
down to San to say, "Okay, how do I get
there?" And the moment Sanan asks for
time left, you're going to have to
assume that he's going through my if I
lose this this game.
There's not a good shot of me winning
the third one in time. I think that's a
Ranata Glask in hand though for San,
which would mean that the sideboard uh
plan of bringing in Ranata Glass
Mastermind to win with the the infinite
combo on the the same turn
as well.
>> And that is where the overtime turns are
benefiting Deluxe here.
>> Oh, massively. Yeah,
>> cuz there
>> you only need to get into one of them to
loop and then it's fine. You can take as
long as you want, but preferably not
that long. Preferably, unless you're
called Sanan and you'd like to go 9-1.
>> Preferably, you just reveal like the
eight cards in the Ronald Glask and say,
"Hey, you saw half of this in game one."
Uh, now here's the actual game-winning
part. But again, San has to draw through
a lot of the deck. But at this point,
the Echo is going to assist allow the
the awakening of the runes already.
>> We are in singularity range right now to
at least
>> calm a bit.
>> Do we have one in hand yet? Uh, I don't
see one. Looks like two retreats came
off the top recently.
Uh I thought that might be the RNA
glass, but it actually looks more like
Ash. It might be the other version of
this deck.
>> They are tucked in there.
>> And I I do think the foiling is
beautiful on these cards, but sometimes
when there's a lot of scenics,
>> it can be uh a little trickier.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Getting the pawns into
position.
>> Well, this is all about drawing now.
It's just having a target to be able to
say, "Yep, draw two cards. I need
Seymour. I need Seymour.
>> Retreat.
Needs to come up with something rather
quickly cuz Echo goes back to
>> another Echo. That might be the same.
You have the energy for the sacrifice.
>> Yep. Sacrifice. Then Ekko's going to let
you do it again. And you're just
looking, just digging. There's one. They
got to be in there somewhere.
>> 10 minutes or 30 or 30 minutes?
>> You said 30 before.
>> Oh, San heard 30 out of 13. Yeah.
>> Instead of 13 is my point. San
understood as 30-0. That's uh not
not the same. Um as San is just not
finding the answers. There is the Ronald
Glask enhanced sprite burst as well. So
now am I ah how many options are in
there to draw? There is a progress day,
but if you if you progress day and don't
have the echo on the back of it.
>> Exactly.
>> You can't you can't um singularity
following it.
>> One, two, three, four, five. There has a
decision to be made.
>> So either has to decide I am not there
yet. I need to survive rather than
acquiring more pieces of the puzzle
which would be a holding strategy like
getting onto the battlefield with like
sprites. But does that do it? Are there
shadows calling? You know you got to
spend some units. So it's progress day
into looking for an option.
>> So now we are in that similar position
where Aurora players are where they
can't find Aurora. But that is in hand.
But is there a way to actually get to
play them? Because there's no echo.
There's no way of of relooping, right?
So the echo is now in hand. This is what
you wanted to see on the last thing of
drawing. Scoops it up and San is going
to get taken to a game three by Pent.
And now the timer ticks. And the really
important thing, the absolutely vital
thing is we go into overtime rules is
what we're looking at. If Penta can
establish a two-point lead and the loop
is not found in the three overtime
turns, then Penta will advance. And this
Lux deck does not take points early.
That is what we've seen throughout game
two ending a dollar short and a day
late. Now it is time to regain the
temple. You can see the nervousness. We
saw before the little shaking of the
hands.
What a disastrous turn. You saw how
close they was. We saw how fine the
margins were in game one and now there's
no time to lose.
>> Is there a way to pivot? Do we throw out
the combo knowing we can't acquire it in
time
>> and just fully bank on sprites?
That looked like uh thinking about a
singularity out. I didn't see what went
in. instead. Uh, you saw San contemplate
it. There is a not so fast in the now
post sideboard deck from Pentax. I
>> I believe they have one main deck.
>> Okay. Okay, cool. Uh, I I will say that
the deck we showed coming into this uh
was correct. The deck list was correct.
just uh the name um sometimes there's a
discrepancy in the the the the data of
usernames and I know Pentto is pentag
here you can see that San is like right
let's get going I think he can't wait to
get all the turns he possibly can out of
this game he will need every single one
of them
>> yes and this is the downside I I
appreciate I'm sure people will be of
split opinion over playing the loop out
in game one but without
ranata in the main
point where it's just like so you're at
zero points or one point I'm you're
going to pass okay playing the regional
qualifier is more than about just
playing the cards in hand and the
resources on you managing energy both in
the game but also in yourself to play
over two days managing the clock
setting yourself up in the most
favorable positions. This is where it
all comes together for Pentagon.
Now on to start it peak. Aspirin's climb
is not going to particularly matter. I
doubt Pentag is going to get to 29. It
is just a case of getting high enough on
the board. Like just getting enough
points to go past Sanans's.
>> The one change from here on out is this
is the first time pan stack is not going
first.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that is very true. Does have
two drop in hand though. That's really
important for the pace of this match.
Now, Sanan
>> going first has to create some presence.
Stupify, retreat, forge, pass.
Call the week is going to help.
>> Is there a defy in hand?
>> Yes,
>> it's lux. It's the importance of just
having a unit. We need dig in. We need
more energy. We need those progress days
ready and up and running.
>> Now, Pentis options are multiple units
or the Y. What is what is the direction
for this turn? Are there multiple units
to play out?
>> Start tit peak will uh at least help on
the hold. That is what the master is
going to want to do.
>> Oh, there are multiple units. This can't
play both of them, but at least you know
there's some protection potentially.
That is the
>> on the call week.
>> You both have first mate.
>> Ready's the parro.
>> Is this now charm? Yep. Charm bring the
lux in. Gets the mastery legend ability
of course.
>> Passes the turn. So first point scored.
Not enough to take this if we were to go
to overtime with this difference. But
>> the units in hand for San, it's it's
just a flat progress. saying, "I need to
get to my loop in the next 4 minutes so
that we can go into overtime and I can
establish control in one of those two
potential turns that San would have."
>> We saw how from seemingly nothing, Sanan
can build up an army and strike.
>> Hold to two.
>> Yes.
>> Trigger start to peak.
>> Channel two
>> start to trigger happens obviously
before the channel. That's why just
sequencing the start of turn
>> uh conquer to three
>> holds to two now conquers to three.
So now the game win is active for Pente
if we end overtime in the current score
point
a point score I should say Penta Stag
would end up taking it. That is a pass
now.
San forge of the future. This is mostly
to get a body and to draw you would
imagine. because we haven't seen
anything like a singularity come
through. This is like trying to
desperately
>> The thing is ruination is going to hurt
you as well in this situation. So, it's
purely about draw, draw, draw, draw. How
do I get through my deck quick enough?
>> We are stuffing our back with as many
cards as we can so that when we go
camping in our overtime turns, we are as
well prepared as we possibly can. And
San is trying to just get these
sequences done as quickly as possible of
like I have to draw basically 40 cards
>> and props Tantis Stag for not slowing
down at this point and trying to play
for the win still.
>> Yeah, thinking about the plays obviously
taking the time to think about it but
after an extremely long game one now
saying hey I need to keep pace I need to
keep going forward and Pentag will score
up to five again. The point does whose
line is it anyway cuz the points don't
matter at this point. Um unless not made
up though.
>> Penta can get you know the rules are
absolutely in force. Uh if Penta is able
to get to nine then yes the points
matter. But the the entire point about
this this motion is when we get into
overtime it's either Sanan wins with the
loop combo or Pentag wins this this
match
>> and facing the sabotage. Right now
you're going to have to at least think
through and be like all right what has
you been doing up to this point? Draw,
draw, draw, draw. Can we slow it down
even the tiniest bit? It matters. Like
we saw in the previous turn,
>> when there is what, three, five, eight,
>> 11 cards in hand, you are entitled time
>> plus fury.
>> Writing it down.
You're entitled time to think is what I
was going to say.
>> Um, writing it down
>> just to keep the information is is
perhaps another thing. But San
recognizes that the only way through
this game is to draw the entire deck.
Penta knows the same thing.
>> There's no singularity.
>> You got to just take the card draw.
>> You would imagine.
>> Oh, he's saying can't be this. Can't be
this. Can't be this. Maybe he's trying
to take some of the the bodies. He's
either the shadows call
>> or the sprite burst. Because with with
the sprite burst, you can start fighting
back up to a certain point. True. True.
>> Though you do have to contest with the Y
passive, of course.
>> Gives the sprite burst back. It is
Shadow's Call. 59 seconds on the round.
I will say uh as always with feature
matchups, yes, our timer uh is ticking.
The judges at the table are the ones
that will tell our players exactly the
uh the exact moment that overtime
begins.
So if we go to zero and there's a little
bit of
>> so we need to keep track of the hand of
San are the pieces there yet
but it's too late surely we are looking
for echo right now you're looking for
you're looking for draw plus echoes
that's the problem the problem is it
doesn't do enough on its own
>> a ruined nation
>> it does slow pentag
to when we're in overtime not get to
nine probably and on the next turn you
do have the sprites available if you can
get up to maybe three or four at least
you can force her to draw that away but
the pivoting of plants it means that all
those earlier turns are not really
getting the result that we've wanted you
have to pick a lane at a certain point
>> so is its
or 0 1 2 3 right
>> okay
turn zero on me then you have one turn
two Three.
>> Okay.
>> So that's saying that Pentag Pentag's
turn is turn zero. Zero means
>> this is the last kind of like regular
turn.
>> After this one we start counting down.
>> San will have one turn then Penta will
have a turn and then Sanan will have the
final turn of the game.
>> And importantly
now the time is off. These are untimed
turns.
So everything about decision-m and the
amount of time. And that's
>> You think he's got to write these ones
out?
>> Uh well, most of them already written
down, right? So it's just new new
information. Um
but but that was what I was going to say
is anything here is now pure decision-m
purely thinking through
>> and that is that is shifting gears for
the players as well cuz you've been
rushing rushing rushing rushing trying
to get as much out as possible and now
you have to take a few deep breaths. You
heard Pensac say no ruination, right?
And I think also clocking the echoes
being missing means we're now drawing
into
untapping like you have to draw into
answers. So Penta feels a little bit
safer to play out units. Plays one and
we'll just say pass.
Stupify rally is probably not what
Sanically was looking for. However,
supervis are a cheap way of at least
seeing one more. Is that enough?
>> He is guaranteed one more turn.
>> Yeah.
>> After this one. So, we can set up this
entire turn.
>> Because at this point, trying to get a
draw out of it is simply not feasible.
>> It's all or nothing. There was a really
important card in hand that I haven't
mentioned up until this point and I
realize uh it was the card that I was uh
misrecognizing in the previous game and
that is Fiora worthy which is important
to buff up the Renata to be able untap
it like ready it and move it to the
battlefield. Apologies for missing that
on the previous game. That is exactly
what was in hand. I uh wasn't quite able
to to sneak a vision of it but it is
there. Thank you to our our team behind
the scenes for for displaying it as
well. It's an important part on the the
Ranada combo to uh to be able to get
that.
And you got to keep setting up as son.
Pull the trigger too early and it's a
blank. Pull the trigger too late and
you're giving the game away.
So this is turn one of overtime,
>> correct? After this one, Pentag gets
another and San will finish out the
game.
>> That's a lot of cards left in San's
deck.
>> That is a lot of cards. Like more cards
left in Echo.
>> Still no Echo.
>> Stupify trying to get just the last
little look.
>> Finds a sacrifice.
>> One piece. It it's it's a piece of the
puzzle, but
>> San will get to draw off that. If it's
an echo off the top to get sacrifice,
then that
>> is a different, you know,
>> he has been drawn so many cards
>> and how many card draw you only need to
you get maybe one or two more looks with
the other super fires. closing hand up.
Extend
>> the last turn for Panther Stag,
>> which means we're now loop or lose for
Sanan on the final turn. It is possible,
I believe, from this situation with the
cards in hand. If an echo comes off the
top, I think it's the last piece. Go
ahead.
>> The six
>> at least to to to create a board state
where you can get the loop.
>> There is a not so fast in hand, but that
doesn't do anything to the loop. That
would have just been to protect the
units.
>> The first domino needs to fall once you
have that million energy in the bank.
That also explains why Pendag was double
checking why San was where San was
targeting was superfy which San said
card sharp because not fast has to be
your own unit right but it would deny a
draw so
>> they're ready into hand progress day
that's
>> is there enough 1 2 3 4 5 six
>> are they on 12 routes
>> that would be enough right
>> echo and a sacrifice
>> that would make 12
and you'll be drawing a 15
>> oh there's one left
>> oh they're short.
>> I I don't think I have a sinking
feeling. James,
>> is there another way? Is there another
way to draw there? We're stupified
there. Right. So, progress day is not
the only option. Ah, there's you could
just sacrifice one of your other units
and say, "Okay, we're going to going to
get into it." A promising future. A card
we have not seen in this matchup.
They're going to look at the top five of
their main deck, choose one, recycle the
rest.
>> Starting with the next player, each
player plays these cards. This is one
energy cheaper. If they hit the echo,
>> choose, but then you play it first.
>> We move on.
>> Oh, right. So,
>> we choose at the same time.
>> Sure. So, I just I had a reveal.
>> You heard Sanan say we choose at the
same time, but you play it first.
>> There is an echo. Is there enough on the
back end of this combo?
and Penta has to play first.
It's mostly units not so fast can't be
played in this situation of course.
So it's just Ruin Runner or Rengar
or Lonely Parro.
>> You want to shuffle?
>> Sahan says doesn't matter. You're not
going to you're not going to see these
cards. This is the last turn.
>> Uh I I shuffled it after you shuffle.
Could you shuffle that again, please?
Oh, wait. You tapped it, didn't you?
>> Shuffle that real quick.
>> It's okay. I didn't do anything. You can
go.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> So, San,
>> we'll see Pente reveal.
>> You had the power.
>> Sure.
>> Play echo.
>> Plays the echo. Surely that's
>> from from Lux
>> got to be enough, right? We know there's
a progress day in hand.
>> So San is gonna
eventually end up sacrificing the echo
>> and there are more echoes laying in
wait.
>> Exactly. And that's going to be enough
effect through
>> promising future. A card that is not
played in the majority of the meta.
Pretty much this is the only time I've
seen it played at this level
>> is looking promising for San's future
being
>> a win in round 10.
>> One more time. We have the energy. We
have the card drop.
>> And this is where the adaptation has to
be Ranata out of the sideboard for the
overtime rounds because if this was the
same strategy as game one, San would not
be able to win. But Ranata Glask can win
on the same turn you loop by utilizing
Ranata Glask mastermind's tap ability to
score a point by recycling. I believe
it's four energy.
>> Sure.
>> But that's
>> four energy plus recycles. Yeah.
>> That's a drop in the bucket when
>> Yeah. When you have a million
Just five.
>> This is the next domino.
>> Three and two.
>> That needs to hit.
>> There's the other echo.
>> Second place.
float six.
>> I feel like we're there on the number of
cards in the deck or at least will be. I
I do are toppling over one after
another. And to add to the drama,
>> whoever takes the win kind of also
ensures their opponent that they're not
going to make the top cut. Two wins is
really tricky to still make it. the the
the difficulty with with with this is
the one player involved in this board
right now that uh is the one I'm just
going to trust to go through is Sanan
because knowing exactly the game state
with this intricate loop is uh a little
trickier than you might imagine. So,
actually just demonstrating a bunch of
the cards that we're recycling here. And
again, this is essentially the the setup
for the loop.
One second.
>> Is four.
>> Two sacrifices. A so two sacrifices
shield. Okay.
>> It is tricky because if you're not super
familiar, you haven't seen the RNA glass
yet in all of the the like sabotages and
stuff like that. You haven't seen the
finishing blow. Now you've seen the
Fiora, so you can infer if you're
familiar with the deck list that it is
there. But you you got to have it. And
at this point, the people still playing
that are eight on one, nine on zero, you
can expect from them that they will not
be caught too off guard by being faced
>> with a loopy loop deck.
Going over the top once more.
>> Another progress day. And we're just
digging for the pieces to to be
connected once more.
Keep everything floating. Find the next
echo. Find the next sacrifice. do it all
again.
And
well, we have the energy still, but
currently no echo in hand as far as I
can tell. Not that I saw,
but when you have so much energy still
available to be drawing.
But it goes to show that similarly to as
when you're playing Aurora, if your deck
is stacked in just the wrong order, it's
not impossible to break.
>> Not impossible, but I think we're at
that stage. I'll be very real, but we
got to introduce some sort of stakes
into this.
>> Yeah, you know, I I get it. I get it. I
get it. As uh again I mentioned
previously, I'm pretty sure TCG players
will uh know that when I refer to LSV uh
did famously win without having the win
condition. We've seen it in this. So I'm
not worried that San doesn't have the
RNA. Uh but it is valid for Penta to
say, "Hang on a second.
>> I haven't seen it yet. Show me the win
condition. Show me the win condition."
Panda Stacks playing the win.
>> Yeah, exactly. Tournament lifeline
>> and that includes your opponent.
>> San Nods going through till the very
end.
>> San's going to extend the ham. No way.
Pent manages to actually make it. Deny
the loop in overtime to go 91. Are you
kidding? The loop wasn't quite there.
the resolve of Panther Stag to sit
through all that calm and collected,
unbothered by what was happening in
front of him.
>> And and I know, I know, I know, rift
community, you're going to say, why
force the play out of the loop? Why do
it? That's why because if you don't see
the gameinning loop, you are not
entitled to the win yet. And that means
if your opponent does not find the loop,
your opponent does not win.
>> We have repeated it multiple times
throughout, but this is the embodiment
of making them have it. and Sanan
didn't. 1 million energy and 1 million
power was not enough to make it through
round 10 with the infinite loop lux as
Pentastag picks up a ninth win.
San I I had to play so clean through
that. Game one was the ruination just at
the right time and it looked it looked
so good. I was like, "Okay, San probably
is making it through this." Now we get
the Renata loop in. Game two was very a
lot quicker and Pentag just forced Sanan
to have the loop demonstrated. I even
was saying, "Hey, we're done here. This
is it. Probably we're going to get
there." But no, not to be. San could not
make it as Penta picks up the win. I
have never seen a more devastating brick
happen on stage in the feature match
with a possible top cut probability
still to fight for.
>> Son had everything to lose here and
Pentastag makes him lose it all. the
consistency, even missing a one drop in
some of these games on Pentastic side,
but just being able to outpace, knowing
that the overtime rules favor a deck
that is able to establish points. And
when you're running a deck that does not
score, the only ways to win in
Riftbound, aside from a couple of
battlefield, like the battlefield
that'll do it by holding, the only way
to win is just have that higher point
score, whether it's getting to the
winning point or end overtime with two
greater points than your opponent. That
is exactly what Pentastack did. Um,
>> I have so many questions for Pent Stack
in with the interview. I I'm sure you do
and I'm sure eventually we will, but uh
considering how long that round was and
how deep in the tank we had to go.
>> Um I think it may take a second or two
to get there. Uh wow, what a what a
round 10. Uh I mean to to to be candid,
obviously letting the players talk
through some of the loops I think is
important in that moment. You can see
just the communication of like step by
step, show me every single thing. and
San. That's one of the problems I think
when you're playing this deck is you
probably have to explain that loop a lot
every single time you play. Um
especially in these Swiss rounds where
your opponents you don't necessarily
know the matchups particularly well.
They want to see them demonstrate the
loop. We're going to take a breather
because Barrett is standing by with
Pentastag after that marathon win.
Thank you so much for that immaculate
commentating and casting for an
immaculate match showcasing a deck that
sure is the talk of the town, the talk
of the regional qualifier. Like you
said, for this past week, we had to talk
about this Lux deck, but that's not what
we're here to say congratulations to.
It's Rift Rift Labs Penta Stag.
Congratulations on your win with your
Master Y deck. And not only just that,
moving on and still keeping your top
eight contention alive here with three
more rounds to go. How does it feel
taking down what I think as we've said a
lot of people talking about this deck a
Titan that people are thinking about how
does it feel having getting that win?
>> It's terrifying. Um when I sat down I
was doom and gloom but um it feels
amazing. Uh especially uh when you
consider statistics I usually lose more
than I win against uh that looks
infinite combo. And I don't have a lot
of practice against it. I know the
basics and I know somewhat but I don't
even know how it actually like goes
infinite which is why I had to pay close
attention. Um so it feels amazing that I
was able to adapt on the fly and uh
honestly watching it happen was I I
thought I would be a lot sadder losing
but 1 million energy, 1 million power,
what you know do what you want. Um yeah,
pretty fun. No, it was so fun to watch
and I feel more educated as well, like
just being more informed into what that
deck does, but also figuring out the
keys to unlock the win of it. And this
even specific adaptation from San huge
shout outs to him because
>> you know I think the version that we've
seen going into this tournament is not
necessarily what he's playing in the
main board and then brings it out for
these other games and that just like has
to be even more difficult to you when
you have to address how to win get this
win. So, one thing I paid close
attention to game one was what cards
were being iterated and what was
happening especially uh paying close
attention to are they playing Renata cuz
um you can win from you know nothing.
So, um I was kind of curious as to if
that was happening but then game two
luckily my sabotage saw the Fiora and
there would be no other reason to run it
other than that. So, I was prepared for
Renata to happen. I had some like very
niche plays. Like I had some really
really niche lines going in my head that
I was like I hope I can pull that off
and maybe that'll be good. But at the
end of the day um I think I just play as
best as I can. And uh there was a couple
misplays. For example, I really probably
shouldn't be holding to play around some
contemp some map but you know um taking
the win is it feels good.
>> Good. And that you should feel good
because that I can't imagine being even
a pilot of that Lux deck, let alone
playing against it like you said, and
having to understand what's going on and
having to assess what tools in my own
deck or in your own deck that you can
use to even try and slow it down. I can
only imagine what your notebook has for
notes now. We saw you grab it a ton
during that match, but I don't want to
hold you. That was a slobber knocker of
a match. I want to give you a break, but
we're going to go ahead and send it back
because we've got another round of the
regional qualifier in Utre coming soon.
>> Slavanaka is the right word. Thank you,
Parrot. Uh that was was a was a mammoth
one. If you stuck with us through all of
that,
>> good job. Thank you. You earned a win in
round 10 as well. Uh you can chalk that
up on on your board. Uh so because of
course that was quite a a significant
match, we will not be looking at feature
match two from that round. We of course
do not want to hold the the tournament
up as we still have more rounds of Swiss
to play, believe it or not. Like how
excited are you for more three more
rounds of Swiss?
>> Oh, it's it's going to be a thriller
because there are so many top eight cut
dreams that are are going to be squashed
in the next few rounds and it's going to
be heartbreaking for all of them.
>> Yeah, it will. but also some players
will have things to celebrate as well,
I'm sure. Um, we will step away for a
few minutes as we take a look around the
venue here in RQ Utract and get ready
for round 11.
All right then, Riftbound fans. I'm
Shane Burton and we're here at the Utre
regional qualifier. This venue is
massive with a lot to look at. So, why
don't we have a look now?
Starting off with the trophy. Only one
person will leave here this weekend
holding that trophy and securing
themselves a slot in the regionals later
on in the year. Who will it be? Only one
way to find out. That's by watching the
rest of this stream. But there's also
some other things that people are
playing for here. This is your last
chance to get the best of legends cards
for Origins and we can see them all
here. A fantastic different way to play
in the tournaments is to try and be the
the top legend for your chosen deck.
Okay, so we finally made it to the prize
wall. For the for the players who are in
the side events, they actually get
tickets which they can redeem for a
multitude of different prizes. We have
packs, we have sleeves, we have
playmats, we have badges. So, it's not
all about the main event. And there's
actually currently an event happening
right now that players are competing for
these points. And there's events
happening right now, a team 2v2 event
and then the pre- regional event as
well. And quite honestly, the scale is
massive. There are hundreds, maybe even
thousands of players right now all
battling it out. But it's not all about
competition. You can actually open packs
here at the event right now. And not
only that, it's actually live streamed
for the rest of the venue to see. We
have to have a look at this. Come get
involved.
Okay, here we go. So, we have two people
opening their packs right now. They even
have a big red button if they pack
something good. Here we go. Let's keep
our fingers crossed.
Oh, here we go.
That's not bad. That's not bad.
Hey, we get the big red button hit as
well. Come on. That's what it's all
about here. Okay, so I was just catching
up with our person who just opened up
the pack there and turns out you
actually really needed this card, right?
>> Yes, correct. I want to play Ivan
tomorrow and in the main event and this
is your alad I'm missing and I want want
to go to play this tomorrow.
>> Okay. Wow. See, it was written in the
stars. Best of luck for you at you and
your event. And of course, when you're
at these events, there's always
cosplayers. I can see one there. Let's
see if we can quickly chat to him.
Excuse me. Excuse me. I must say I love
your cosplay. How long How long did it
take you to make that? Well, this is
amalgamation of 3 years to four years of
cosplaying, continuously upgrading,
tests and bids. Sometimes something get
ted, something get broken. So, I'm
always working to improve.
>> For the people, why did you choose to
cosplay Ekko?
>> Well, everybody tells that I look like
him, so I might as well commit to the
bit.
>> You definitely do. You definitely do.
Uh, why is Ekko one of your favorite
characters?
>> Ekko is maybe one of my most respectable
characters. Mostly because we share a
lot of ideas and opinions about a lot of
things. Yeah, I can respect him a lot.
>> There you go. Playing the character.
I've got some fantastic advice there.
Thank you so much for your time. It's
been a pleasure.
>> And here's something I love about the
Riftbound events, the community aspect.
And I think that's immortalized
perfectly with the graffiti wall. You
can come over here, write down anything
and everything you like and it will stay
there for the whole event. And we can
see card shout outs there. You can see
people saying that they was here. And
quite honestly, it's a bit of me. I'm a
big fan. Look how colorful it is as
well. Who doesn't love colors?
But of course, the main event, it has to
be all about the stage with two feature
tables. So, we can feature two matches
per round and the interview area as
well, so we can hear from the winners.
Now, at the end of this weekend, our
finalist and champion will be crowned
here. Who will it be? Who will be
getting the last of best of the origin
set? Only one way to find out, and
that's by getting back to the street.
Hello, Riftbounders. Are you wondering
how the game developed with Unleashed?
Let me give you a little introduction.
The calm domain has reinvented its
defensive capabilities. With powerful
pump spells and counter spells, calm
decks were already good at contesting
their battlefields, but with unleashed,
holding the fields becomes a whole lot
stronger. A standout example for this is
back off. Three energy, no power. This
card on action speed stuns a unit and
draws a card if played from hand.
Incredible. But leaving three runes open
isn't always an option. Luckily, you can
also hide this card if your runes are
exhausted or you want to keep them open
for another card. Fury, on the other
hand, brings plenty of new ways to
assert pressure onto your opponent.
Every jungler's dream is coming true
with smite, finding a new way to remove
units. It simply deals three damage to a
unit at a battlefield for two energy and
one power. While those stats are not too
impressive, the unit will also be
banished when it would die. This takes
powerful death nail effects out of the
equation and can also remove follow-up
if your opponent relies on resources
from their trash like Fiora worthy that
can't be played through spectral matron
anymore. Order has been known for its
hard removal and kill spells. Now, what
if I told you that you can remove your
opponent's hand as well? Ash Focus gives
you full information about your
opponent's hand and lets you banish a
card of choice for five energy and one
power. They will get it back as soon as
they hold a battlefield. But with full
information in one card less in the
opponent's hand, it's now on you to not
let that happen. Chaos has been
chaotically bouncing cards left and
right, pushing them front and center.
And now you will also be able to reach
the opponent's units in base. Starcross
reaction speed removal is revolutionary,
especially when it hits the base as
well. For three energy and one power,
you can return a friendly and an
opposing unit back to the owner's hands.
While this can give you an incredible
advantage with play effects, it also
disturbs your opponent. It slows them
down massively and can sometimes deny
powerful effects like Elder Drankren's
passive kill ability. While this domain
has already been good at controlling the
opponent's units, the mind is now
finally greater than the sword. The mind
domain receives a fantastic gear removal
card. Turn to dust will turn any gear
into a temporary problem for two energy
and no power cost. While it does not
immediately help you remove units that
are boosted by equipment gear, you can
easily take care of seals, dazzling
aurora, or other great gear that stands
in your way. Now, what's scarier than
body units that are standing on your
opponent's side of the field, just
waiting to overwhelm you with their
physical prowess? The ones you didn't
see coming.
Ringa Trophy Hunter has to be on your
opponent's mind at all times. Every time
your opponent feels secure about the bot
states, the Apex Predator could be
played on a battlefield where they have
units for five energy and one power,
either as an ambush or reaction speed to
support your other attacking or
defending units, or as a lonely attacker
straight from hand with its powerful six
smite. What cards do you think are going
to see the most play? And which domain
do you like the most after unleashed?
Show us at your next tournament.
>> All right then, Riftbounders, we are
back. I'm not sure how we can compete
with a million power and a million
energy, but we're going to try our best.
I'm Shay Burton joined by Leo. We're
getting to the business end of the
tournament now. What you thinking?
>> You know, Shay, I don't think you
actually need to have 1 million power, 1
million energy, and 1 million tokens. I
think you're going to be just fine
without those. Sometimes, you know,
about 20 is enough, but yes, we are
nearing the end of the Swiss stage of
the tournament. And this is where the
top of the crops is sitting. We have
some players still undefeated after 10
rounds of Swiss. And again, we have
Squirtle on top on Azir. Pedro is
undefeated for two tournaments in a row
so far.
>> I know. Doing a fantastic show there.
Obviously, our little champion running
it back with the same deck and doing
fantastically well. Let's consult this.
We do only have two undefeated people.
It looks like Alan ZQ has taken a loss
there now. And so has Prag Prismaticism
as well. But this is a pretty star study
top 10 though, Leah.
>> And look at that. Mice Diamond. Yeah,
>> still in there with Darius. We still
have the Rexai of course as well and
Anzu there on the nine who lost to
Squirtle in the last round. So I think
>> we need to start broadening the goat
debate in Riftbound, right? I know the
game hasn't been around for too long,
but people are still already starting to
discuss, hey, is Prismaticism maybe the
best player in the world? Maybe it is
Alen ZQ. So far, nobody has been beating
Squirtle.
>> Oh yeah, no one has been. But the thing
is when you only have two undefeated
10-0's at some point they're going to
have to match each other and that's
exactly what we are going to be seeing
here. Squirtle with that Azir versus
Great Pona on the right. Worth noting it
is Great Poner's first time at an RQ and
they are currently 10.
>> You know what that means?
>> What does that mean?
>> None of these players ever lost.
>> Yes.
That's incredible. And they finally
matched each other here. Looking at it,
it seems like it's going to be a very
fair match up when you look at the
matchup percentages there as well.
But what achievements so far there if
you are a Diana player at your first
ever RQ and you just, you know, you're
in one, you're in two, you think, okay,
three, four, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, and somehow
you're at a 10 and0 record. But that's
going to get tested now cuz we've
already you were mentioning could
Squirtle get starting to be in that goat
debate and he's playing that Azir deck
which he has won an RQ with before.
>> You got that double back of that card
can get nasty versus Diana but it
doesn't have to sometimes flash or write
the wind just save those units easy
peasy. But here we are seeing a deck
list that has one acceptable losses in
the main deck. Of course, a good card
versus the Azir strategy to get rid of
those equipments, but acceptable losses
a bit less strong than compared to
something like turn to dust because you
can't just choose ABF sword. You really
want to get rid of that if you're
getting rid of an eye of the Herald. I
don't know how impactful that is.
>> Yeah, it's interesting because you know
gear hate is rather high mostly for that
dazzling Aurora, but they only tend to
have one Aurora in place. You can play
something like an acceptable loss and it
will get the thing you want. Azir will
have a cornucopia of equipment and gear
in play. So you won't be able to pick
off the best one with such that gear
hate.
>> There's also more interesting
interaction in this matchup. You know,
you have Moonfall, the powerful
signature spell of Diana that is against
some decks used in the in the mid game
to gain some advantages versus these
tokenheavy decks. I would think that it
makes a lot of sense to wait with those
until the end game to actually get to
those big points where you're trying to
hold a little bit with some unit, maybe
a Kha'Zix, maybe a Hue, maybe a Vex, and
then wait for your opponent to push in
multiple of those sand soldiers. On the
other hand, I can see Azir player going
to stack up multiple equipments on one
unit and then starting to push with
multiple after another to play around
possible moonfalls or just slam defy.
>> But here we go. Our Swiss round 11
feature match here at the UK regional
qualifier. The battle of our only
undefeated players left is kicking us
off. Great pron has put down the tie
turner and pass over to Squirtle who's
going to put down the Dorian sword.
Activate that legend ability and the
sand soldiers are coming down.
>> Got that Doran shield start. Best two
drop in the game. However, so far things
are going decently well for the great
Poner. He can take that Raven Bloom
Conservatory. That is always nice
developed that Diana already does not
want to take it. Does not want to give
up a unit for a potential spell. I can
see how it is. You would just negatively
trade into one of the sand solders. So I
I definitely support that decision. But
>> the deck of Azir is not the best deck at
handling a Huay on site, right? You can
drop a Huay and then what else do you
have? You have hidden blade to kill at
the battlefield, but that is not on
site. Then other than that you don't
really have anything except for back off
and the vi except for like you know
heavy combat. So I think having a way
early on versus Azir is powerful. I
>> think you are right. There is another
Doloran sword coming down. Remember
those sand soldiers will have weapon
master so you can equip that if you
like. Oh, we're going to see a double.
>> I'm going to charge into the top battle
for there. The hall of legends and you
will get some recruits as well.
of legends really really multiplying
your value that you get out of the zir
readying it again for one energy and
then playing another one another sand
soldier to one of the strongest
battlefields for that deck by far.
>> So look at this free sand soldier in
play as well. Great Poner currently not
on the board via the points
only has chaos runes it's looking like
right now. Is that something to keep an
eye on right now?
Yeah, that is honestly incredibly
unfortunate for great pawn because
developing away early can be really
really strong in that matchup and you
are not allowed to do that. So that is
absolutely huge for Squirtle and I think
when he sees all of those six chaos
runes is that six chaos runes or is the
one on the right side maybe
>> oh
>> the mind one?
>> I mean the colors are matching quite a
bit.
>> Oh no there is. You're right. There is
one blue one there in the middle on the
right hand side and because there here
comes the way coming down as well.
>> I wait one point from holding
>> tie turner did accelerate. Well, not
accelerate but move into the Raven Bloom
Conservatory. That is a great
battlefield for the Der players of
course but as you say that way which
will be the way for great porner to win
this game. That wasn't intentional but
it sounded good didn't it? Has come
down.
>> Phenomenal.
>> I try my best Leah that's why I'm here.
So quite curious to see how we're going
to approach the point scoring
game here because you know Squirtle has
to send soldiers in base. None of them
have an item equipped themselves.
>> Uh-oh, there's the big one though. That
BF sword. That is the great equalizer
right there.
>> Going for five.
>> We have to expand a power to push that
sand soldier into the Titan. Super fire
is found. That's always nice to have.
Know it's not going to have the biggest
impact right now,
but who knows?
No, that's going to go through. I think
there you're not really going to try and
defend this Titan, but you want to try
and stack those resources, right? So,
having that stupify nice and early for
great poner, I'm sure that it's going to
come back up at some point.
>> One soldier,
>> it's going to be impossible for him to
make another sand soldier token in this
situation because he cannot
>> ready that Azier emperor of the sands
and then use it again. Only one rune up
and now it's on great ponra to deny
points that Skirtle can score. Right now
quite chill actually since he's at three
uneven scores. So he's not threatening
those mighty six just soon. So there's
still a little bit of time for would be
a little bit more urgent.
However, the thing is how are you
playing into this now? Do we start using
cards like right the wind? Do we set up
for bigger turns in the future? Or do we
just go way into this, discard a unit,
don't get the next draw, then ride the
wind over? Because Squirtle does have
quite some resources already built up.
And from the way he's playing,
could be in a rise coming down quite
soon. Already has three equipment here
on board.
>> Let's move.
Okay, so Hawaii is going to move into
that Raven Conservatory
>> trigger.
>> Oh, and there's of course going to be
the Raven Bloom Conservatory. Can we
find a defy
>> guards?
>> A guard.
>> It's not currently live though. You need
two to play that. So that is going to go
through. Her will take the Raven Bloom
Conservatory back for great poner.
Second point of the match.
One of the big downsides of the Raven
Bloom Conservatory is that yes, you are
playing a deck that almost always hits a
spell with this.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I mean, there's rarely a deck that
doesn't really play spells. It's good
against some things like Rexi where you
rarely hit or something like a Darius,
but most of the other decks, especially
those calm domain decks, they run Defy,
Ong Guard, Discipline, all of that good
stuff.
>> We're going into the Hall of Legends
now.
>> Let's find a Moonfall.
Not useful, I think, this turn. Oh,
maybe it could be perhaps one.
>> Oh, there we go. They're going to
immediately come into play there. That
signature spell
>> play and guard on this one. Response
>> in response to the move.
>> Yeah,
>> really nice response. So, the ong guard
gets the full two might instead of GS1
when it has resolved.
>> So, well, this will get it's plus two
minus two. So, it stays and this has
minus two. Mhm.
So we do see the reaction of the on
guard.
>> Does great pawnra have immediate might
modification here. Is that perhaps
>> a rather diff Oh
>> considering to go for the right the win.
Now the question is do you just
>> it was a stupify
>> save the Diana or do you shove over the
Hi to keep more units on board or are we
trying to dig a little bit deeper just
with the simplify here?
>> Sure.
>> Now I think we would have an even trade.
>> Uh no actions.
>> I think you are correct.
see how this pans out here
>> cuz the other sand soldier on the side
is not
>> Yes. It's just there for vibes at this
point. He's just cheering on his mate.
>> But you can't kill it.
>> Okay.
>> We are going to see the eclipse.
>> Yeah. Also, you can't kill it because
you have to assign damage to it. So, if
one might unit is at three might and the
other one is also at three might. If
there is a zero might unit, one unit
will not die.
>> Hide the card here.
>> Yeah.
>> We are going to hide a card there as
well. Tapped out though is great.
opponent though going back into
Squirtle's turn did essentially remove
all those sand soldiers from play. We
know guards is in the hand
can use that to get some in play I
guess.
>> I mean there is one playing it.
>> Oh, there is one. Sorry. Yeah, I I
missed him there in the on in the base.
>> Heart bargain is an insane card versus
the Azia strategy sometimes. But if you
can basically guarantee that your Arise
resolves, I think there's a good
argument to be made that you're just
>> Yeah, you're right.
If you see your Diana player is tapped
out, could you BF swords your sand
soldier? Just charge him on in. That
would be a trade, right? Seems like an
easy
>> Yeah, but I mean there's a hidden card,
so you have to
>> take into account that there could be a
possible tie turner.
>> Yeah, tie turner. That's most likely
what it's going to be, right? going to
still get a point then if you push a
>> true
>> sand soldier in there with a BF sword
and then you can arise later on. It's
actually a very very solid point. You're
threatening a double kill. Then you can
arise later on when the Hay has already
gone over to the Diana. There it goes to
11 might and after arising then
it's a good question if you can then
actually just uh still overpower it if
we're playing versus 11.
And
>> you could also double equip a Doran's
shield if you wanted to
>> not trade. But here we are. We are going
to see
>> Raven Conservatory trigger. Oh, that's
going to find a stupify. We are out
though.
>> That is a 5v5 currently.
>> I mean, it has to be a tight turner,
right? Hide there.
>> Yes.
>> So, that is going to bring extra value,
but as long as you are tapped out, that
is still rather rather tough. And I
think you if you are predicting a rise
to come, you're definitely going to try
and discard a unit. Don't even know if
you have too many units. That might look
like a Ka'Zix on the hand from Great
Ponder. So
>> that is an interesting one for this
matchup though. That Kha'Zix you can fly
in him with that ambush.
>> Oh, it's away.
>> Okay,
>> we're going up to 11 might on the Hall
of Legends.
>> And now, of course, the interesting
thing about weapon master is that you
can also steal from your other units.
Okay,
>> so you're ready two
and you use the weap master ability of
those two to grab a Doran shield and one
of the BF swords. So that's four extra
might. That's eight might in total. You
can deny the weapon master ability of
the other one. Float one more energy.
>> Important. Uh, so I do one
and I need to
>> equip Dorance and then discipline to at
least trade with Way and Diana and then
take away all of the units on board for
Diana.
>> F14.
>> Mhm.
>> I'll play accelerated.
>> Oh, champion is here.
>> It was the one floating short.
Oh, we didn't have enough runes for
that.
>> Champion the zero. Normally we see for a
big late game push. This is
>> 54. That's 11.
>> Definitely a bit earlier than you'd like
normally.
>> So you can now
>> equip.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Give this one tank. That is huge
already. If you can boost it up even
more.
>> Yeah.
>> Eye of the Herald. Okay,
>> that means we can get some recruits down
as well if it moves. Well, if it's
attached to does move.
>> 69
69.
>> Wow, this is a good turn.
>> Uh, move trigger. I will go with both.
>> Mhm.
>> Wow. Okay. And this is the strength of
the Azir deck. You can just spawn in
sand soldier
>> and
>> currently 13 to 11. And we know great
poner is tapped out
>> and they have to
>> I have to give him the tank.
>> Both sand soldiers go. They have tank.
>> Wow.
>> Big turn there. Leo clearing off the
battlefield.
>> Azir surviving there.
>> Question is also we have seen that the
way was discarded to grant three more
might. So the chances of a follow-up
Azir there is pretty low. We picked up a
wages of pain that could potentially be
very very relevant if we wages of pain
now and stupify.
>> Yes.
>> So we at least get rid of that Azir.
>> What are we finding now? Star cross,
smoke screen, and another supery. I
think we're good on superies for the
moment.
>> Star.
>> Maybe not.
>> Smoke screens. Was it star cost that was
taken there?
>> Might have been the star cross. Might
have been the super. Not too sure about
that. Yeah, it was the stupify.
>> I think you're right. So, it's going to
be the stupify into the rages of pain
combination.
>> Oh, that works as well, I guess.
>> But then, yeah, he picked up the Vex
Apathetic together with the stupify. So,
he knew, okay, if I don't wages of pain,
if I just gust this, I can develop this
big unit because you need to get
something on board.
>> And a Vex already immediate arise tapped
out. That is so big because the Vex
couldn't move to a battlefield yet. You
are going to be able to conquer two.
You're going up to seven. This is such
an uphill battle for the great pawner
here. This Arise was so confidently held
by Squirtle really showing why he is one
of the best players in the world right
now. That was the perfect turn for that.
You don't want to let that Vex apathetic
get onto the battlefield first. You can
go up there with your sand soldier army
that are all equipped with their gear,
high might and say, "Come on then. Let's
have a let's have a tussle, shall we?
We're going to charge into the Raven
Bloom Conservatory. We know that Dana
loves to hold that one.
>> And we are going to go into Hall of
Legends as well. We get to draw one off
that.
>> And I will hide a card.
>> Hiding a card. Most likely hidden blade
or it could be a guards as well. I
>> was going to say good chance that it is
actually gods stealing the BF sword from
the hall of legends sand soldier token.
Feel like we should start giving the
sand soldiers names. No great names,
>> individual names.
>> Yeah, it's so hard to always say the
sand soldier when there's four with
different equipment, you know.
>> Okay, let's call one Timmy then, shall
we?
>> All right, bottom one is Timmy. Top one
is Tommy.
>> See how long we can remember this.
>> Yeah, maybe that's stone.
>> Back over to Great Poner, though.
>> X is pushing.
>> The thing is with the Vex,
>> it's a death claw.
>> Uh,
>> death grip, I should say. Sorry,
>> that one helps. So, a few guards here
and it was the guards of the hidden.
That one is going to be stunned though.
But Vex would just recall and not
conquer here if you bring out the guards
and give it a nice little item
>> guards and you've got two Sun Soldier.
>> That is something you could definitely
hard bargain. There is no runes open
anymore on the side of Squirtle. Hard
bargain for full value there would help
with the push because there's only three
might hard bargain. Very easy solution
to that. Uses the
>> Diana as well. So takes the fourth
point.
>> Nice to have
>> but that does not quite help us here. Do
we still have a right the wind in hand?
So we can bring over that Vex into that
battlefield with Tommy the sand soldier
that has five might. I suppose that
should be the BF sword, right?
Fizz.
>> Where's his final moonfall then to move?
Was it Timmy off the
>> Moonfall? It
>> is going to be the Moonfall to move him
off.
>> And we get the conservatory trigger.
>> Yeah. And we get the conservatory
trigger as well. Top play there from the
Fizz stat. Don't mind it.
>> Okay. Great turn there from Great Proner
cuz my Squirtle was actually on seven
points. So, snuck his way up there as it
were.
>> It is still going to be rather hard
here. Yes, your opponent is going to
struggle. can't really arise in
anything, but if there's already two
units developed in base, Vex is not the
toughest unit to overcome it. There is
worse things in the world, but we have
so many runes up still. That should be
five. Diana has been used, so we know
what we're up against. Starcross could
be brutal. Azir Sovereign is not going
to help us much because Vex is sitting
in the battlefield.
that Vex, you know, stopping accelerated
units, units coming in play from
maneuvering on the same turn they would
played, effectively nullifying
accelerate. That would be normally this
is where you would see an Arise plus
Azir combination just to maneuver these
sand soldiers. I think Squirtle is up so
much in points. He can just take a turn
to develop stuff.
>> I don't mind it.
>> You can you can even consider playing
the Vi in base. I don't know if that is
what he's going to go for, but he is
going to use that BF sword first. floats
a rune here
>> and is now going to push into that Vex
apathetic battlefield.
>> Yes.
>> Next figure. Hey.
>> Hello.
>> No. What was
>> was it that wages of pain? That looks
like it was on that side of the hand.
>> I think I think we haven't used it yet.
>> I think that was the one from earlier. I
will figure it out. Okay. So, Vex is
still standing there. And now Squirtle
is giving Great Pawner the option to use
all of those runes that he left open in
the last turn.
>> We have here ride the wind.
>> Oh, Ride the Wind could be kind of risky
at six might on this sand soldier. 6
to4.
>> Yeah, I wouldn't want to give any I
wouldn't want to go any battlefields now
on Great Proner. If I'm being perfectly
honest, those sand soldiers can just get
out of hand. Yeah, the the biggest issue
for great ponra is he needs to keep that
Vex apathetic around because otherwise
Azir sovereign is just going to go
completely loco
>> stupify
does that help us in any sort of way
>> what are we what's old Timmy on there
two three six five
>> stat deck I think I think I make that
five right
>> he's got to try and find something
acceptable losses usually so strong
versus gear deck X. But here it's going
to just be the Eye of the Herald that's
going to get sacrificed.
>> He really needed a smoked screen or an
Eclipse
>> just to keep that Vex around.
>> Now the other option is to ride the wind
over the Vex into the other battlefield.
>> Acceptable losses. That has to be ID
herald, right? Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Have to try the wind.
>> Yeah.
>> Is going to be the ride the wind.
>> It's going to move Vex over.
>> That does cut it a little bit. That's
going to give Squirtle a draw though. is
going to conquer in the Raven Bloom
Conservatory. Doesn't get a point. Is
already at seven to pick up another
card.
>> Oh, and I think that a concession there
from Great Proner as Squirtle will win
game one here. Remember, both of these
players are currently 100. One player
will leave this with a loss, but
Squirtle has won game one.
>> And we also know why that is because we
have seen earlier with the Raven Bloom
Conservatory that the Death Grip was
picked up by Squirtle. After that, he
can just go, "Hey, Death Grip, you are
exhausted fully anyway. So, I'm going to
just kill my sand soldier at that
battlefield at the conservatory. Put all
of that might onto my sand soldier. If I
really want to, I can put all the
equipment on it as well." And then just
run into that vex with 20 might. You're
not going to stop that, especially not
when you're exhausted. So, again, a
masterclass of a play by Squirtle.
>> Yeah, watching Squirtle play here is
just, you know, so patient. held that
arise, did everything correctly, played
the equipment down, attached it when he
needed to. Used the Aziz sovereign a lot
earlier, I think, than what a lot of
Azir players would prefer, but turned
out to be the perfect way to clear that
battlefield. And that is why he's 10
games and zero losses. I think the key
to use your chosen champion unit in Azia
versus Diana or versus any chaos deck
basically is use it when you really get
the chance to do so because otherwise at
some point when you're getting pushed
out of if you're just going wide in base
if you're preparing for a big turn your
opponent conquers a battlefield and then
slams a vex down
>> and then you cannot really go for your
Azir sovereign at least not that easy.
So if they can protect the Vex, you are
lacking pushes. So you're making the
most out of the out of it as soon as you
can.
There we can see the deck list again.
What do you think Great Prona can be
side decking right now to sort of
helping him help him in this scenario?
>> If he runs cards like Turn to Dust,
those are a lot more helpful in this
matchup. If you can get rid of that BF
sword,
>> that is a high high value target. those
one drop, two drop gears,
it's not too hot to to kill any of them.
Acceptable losses really
is lackluster versus the deck because
after the first turn, you know, the the
first gear that is being played just
counts towards a rise that makes it
better and just there to give you a sand
soldier token basically. So, I I would
leave that card in 100%. Can also be
used as a nice combat trick very early
in the game.
>> Yeah.
However,
turn to dust, I think, is would be a
great idea. No, acceptable losses. A
little bit better versus something like
Aurora or seals decks
>> for sure.
>> But I mean, also not too much better
versus Aurora because if you're playing
versus something like a Civer, Civer is
going to have X amount of gold tokens
lying around on the battlefield. And
then if you acceptable losses, they're
just going to sacrifice those or the
cryers bloom. And then you're going to
have a whole sort of other problems.
Unless of course your opponent
write the wins
or just plays Aurora and then goes into
a battlefield and then you get to
acceptable losses.
>> So it looks like
>> salvage.
>> Our game two battlefields will be seats
of power and Targon's Peak. Targon's
Peak is a very interesting one letting
you ready runes when you conquer it at
the end of
>> You're Annie then.
>> Yeah, you're essentially Annie when you
conquer a Targon's Peak. of that and
seat of power. A little bit of extra
card draw as well can help out both
players where I think the Ravens Bloom
Conservatory was probably more so I'd
say uh better in the Dana deck. We did
see it obviously hit for Squirtle. I
think both of these battlefields can be
used by both players.
>> Raven Bloom Conservatory hit quite a lot
in that game
>> and still it wasn't enough for great
Ponra to overcome Squirtle's Azir.
>> It's remarkable to see how he pilots the
deck. Just the patience on those plays.
Oh, wow. Is that a whiff? Are we
actually any equipment in that hand? No.
>> Ah, is that a brutalizer?
>> I thought it was on guard times two.
>> On guard is there's another card.
>> Or have we not mulligan yet? Because
then
>> he hasn't mulligan yet. That's what
>> deciding what to mulligan. But I don't
see no equipment yet though
>> because Angar is quite a good card.
>> No, it is. No, it is. So, but so but so
is equipment when you're playing as
here.
>> That is a very good point. Now, great
pawn now contemplating what tumal
>> keeping. What is
>> I think that's a brutalizer.
>> Yes. So, that is a brutalizer.
>> And if you are going second then Oh,
he's holding
>> is a one drop basically.
>> Okay. All right then. So, here we go.
Game two. Our Swiss ride 11 feature
match here. The UK regional qualifier.
Rain blue student coming down and it is
back over to SW. That rain student can
get out of hand by the way. But there is
the brutalizer. Azir Legend will
activate San Soldier
>> coming in.
>> Squirtless on a We've just heard that.
24 game win streaks.
>> 24 game win streak. That is
>> mad, isn't it?
>> That is
mindboggling is the phrase I'm going to
use for that.
>> Sure,
>> I would agree. I know that is a play
that we have seen so many times from
Diana. just develop Diana, push a two
drop into the Targon's peak and then sit
there at the end of the turn with you
forgot your Targon's peak there.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I was about to say that.
Should be should be ending it up here
for lack of a better term. But
>> okay,
>> is over to Squirtle now and try to
>> on stage a lot of things can happen. The
nerves up there, it's it's crucial. You
know, so many players are watching that
mistakes can happen there.
>> Camera's light.
>> They're not. Yeah,
>> it all adds up.
>> Watch stupify.
>> Uh, results
>> plus one.
>> He gets to draw one. But I don't think
that's going to the stupify maps won't
matter though.
>> No. Plus one. It's uh three.
>> We have another
rune up. We have just used Diana.
Another stupify. And that's going to
actually cut it. Was that just a bait?
Did we just Did we just mind game
Squirtle into thinking he's safe to
attack?
>> Play and guard.
>> On guards.
>> Oh, but on guard. Yeah, that cuts it.
Wait, so were you suggesting he missed
the Targon's peak on purpose to bait the
sand soldier in and into the double
stuper fight?
>> Maybe
>> that would be one play right there. But
unfortunately, it did not work. Oh, and
Azir Sovereign has come down. Yeah. And
of course, Squirtle has the Targon's
Peak trigger, therefore can just easily
easily ready two runes with the Ong
Guard in hand. Usually, this deck is not
known for being too interactive on the
opposing turn. Of course, you have a
few, but sometimes there are just these
big gear heavy hands that are much
better
>> in other battlefields there. But I mean,
Squirtle, he's sitting on his hand
soldier. Two super fights are already
out. You cannot underestimate in those
mid games how much of a combat trick
Superfy really is. Quay is being
developed.
>> So, I think that might cut it. a hold
that early for Squirtle is huge when it
comes to the points in the end game.
Already has the Azia sovereign developed
as well. Big question is going to be is
he just going to push it into the seat
of power to draw an extra card.
Draw drawing cards is good. I don't
think there's any way for him to try and
remove this way though, right? There's
no way to force it around. I think
looking at this list, no, I don't think
so. So, the way I imagine will be
staying but yeah, do you just start
trying to hold at this point? start
trying to make your opponent ask
questions. Is there I haven't seen much
equipment though.
>> Does he have something like a BF sword?
Another brutalizer that can just make
another token. Pushing that Azir into
the seat of power
>> would mean that you're going to lose it
next turn for sure. It's going to be one
draw and you really want that draw. But
sometimes that guards
>> Oh, here we go. Right on Q. The guards.
Well,
>> it has an exclamation mark. Okay. Have
to give it a bit of bit of gum. I try
that again. Guards. Is that better?
>> That's it.
>> There we go.
The guards are there. We got Timmy,
James, and Bob.
>> Love myself on Bob.
>> All right.
>> Is over to Great Poner, though. The way
is out. So is a Diana.
>> It's going to be a big turn here.
>> The deadliest triangle formation of the
Sans just chilling in base. And that is
one of these decks that can handle Vex
just as it was. Nothing. You don't
ambush a lot of stuff. Yes, you have VI,
but that's completely optional. You have
big units in base already. Who cares
>> about those? Seat of power plus Diana
trigger is going to be a lot of value
though.
>> Yeah,
>> maybe.
>> Yes,
>> it is.
>> And I conquer the second.
>> Remarkably strong spell versus the Azia
strategy sometimes.
>> Depends if they got that that BF sword
equipped though, right?
>> Yeah. But I mean most of these units
just go to three might if they have a
brutalizer for longer or eye of the
herald or the doran shield. However, if
there is a discipline or ong guard gust
is really not the greatest card. It can
be countered so incredibly easily and a
vex is again developed in base. This is
a story we have seen over the entire
weekend. Very rarely
>> something
>> people play vexes and the hidden tie
turner we imagine. Oh, if if I think if
you're hiding a card in the way
battlefield
>> that might be
>> okay. Yeah. No, you are you are correct.
>> Think we did get the Targon's Peak
activation there as well. I believe
looks like it. Okay. Big turn here for
Squirtle.
Here we go.
Tension is rising.
>> A lot of decisions to be made in that
hand. I think I saw a rise.
>> Guards four. Four.
>> What you said? Guards
>> just yelling guards.
>> There's an exclamation mark as well.
Here we go.
Oh, VIP peacekeeper highlighted. I
really do like that because the Vex is
still in base. That might be a huge play
for this turn. Might be a huge surprise.
This is a big sand soldier boosted by
Brutalizer effect.
>> Oh yeah, if it is attached on the same
turn, it gives an extra one.
>> Wages of pain would do nothing here.
>> Wait, we're at six. No,
>> that is crazy. If we tie Turner over and
we w off pain, then we still don't kill
the sand soldier. Six might be the magic
number here.
>> Yes.
>> No action for swap.
>> Yo.
>> Wow.
What a turn. The double move on the way.
The double tie turner.
into the moonfall.
>> That is a lot of movement for the
opponent.
>> Yeah. For an opponent turn. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Playing musical chairs as it were with
that Hawaii said. Oh, I'm over there.
Nope. Now I've come back.
>> And now contemplating whether or not
great pawner wants to discard a unit or
a spell
>> for one.
>> Oh, we have discarded the gust.
>> I'll play and guard. Sorry 10 might
>> on god
>> that would be enough to take out the
>> be right now it's uh six so it will be
an eight
>> yeah it's okay
>> results
>> Squirtle really wants to get rid of that
way great pawner on the other hand of
course needs to protect Diana's queen
basically you know inelia
>> that's a different unit
>> actually yeah there much similar play
style like where coming like that
wrecking ball you know gaining momentum
going from that battle back and then
back discarding Off screen. Smoke
screen.
>> Smoke screen from Origins. Almost
forgotten in spirit forged format, but
one of the most impactful combat tricks
in single combat.
>> That's a minus four. Looks like that has
gone through.
>> Any other tips and tricks? V is in the
hand, remember? But that would exhaust
pretty much all your runes,
leaving you with two. I think I'd make
that.
But sometimes if needs must, Leo, if
needs must.
>> Wow. A V here would actually slap really
hard, I think. I mean, it's in the
hands. You when you've invested so much
resources, you can't just let your
opponent win like that.
>> Okay.
I mean, there's still three runes open
for a Gab Ponra. Who knows what he has
in hand. If you commit a V here and
you're not 100% sure if you're going to
win that combat, you're opening yourself
up to a massive risk.
>> Oh, the double brutalizer though on the
next Sam Soldier. Here goes Timmy
getting ready.
>> And here we go again. The way is in
trouble.
>> I'll try going.
>> So, this is currently what? Eight on
eight. That's a that's currently a trade
at this moment in time
>> of the because Squirtle, he does not
care if he wins this combat. He just
wants it to happen. He wants to get rid
of the way. Doesn't necessarily need the
conquer because you can always take that
with the other sand soldier and then
push it into the seat of power as well
with the Azir Sovereign there just
forces great Ponra to react to this. But
is there even anything he can do?
>> I'm not sure.
>> Sorry.
>> Uh three.
>> That does look like a moonfall. It does
look like a moonfall
>> and we cannot defy that right now
because we do not have calm runes.
Great. Ponra has to take that into
consideration that this cannot be defied
right now. One of the biggest risks of
playing Oh, actually
>> he's just going to go through the trade.
Timmy's gone and done it. Hawaii has
been sent to the trash.
>> Gone away.
>> Love that.
>> Thank you.
>> Squirtle's done it that way. Oh, wait a
second. Is that the moment for
>> Are you thinking a rise?
>> No, I think if you arise here and you
get hard bargained,
>> you lose.
>> True. Yes, there is still enough room
open for that. You are correct.
>> I think just pushing the sand soldier
into the targon's peak and then going
into the seat of power
with maybe
>> four four.
>> Hey, does he have a BF sword?
>> There is a BF sword in hands. I did see
that before.
>> That would be really nice because you do
have
all the
>> There it is.
>> Yeah,
>> that BF sword. Honestly, you give a sand
soldier a BF sword, it becomes a titan.
Six might every No, five might I should
say.
Could even give it to your sovereign.
Now going to protect the sovereign of
course that is going to get attached to
the sand soldier. currently have five
might unit.
>> Of course, we have played in equipment,
so we can get another sand soldier down.
Of course,
>> I'll try to go here for five.
>> Goes into the targon's peak.
>> Go to three.
>> Oh, I like that. I think he's trying to
go for the draw in the seat of power.
Pushing Azia sovereign and then just
perhaps using the sand soldier that has
just been equipped by brutalizer into
the seat of power to be able to get a
draw.
Or are we just taking everything to
ensure that we
>> win here?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, we'll grab the other sand soldier.
Moving it to seat of power as well.
>> We have seen smoke screen. I think we
have seen an eclipse as well already.
>> And usually Diana does not run so many
different kinds of those.
>> We know Moonfall did get taken though.
>> A star cross could be
>> Oh, is going to move over the other BF
sword. sand soldier as well.
>> Oh, oh, oh.
>> Oh,
>> look at the moonfall in hand. Let's do
the math together.
>> Please help me.
>> I'll try.
>> Oh, that would be two, three, five.
>> That would still
>> So, this
three.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Eight.
does still lose the combat,
>> but takes out the Azir and the sand
soldier that has the BF sword equipped
to it.
>> Uh,
>> oh wow. Okay,
>> we're trying to hold.
>> Well, when you got Vex apathetic
knocking on the door now, you have to
try and, you know,
>> present some kind of offensive threat
cuz what you can't have Vex apathetic do
is catch your lacking, for lack of a
better term. Especially if you haven't
got units in your base, you have to
present some sort of a threat to deal
with it. Here is a stack deck though.
Great turn from Squirtle. Great poner.
We've seen a lot of resources been used.
Now
this one,
>> you know, I think that was exactly the
moon for that great pona needed. That
was one that couldn't be defied because
there were no calm runes anymore. And as
we said in the beginning, it is about
those big combats where multiple units
are involved. The maximum amount of
might that you get out of that moonfall
>> turn to dust. I imagine that's targeting
the BF sword.
>> Yeah, we already put it to trash. It's
not going to do anything anyways. And
now we're passing on that turn. I think
that great pawn is in a phenomenal
position right now to win this game.
>> I think so.
>> It's just slightly behind in
>> runes. Did not use a gust on that sand
soldier. Well, he couldn't because it
was when the temporary trigger happened
still at five might or more.
>> V. Pace keeper coming down and
>> passing just developing here
so far ahead in runes and keep in mind
great porner does have hard bargain in
hand. So next turn when Squirtle is at
six and wants to go for this big arise
turn that is the freest bargain that you
can ever imagine.
>> Hard bargain increasing the cost of your
opponent's spell.
>> Yeah.
>> So the tools false curdle in this game
are limited. Oh, what is his max? What
is his Fizz going to take, I should say?
>> Do we have something like a right one?
Oh, a moon.
>> Moonall.
>> So, is that going to bring in that's
going to bring in the buy
>> and Yeah.
>> And that gets immediately sent to the
trash.
>> That moon forward is just so deadly,
isn't it, Leo?
>> The divide going down to three might
Could
not have taken the fizz then if it was
down to three.
>> I'm also quite curious.
>> Get conf sort of buff. Was it stunned?
It wasn't stunned.
>> Maybe because of the Vex effect. Is it
not does not do any combat damage or
>> No.
>> Well,
>> just stunned. The turn it was played
out.
Well,
>> either way, it's been sent to the trash
now.
And looking at that handler, there's not
a lot of options. Just Dan Shield, the
Arise.
So,
>> we can use our Azir Legend here if you
like after playing that equipment. Or is
this going to be the Arise turn? Okay,
we're going to move over.
>> Okay,
>> the seat of power conquer there going up
to six. Relatively close game, all
things considered.
>> And Squirtle can smell that hard
bargain. He has played this match up so
many times before. He knows if I slam
this without enough runes, I'm going to
lose this game. But also, next turn does
look quite dangerous. Is only at five
runes. So, it's going to be seven. That
does not play around hard bargain even a
little bit.
Great pawn, I think, equals up to six.
>> Yeah, sure. Sure.
>> Does have another fizz in hand.
>> That's what was checking for. What could
uh any potential Fizz be taking? Here
comes that Fizz.
>> What are the options?
>> I don't think we ever seen a Starross.
>> No,
>> I don't think there's another moon fall.
So, it's just going to be a a stuperify.
Get a draw one at the very least.
>> Yes, Diana held to six at the beginning
of this turn.
>> Do we Is that setting up a ride the
winter?
>> As I was about to say, do we have a way
of sliding
the
>> unit over there? Why would obviously do
that?
>> Yeah, because seed of power
the sand soldier there now is only at
three. I think that's double D shield
attached to it or one D shield one.
Yeah, and we gust it. Don't even need to
write the wind necessarily. Something we
could do on the opposing turn.
>> I think at this point when you are at
six, you just want all the flexibility.
I don't think it's the moment for
offensive. You can only go up
>> Yeah. Yeah. to seven at max. You want to
stay at that six and have offensive
slash defensive capabilities. Now, the
big question I'm asking myself is how is
Squirtle going to handle this? Because
the Horizon's hand is also absolutely
useless as long as that Vex is on the
battlefield. That alone, the hard
bargain in hand. So, you would think
that the way to play this is to buff up
the sand soldier with as many equipment
that you can have and then just run into
that Tagon's peak, right? But when that
happens, a right the wind into the seat
of power would immediately threaten game
for the great pawnra
>> because you get that conquer point on
the seat of power and then you're
holding there as well and
>> Arise is still shut off. So it's a three
card hand and you need to play basically
around two of those cards.
>> Arise just into all of them.
>> Yeah, this is looking like dire
situation but I think here we go.
>> Double D. Is that was that a double dash
shield? Is that a brute? Don't
>> I think he found a defile? That is a
massive rip off the top.
>> That is huge.
>> Being able to stop that right the wind
is so much stronger in this scenario. So
much
more valuable.
Question is how many runes does great
pawn have open? I think it's four.
>> Yeah,
>> B3. I'll try and red.
>> So, we have two left after this. So, we
can cast one hard bargain if this is
defied.
That would be an amazing turn of events.
>> I'll try to play defy.
>> There's a defy.
>> Does he see it?
is contemplating over using the hard
bargain to possibly take away some of
the runes that Squirtle has to his name
right now. But I think keeping it to
bait your opponent into using the arise
and then hard bargaining that is the
much better play here. Take out the hard
bargain, you out tap them for the next
turn, then you can possibly try to win
the game off of that Fizz.
Okay, it's such an interesting turn of
events here.
>> A Squirtle play arise. Two runes still
left open. Hard bargain casted
immediately.
>> Wow, what a play. The hard B coming in
at the correct time. He was holding it
for the longest of time. Great Ponera,
but really stung it right when he needed
to.
That is no runes almost anymore on the
side of Squirtle. Squirtle can trade
this off with both of these fizz and
then threaten a hold. So now goes into
the seat of power. What else do we have?
Do we have something like star cross
bounces the sand soldier token grade
pawn takes this game beats Squirtle the
first one in 24 games.
Wow. How's that's not bad for your first
ever RQ, right? And we're going to a
game three. Remember both of these
players are currently 10.
The winner of this will advance to 110
record. Great Pronero are putting on a
master class. Played that so patiently.
Leo held those cards and used them on
not only at a good time. Didn't use them
at a great time. Used them at a perfect
time.
>> Exactly. Waiting for that hard bargain.
knowing, hey, if I just hard bargain
this defy, I take two runes off of him
and then he maybe switches to another
play because he had the option
>> Mhm.
>> to still develop in the base then. But
this hard bargain was so incredibly
important. Even though I do think the
hard bargain would have also won the
game on the defy could have just played
the gear from hand and then developed a
soldier and base that would have not
changed the way how the fizz plus star
crossed still conquer both battlefields.
I think just the existence of that hard
bargain won in the game. It was cooler
on the horizon though.
>> It was and it's just sort of that sort
of minaxing, isn't it? Turning good
plays into great plays and great plays
into perfect plays. Just really, you
know, as you say, if you was to defy
earlier, you would maybe be able to
change strategy, but on that arise just
immediately shuts things down. H no it
was I think it was important because
otherwise you just play that sand
soldier token into that battlefield
trying to hold there together with the
other gear then you can also like suck
in a BF sword. I I don't think the BF
sword was there anymore. It was turned
to dusted.
>> It was turned to dusted. You are
correct. But yeah, looking back
>> here we go. Win prediction based on
legend matchup performance and recent
form does favor Squirtle. But you know
what? When it comes to game threes, I
don't think favors and all that matters.
It's just going to be who will win one
game. Will it be our Lil RQ champion
Squirtle or Great Poner even though it
is their first time at RQ putting on a
masterclass 100 and taken one game off
Squirrel. So it's all going to a game
three.
>> I mean looking at the accomplishes
accomplishments of these rift bounders.
>> Both of them are first in something,
right? We have the first place from the
last RQ and we have the first time
participant. So both are winners. I
would say those are very equal
accomplishments. last game. Trifarian
war camp and abandoned hall. We are
going to see some mighty mighty units.
>> Abandoned hall in a game three could get
a bit silly. But here we go. Game three
getting started. Soul sword coming down.
Sand soldier is over to great poner.
That is very very interesting because
now you can see the Diana but we have
acceptable losses. Acceptable losses is
an action. So once Squirtle pushes in
the sand soldier into the trifarian war
camp.
>> Thank you.
>> Great pawn can use the acceptable losses
to get rid of the sword and then next
turn win a combat with the Diana versus
the sand soldier without having to use
any sort of combat tricks. Those small
little moments in those games they can
really help.
>> Exactly that
sensible loss is coming. That is going
to remove that soul sword immediately.
As you do say that Diana prevents much
more of an offensive threat now
>> valuewise acceptable losses is a one for
one if you're not playing any items
yourself.
>> Yep.
>> This time around with those sand soldier
spawning.
>> It does really feel like a neg one.
>> Because the unit is still there. You're
just going to perhaps get a favorable
trade. But be aware there might be
>> for sure
>> something to stop you like an ong guard.
Only one rune left. Squirtle actually
using the Diana ability, finding a star
cross. Always nice to have
great pawner here with the extra cards.
No way yet in hand in game one and game
two. We have seen a second or third turn
develop of Quay.
>> Try to play on guard.
>> Oh, and there you do say the on guard
has come up immediately.
I
>> So now we're actually
>> wait
>> we're leaprogging though
by far war campers. I keep that into
account.
>> He doesn't have a good answer for this.
>> Great poner.
>> Yeah, he just has he has to search
something with these stacks.
>> I was going to say yeah I think he
reached over the top now
>> and there he found it.
>> But that is quite costly actually in
those early games using stack decks and
superfice that does hurt a little bit
because what are you going to build up
after this? You don't have the target
speak to generate runes for you. So
you're going to be defenseless
afterwards on this Diana supery first
puts it to an even three might for might
trifarian war.
>> Trifarian walk out
>> and then the next
>> but then if you're expending two stupify
just to get around a sand soldier with
no equipment as you do say
>> it's good thinking about next. So I
conquer
>> and now you know I confused the three
might with four might on the trifarian
war camp. That makes a real big
difference in the next turn because
usually the soul sword the sand soldiers
just have three might but in the
trifarian war camp they on four might
meaning that he could go for an easy
double kill without getting gusted.
>> Yeah, you are immune to the gust with
the trifarian war cam. We're going to
see the raven blue student coming down
is over to Squirtle now.
I love how great Ponra also identifies
that and goes, "Yeah, well, I was
probably the only combat trick I have in
hand right now is the gust and that is
not going to be relevant. So, I'm just
going to play that raven bloom." Even
though that does mean that Squirtle
doesn't have to play around anything.
>> He just plays a soul sword now and
pushes it onto the sand soldier. Loses
one rune in that process. However, great
pona loses the Diana. We're going to be
able to make a sand soldier token.
>> Squirtle immediately applying the
pressure here.
Oh,
going to be the Azir sovereign coming
down. I like this. Apply that pressure
in a game three. For sure your opponent
to answer every single question.
Great poner now only has that Raven
Bloom student developed, but we do have
abandoned hall up so we know things can
get out of hand and get ridiculous with
the Raven Bloom student there. Squirtle
is already up in points and he is
dictating where this game is happening.
He wants it to be in the Trafarian War
camp immune to gusts most of the time
and of course abandoned hall is a
nightmare to play against. Now great
pawnra takes the easy point in the
abandoned hall wants to say hey I want
to play in the abandoned hall too. I
want to make most use out of all of
these spells that I have and stack deck
as a combat trick for example.
>> Yeah.
>> However that is going to give Squirtle a
hold before he goes for the next pushes.
>> Oh okay. Vex apathetic coming down. That
is scary. That means units that come
into play will not be able to move from
the base. They will lose any accelerator
or anything like this. That is a big
card to find there.
>> How risky is playing Vexpathetic into
this battlefield. There is a sand
soldier token alive and kicking. There
is the Azio sovereign and a huge huge
token on the Tfarian Wam that can be
pulled in. There is multiple answers on
the hand of Squirtle. does have two
defies. That could be absolutely
crucial. Pushing in to the abandoned
hall with everything. Wants to take out
the entire board state of great pawn.
Wants to get the early head start here.
This is 8 to six might. Great ponra now
might be able to with spells to push the
raven bloom student. However,
>> that won't happen if you have defies in
hand. As I was about to say, those
double having a defy in hand might be
giving us insight into why students do
this stack deck first.
>> And that is not something that you'll
love to see as Crystal. I can tell you
that much because that is not the card
that you necessarily want to defy
because it is not a real combat trick if
your opponent has something like a
moonfall in hand. That is something you
really really need to stop. Or a stupify
because it also really hurts you. A
stupify would tip things to eight to
seven.
>> We did see two stupifies get used
already though. Yeah, that is true.
Maybe it was. Oh, yeah, it was.
>> Uh,
>> there's a hidden blade in that hand as
well.
>> Oh, wait. But also, Squirtle has a lot
of cards in hand. One of those is V
peacekeeper.
>> Peacekeeper.
>> It would get stunned from the Vex.
However, Oh, he finds a Moonfall
actually resolves the stack deck. Now
we're at 88.
>> Oh, goodness gracious.
>> Priority might go back to Squirtle and
then it's on to him to decide.
>> Do I want to offer a even trade? It's
>> which I think he could be fine with. He
has almost infinite value with those
sand soldiers.
>> I think an even trade I'd be happy with.
>> Or do you just pass priority back? Great
poner could then opt to use the moon for
that he found, but you could defy that.
>> Yeah.
>> And that would be an interesting turn of
events. So great poner was also eyeing
up the flash in his hand there. So could
be used opting to go for that as well if
it all you know that's like your big
emergency big red button isn't it that
flash
>> can only use one of those
flash will be defied. Squirtle is going
in and now he has used the defy. He can
use the abandoned hall that is going to
tip his might over the edge. Great Ponra
should have taken that trade perhaps. is
going to gust his own Raven Bloom
student would still mean that he loses
the Vex. If you defy this, your opponent
is fully tapped out now. He is at your
mercy, Squirtle. Do you want to defy
this or do you want to keep Defy for the
late game or is this the late game
already? I think this is the late game.
We are going to see the double defy.
This abandon hall showdown has gone
exactly how Squirtle wanted it to go.
And I think you're so correct. Don't
save him for the late game. This is the
late game. This is a game three with
only 6 minutes on the clock.
>> Squirtle applying that pressure and look
at his runes. He is sitting there with
so much might is going to take out Vex
and the Raven Bloom student at the cost
of merely probably just Azia the
sovereign
and then he can still develop perhaps a
Vi in base even though I don't even know
if you necessarily want to do that.
>> Oh, do we? We do want to save the sand
soldier or the Azia. So, we're going to
bring in that V. Vi is going to get
stunned. Not helping with the combat,
but is denying the damage from Vex.
Everything survives. That is absolutely
massive.
>> Leo, talk about a tempo turn in a game
three situation.
>> Squirtle clearing the board.
>> Look at those units. Can even preserve
the sand soldier. There's a lot of might
on board. Leo, great poner is out of a
lot of resources. I see a hidden card as
well. Leo.
>> Yes.
>> Two stupifies down.
>> That might be gods. That might be
>> hidden blade. Hidden blade was in hand.
>> Hidden blade. I don't think you want to
hidden blade your own units there to be
honest. I don't think you want to hidden
blade Azia or buy this.
>> I say if you're going to start trying to
get tricky with me, hidden blade have
some of that.
>> He is at four points. That is going to
give him six points next turn with a
hold. Then you can push into the
trifarian war camp one of the sun
soldiers. Yeah. Retreat the Azir. Take
back the sand soldier. Open both
battlefields and say, "Hey, you know
what?
>> I give you no unit to trade away for."
>> Viz coming down. It's going to be stack
deck.
>> Stack deck.
>> Oh,
>> that is Look at the the light smile on
Squirtle's face in this situation
saying, "Hey, you spent three energy
just to resolve a stack deck.
>> Carry on." Yeah, keep doing that, my
son. Keep carrying on doing that.
forcing the fizz down as well.
>> And the traveling merchant. Not the most
explosive turn there, Leo. Let's be
honest. Squirtle going up to five. I can
easily get to six as well.
Now, the hidden blade hidden at the
abandoned hall is still one of the
reasons why I'm quite curious to see how
this turn is going to go. Maybe we're
pushing that sand soldier up into that
abandoned hall and then kill it with our
own hidden blade and then preserve Azir
and the Vi.
Yeah, contemplating contemplating here
too. Squirtle not too sure about this.
The hidden blade in a little bit of a
pickle.
>> Pushes up sand soldier.
>> Maybe you just leave it there then to
threaten a double hold perhaps.
>> Azia goes back. Does Azia only pull
units to battlefields?
>> When I attack. Yeah. Okay. So it doesn't
pull back the sand.
>> Sorry for that. So threatening a double
hold here with the you know the hidden
hidden blade as well and that sun
soldier there who's currently what two
three four
okay threatening game if great poner
can't answer these question it shouldn't
be too hard to push one of these off but
does have to do it here we go fizz being
eyed up here
what we got star cost in hand a moonfall
important important turn.
>> One of the things that great Ponra has
going for him is that two defies have
been used. You are
>> in such a good state when it comes to
runes. Your turns are
>> stronger.
>> Showdown up there at the top. Triarian
walk out Moonfall.
>> And do you bring in that VI or that
Azir?
>> Soldier.
>> Brings in the sand soldier
>> hidden blade. So now you get the draw
two at the very least
>> unless it doesn't resolve. There might
be
>> might be a star cross as a response. But
what kind of star cross would that be?
Picks up two cards. Oh my goodness. Did
he pick up discipline? That is insane.
>> Talk about a time to have it, right?
>> This is three to four.
>> Yes. Yes. Wait for is
Indeed. Treat the four
>> and the discipline. The
>> discipline found of the hidden blade.
Leo.
>> Okay.
>> Says, "Okay, so we're going to draw
another card. More resources. A mast for
Squirtle to win the game next turn.
While great pawn will have to use more
cards.
>> Yeah, it's normal. It's normal
>> to even stay in this game.
>> Does he have a combo trick? you have
anything to fight back in this the way
in hand is way too late.
>> Yeah, star cross onto a usually a
powerful play but not in this not in
this scenario though. So I think
>> there's a good option that you kind of
have to do that unless you have another
stupify
>> starross. Starross.
>> Starcross.
>> Where'd you return? What? The sand
soldier
>> decisions.
Short freeze.
Does great porn find himself in a
position Raid doesn't see a way out of
I wouldn't be surprised this is looking
like dire straits here the sand soldier
does survive at Trifarian war camp
traveling merchant
>> if that sand soldier survives the Azia
sovereign attacks next turn with the
support of a VI with the support of the
sand soldier that is threatening the
holding seven point on that trifarian
war camp way is discarded tries to find
another cut that can help you holding
raven bloom student plus a stupify in
hand could cut it
>> good
that is the last dupify
>> dangerous cards in the abandoned hall
>> but are they enough
>> are they enough
>> the raven bloom student against the Azir
sovereign plus a vibe plus sand soldiers
Looks like that is going to go through.
Leo
>> is coming back down.
>> Oh, fizz might be able
>> crossfall.
>> Moonfall
this.
>> I dig it. Taking out
>> I think that sand soldier.
>> Yeah.
>> And abandoned hall is going to make the
traveling merchant stronger.
What does Squirtle have as an answer?
>> I'll try to play hidden blade on your
>> A hidden blade on the traveling
merchant. You're taking away resource.
>> Absolutely insane turn there. Just
closing the door for great poner.
>> Anyway, he's got to get back into this
game. Squirtle has denied and Squirtle
takes game three. advancing to that
perfect record and in Scrrenon that
perfect winning streak as well.
He is absolutely insane on a roll. So
many wins in a row. Undefeated in this
tournament again. He's already a
champion. He's aiming towards another
champion spot.
Wow. Honestly, the Azir master class
there playing everything so well. This
is our game one highlights where he was
just off to the races ridiculously fast.
>> Shay,
>> yes, he has played. I'm not sure about
game one, at least game two and three
without a rise.
>> Oh yeah, it's a good point. And he's
still winning.
>> That is the most powerful card of the
deck. That is the card where people say,
"Yeah, if you don't draw your arise, the
deck is bad." No. Squirtle still
overpowers his opponents. I
>> mean, how many times have you heard
people say, "Oh, yeah, it's just an
Arise plus sovereign, you know, finish
the end game." Squirtle didn't have
that.
>> Yeah,
>> we never saw that, you know, that tried
and tested Arise versus Aiz sovereign to
just move everything over cuz this was a
Yeah, that's when they got hard bargain.
This was game two, I believe. Right.
Yeah, that was game two where Great
Porno, let's not, you know, let's not
let's not gloss over Great Porn there.
It's his first time RQ and took Squirtle
the Azir god. I think it's safe to say
to a game three. This game three, you
know, Squirtle did get off to the races.
Great porn did mount a decent comeback
here though with the vex apathetic turn.
But then this was the turn though. The
double the far end flash not today. Gust
not today. And I'll take the abandoned
hall.
>> And I'll take the abandoned hall as
well. And I think from there great porn
was on the back foot. But Squirtle was
just answering all those questions. And
in the end, it's going to be a bit more
than a traveling merchant and a fizz for
you to topple Squirtle as he advances.
What's that? 11 and zero.
>> That is absolutely marvelous.
>> 11 and that's more things. I can't even
hold my hands up for as many as 11 wins
as that. Hold up for me. That's as many
wins as Squirtle has. How many losses?
>> Insane.
>> Splendid.
so incredibly strong, especially without
using cards like a race and he had them
in hand right in game two. I mean, he
was eventually losing game two because
of that hard bargain, but still showing
that the meticulous play of that deck if
you set your conqueror right like every
single in the games he won, every single
conquer attempt was a success.
>> Yeah. And I love that VI peacekeeper
just adds a whole another layer to that
deck. Before that, you had a lot of
might. You didn't have a lot of
flexibility. Now you can also play
threatening cards from hand during
combat. That is absolutely huge. Before
that was on guard. It was discipline. I
don't even think there were too many
crazy other cards that you could drop
for hand. Now you are threatening at
least once in a game that a VI
peacekeeper is flying in there just from
hand and stunning a unit because when a
VI peacekeeper resolves really tough to
come back from that.
>> It really is. It gives the whole deck a
new dimension. But I think that's enough
listening from us. Let's hear from
Squirtle the Azir Masterclass God
himself.
>> Excellent cast there with our wonderful
performance here as now we have a
finalized currently only one undefeated
player here at the Utre regional
qualifier and it is none other than
Squirtle your reigning Leal regional
qualifier champion. How does it feel
right now at the end of round 11 to be
the only undefeated player in the room?
>> I mean it feels great right we are still
doing it. We are maintaining the streak.
So that's nice. You told me it's a new
record kind of.
>> You you have a new record right now. Um
just a small thing that we're keeping
track backstage. You had to go against
Allen's EQ in Swiss the round before
this one.
>> You won.
>> You have proved that you are also here
to compete in the European regional
qualifiers. That you have a real name to
stand for. And you beat our only twotime
regional qualifier champion. making your
own way to try and become a twotime
regional qualifier champion. And now
with only a couple more rounds to go.
Yes, you have the current longest win
streak for regional qualifiers of of
that you attend. Of course, now he's
going to so many more. That's fine. of
course, but that kind of that's that's
just shows how much per like the amount
of work that you've put in with this
deck. The extra tools that you've
acquired from Unleashed, you know, the
vi the vise, you know, being a little
bit of extra pressure, but other than
that, the deck hasn't changed too much,
but the new tools are so powerful to
help you in these decks like Diana.
>> You've now had to beat two in a row now.
How many have you gone against all
weekend? Actually,
>> three total. So, how it's not just about
how you're feeling, but what's the game
plan for next round? The same stuff. How
do you reset every single time fighting
against these titans of the game?
>> Well, I I'm pretty chill right now,
but as long as you like for in this
case, for example, I it wasn't my best
games. Uh so that's uh gets more more
tilted than losing or winning. So
sometimes you play well and you lose and
it's okay. you you still did your own
job. Sometimes you play bad and you win,
that's nice. But if if you play bad and
you lose, that's something you need to
work about because it's your fault, not
variance or whatever.
>> I think players just like yourself are
your biggest critics. And when you do
have those misplays, that's the biggest
thing that you have to consider all the
time, but you have to keep going.
>> Yes. And it pays off because here you
are
>> essentially I can't imagine we don't see
you in our top eight already in this
feeling of course you know
>> and so I'm going to give you some time
here to relax reset as well because I
can't wait to see more of you played
later today and I can't wait to see what
our casters have in store for us. Thank
you so much Squirtle. Congratulations.
>> Absolutely incredible to hear. man is 11
and0 just won that thriller game three
on stream and he's as cool as a cucumber
that's why Squirtle is the Titan that he
is
>> got a lot amount of big amount of
confidence as well on him but I mean at
this point why wouldn't you just
decimating everyone in your way to
eventually another title
>> but we're going straight into our
feature match two here and we are
joining this live right here looks like
it is a game three here if you haven't
had enough game three more for you good
old fan favorite for Who Leo that Rexai
>> and Aurelia it's my two queens.
>> Okay,
>> I might pass to you.
>> All right, here we go. So, it looks like
we just saw the pass. So, it is going to
go over to
>> Sure. Oh,
>> Arc Gill, it's looking like
>> Oh, no. Oh, pass the other way, I should
say. So, now it's Mice's turn
>> this. Wow. I haven't had a chance to
look at this. We're a two to five um
point discrepancy and the board state
definitely favors Mice.
>> This could be a quick game free.
>> I mean, there is so many runes open
right now for Argal. You cannot tell me
that you think that there is not going
to be anything to protect this tie
turner. But is one singular tie turner
enough to turn the tides for arc 7 Gil?
>> I mean,
>> as we look at the champion zone for
Argill, it looks like that has been sent
to the trash that Ireelia so might have
had.
>> Yo, there is the big Rengar coming down.
And this is what you want to do when you
got a big prize and point discrepancy
there is just load up the battlefield.
say, "All right, try and battle your way
through this."
>> And don't forget, we got a little cheeky
knock that's hopeful down there of a
battlefield there as well.
>> Thing is, if we're committing heavily
into this with our units, cards like
Defiant D just get even stronger.
>> We're battering this down to
>> three and we have a four. So, we have
six to six.
>> I Wow. If you pass action back to me, I
might play something. Uh yeah, I I
passed the bra section.
>> Um
>> now, usually that sounds like a trade
you would always want to take when
you're just looking at the units on
board. But if you are looking a
>> little bit into the hand of Gil, he
needs some units.
>> He does needs to keep something on the
board to try and get out of this two to
five point discrepancy. Do you see
another Defiant Dance in the hand?
I'm a fan of playing the gust here first
because it's like the lowest investment
kind of spell that you can have. Oh,
plays the defant dance first. Wants to
get all of that big might.
>> Yeah. So, this is two
>> puts down six
>> token generator 3,000 to zero might.
Faithful manufacturer
>> faithful.
>> So, we are going to pass priority back
over currently 8 to four. the tie turner
that could
>> Oh, we're seeing something be used here
>> to play.
>> Honestly, depending on the hand, three
cards being used
>> with repeat
>> gets Oh, a blood rush here. Repeated
>> one here.
>> Give assault plus two.
>> That's another four swing then. So now
we're a tie.
>> And there we see the gust at the end.
>> Thinking about the target. plays around
the gas really really well here by
choosing different targets for the
assault. However, he still needs quite a
bit to get through this. We are at eight
might on the tie turner five. If you
have another Rengar pouncing,
>> this is the moment. Nope.
>> All of those units die. However,
>> Rameo still in a pretty decent position.
Plays a carry on dredger. Pulls back the
Noxus hopeful. I untap
still sitting on this tight turner.
Really really needs to find something
else.
>> I go to three.
>> Love the direct use there of the ABCD
there from Art Gill. Love to see that
>> that the Titoner stood the test of time
there. Leo,
>> um going to play
>> Sorry. Sorry. I'm going to play Titan.
>> You are forgiven to change positions.
Yes,
>> I need to tap two. Sorry.
After that, I want to go here.
>> Sure. Fourth.
>> I get my fourth point.
>> Then
I'm going to pass. Okay.
>> Wow. I love that. He's doing our job for
us in He's illustrating his turns
perfectly. A little bit of a break here
for us, but he's just really in such a
horrendous spot.
>> So,
>> oh wow.
>> What are we all wowing? What have I
>> a void rush or an under titan? Whatever
you prefer here. Both of those are real
power plays. Now
>> try to play this.
>> Sure.
>> This is plus two. This is plus two.
>> Yeah.
>> Goes for the Titan. So if you try to
conquer with the Noxus hopeful that
plays around defined dance.
>> I'm going to go.
>> And the Titan giving everyone plus two
might this turn.
>> Sure.
>> Almost pushed it into the arena's
greatest, but now this is a draw for Sun
Temple.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh sorry,
one question. Uh uh I can put this in
the pile but no pay uh the one
>> uh this and this go to the pile because
it's the conqueror effect. So uh I can
>> yeah I can I can play put this in the
pile but in the result no pay for this
or need pay in footprint.
Yeah now what is happening because he
wants to check if he finds something
nice from the void ber to play and if
there is nothing good to hit you can
still draw card.
>> Good question. So you cannot wait for
>> okay okay for this for this put this in
the pile I need I need pay
>> you have to already pay otherwise it
won't be
>> okay
um
>> that is what we have our table everyone
thank your judges without they won't be
able to run these events
>> absolutely
>> you do a fantastic job
>> so we are going to get confirmation on
that one It seems like
>> I mean my personal opinion if you
resolve the void borrow first and you
find a three energy unit then you just
can't resolve the sunken temple anymore.
>> Yeah. I mean that is also my uh way of
thinking this as well. But I don't blame
people for you know wanting concrete
information.
>> Okay.
Also, I think part of the question is if
you find something that costs like two,
if you are forced to spend your last
energy or if you can keep it
>> and first draw and second this. Okay, so
one card
and now this.
>> Well, he's going to do it anyway.
>> Can play the inferno or can play both of
them actually
as in one of two
>> or two and this go to
sticky one that is
>> as you called it what the bird token
generator 3000
thinking on this one
>> with that plus two from the uh the void
seek not void underworld titan I should
say
>> that is a pretty strong carry on dredger
>> yeah not just about spawning bird tokens
is he
>> g will need to find another unit off the
top because maybe maybe you can save the
titaner here by using right the wind so
you do have a unit
>> oh no it's going to go through with that
under titan booster carry on dredger
will push the tie turner to the trash.
>> I like that decision from Gil because if
he saves the Titan, he has nothing to
work with a topic. If he finds a Stellon
now,
>> yeah, sure.
>> He still has plays with right to wind.
>> I will is turn one, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, I will untap this time properly.
Then I will ram two runes and I will
draw my card for turn.
>> Okay.
I'm going to play for two Scuttle Crap
to draw.
>> Okay.
Okay.
I love this.
>> Me, too.
>> He's really turning the tides.
>> Tide Turner's had his hands all over
this game, it feels like. Bear in mind,
Mice is on seven points, by the way,
threatening the win. So, what do you
have there?
needs to push off both of these.
>> Gil is trying to puzzle out a way to
stop his opponent from winning, but with
a carry on dredger.
>> Okay.
>> And base and under Titan, I'm assuming
it's going to be quite hard.
>> Okay,
>> that is currently a trade right now. If
you ride the wind into there, right?
Yeah, we will get the bird token though.
You roll five.
>> But what is this Noxus hope was going to
do about this Noxus hopeful though?
>> Oh, a charm. Okay, that's going to move
it over.
>> He's having fun with it. Just
>> still going to Okay,
>> a hidden blade to draw two.
>> GG's, man.
>> Okay, it looks like Ro's going to see
the concession there as Mice will take
that one. advancing to that 902
record. That rack side deck, a deck you
were quite bullish on coming into this
event. Doing rather well.
>> Pretty pretty strong, I want to say.
It's a really cool deck. It's a really
good deck as well. But I also love the
camaraderie here and how Gil handled
that loss, right? He was just absolutely
sympathetic and just having fun with it,
saying, "Hey, GG, man. You got me in
this game where he was just really
sitting on a bunch of tight turners."
And while this is a great card, very
flexible, doesn't really pack that big
punch. No,
>> no. It's funny when we hopped into that
game three scenario and you can see the
Aurelia champion unit, you know, not
there and all you see is a tie turner on
the field. You're thinking this probably
isn't going to go your way, but I think
the nail in a coffin had to be the Rexai
getting under Titan down boosting up the
carryon dredger and everything else to
plus two. Noctis hopeful comes swinging
in. Carry on dredger swinging with his
bird cage knocking units about the head.
So yeah, advanced into that 902 record.
Fantastic to see.
>> Also had a Voit Rush in the hand. Yeah,
could have played that one too, but I
like it when people just play their win
conditions that they have. I'm always a
little bit more lenient towards just
getting all of those value cards up, but
that's just because I I think I'm
addicted to drawing cards. I I really
like drawing cards.
>> Yeah, we've seen drawing cards be
fantastic. Speaking of drawing card, we
didn't see the Selicon Herder there
either for Aurelia player. So, you know,
just having it out there, having some
fun. So talk to us a little bit about
this Rackside deck then. Why have you
because you actually chose it as your
cards prediction coming into this event.
Why do you like it so much?
>> Because the deck is just so ignorantly
aggressive, right? You can you almost
never with your first and you're playing
so many different two drops and the deck
just has this way of being super
aggressive. Finding a bigger ceiling in
the early game. If you are using your
Rexi ability and you find an under
Titan, you can get to play cards for
free. Some of these decks that are
really strong right now, they first of
all take a little bit too long to set
up. Something like a hook Leblanc,
something like a Diana from time to
time. If you really get those favorable
trades, it's hard for Diana to establish
and then you're just running away with
those games. And we have seen that
yesterday, you can absolutely high roll
with this. I am of the opinion while we
have so many different incredibly
skilled players rift boners that just go
to the top cut every event. You
sometimes also, it's still a card game.
Need that little bit of luck to succeed.
And if Rexai wants it to be your day,
it's going to be your day.
>> Yeah, we saw that in our feature match,
I think, of our last one yesterday,
wasn't it? When the Rackside deck is
just finding it stuff, the top decks and
what you're seeing there, what you want
to see quite honestly, the deck almost
borderline unstoppable, I feel.
>> Yeah. And now in this game, we have seen
that you can integrate different cards
like the Rengar pouncing into this deck.
These different ambushing strategies.
You have Inferno Renga Pouncing and V
Peacekeeper Ranga Pouncing. Basically
the OG ambusher. So we have seen that
card for quite a while now even in
Spirit Forge. Why don't we learn a
little bit more on how to use Rengar?
This is a story about a big meta upset.
A story about technical precision. This
is the story about how a Rengar changed
the tides. Riftbound Regional Qualifier
Atlanta. The last regional qualifier
before Unleashed release. We are finding
ourselves in the League of Draven. Chaos
and Fury are the domains to beat. A
whopping 211 of the 1832 players brought
Draven Glorious Executioner to their
tournament with the hopes and dreams to
win it all. Equipped with Ferris
Forerunner, the undisputed best unit in
Spirit Forged and Rebuke as the best
answer to it, the mid-range deck proved
as the most dominant force in the
tournament. Winning combats with sticky
units and utility cards to profit off
the passive card draw engine of your
legend. A snowball that once it starts
running cannot be stopped. The perfect
strategy not for prismaticism. He found
a way to play Draven's game, but more
aggressively. What the Draven Legend
brings in value, any doubles in tempo.
The meta centers around powerful units
and most importantly two energy cost
chaos spells, flash, hard bargain,
rebuke, and ride the wind. All of those
cards provide utility on your turn and
on your opponents. You can dodge combat,
force points, or protect your units with
all of these cards. While these cards
provide similar amount of utility, they
work in completely different ways, which
makes it hard for the opponents to play
around all of them. Any the dark child
readies two of your runes at the end of
your turn, which allows you to always be
able to completely exhaust your runes in
order to play your biggest units and
maximize energy usage while still
keeping your opponents on their toes
with two runes up at least. But one card
in particular sets any apart from the
Draven decks. Rengar P. The OG Ambusher
is an incredible offensive threat,
coming in hot with five might on attack
for only three energy straight from
hand. While the offensive possibilities
that Renga as a champion historically
has are quite obvious, prismaticism
finds more death in the cart, which
brings us to the moment he won his first
regional qualifier title. We are finding
ourselves in game three of the Atlanta
finals. The winner immortalizes
themselves in Riftbound history.
Prismaticism Monani versus Challenger
TCG's Koko Lopez on Draven. A dramatic
aspirin climb game in which both players
reach eight points.
>> Both players literally one point away
from being the regional qualifier
Atlanta champion. The tension is
palpable and the resources are few.
Prismmet finds himself with five runes
ready. Looking at a ferris forrunner
previously established in Koko's base.
Both battlefields are empty and
Prismmeticism only has a long sword on
his side of the board. The situation
looked dire. The options in his hand
looked mediocre. A traveling merchant
for two and a pass, immediately readying
his runes again. After thoroughly
thinking through all the possibilities
and checking both players treasures, he
decides to only play a two drop with no
immediate impact on the board state. It
feels almost like a concession. GG's
were spammed in chatter already. Koko
Lopez starts his turn by trying to
conquer the arena's greatest to set up
for a winning hold next turn. That was
the moment in which Prismat with haste
slammed down the right the wind pushing
the trebling merchant onto the other
battlefield. No answer from Koko. First
the move trigger of the merchant happens
discarding the ferris 4runner to draw
another card. Then both players conquer
in their respective battlefields and
draw a card since they cannot get the
victory point just yet. All of a sudden
the pressure is on Koko Lopez. He needs
to deny the holding point or
prismaticism will be crowned the Atlanta
champion. His out is just in his hand. A
falling star that he kept in hand to get
rid of the traveling merchant. But
again, lightning fast prismaticism picks
up his cards and throws down a defensive
Renga pouncing onto the battlefield.
>> And does Koko have the rebuke in this
instance? Noism.
immediately followed by a quick
concession of his opponent who fought so
hard to become a finalist instead of
developing the merchant and another unit
to then later on try and deal with the
ferris 4runner. Prismaticism in this
tournament displayed how a risky play
style, playing the odds, and bravery can
catch your opponent off guard and win
you a regional qualifier.
Have you been feeling moody lately? Are
you also tired of conquering for your
points all the time? Do you not want to
play a normie deck like the others? Then
we got the deck just for you. Vex
Gloomist appears in Unleashed, a legend
that massively profits from holding
battlefields. Stop your opponent from
ambushing or accelerating consistently
as early as turn two with Vex apathetic
as your chosen champion unit. Tell your
opponents to back off by stunning their
units when they try to conquer. Play
your shadow ready into battlefields to
immediately use its ability on the
opposing turn. Vex can rely on so many
different defensive tools that the calm
and chaos domain already have. Use
guardian angel and zona's hourglass to
protect your units from dying. Not so
fast and defy to counter opposing spells
and deny their tempo. But also new
defensive cards can be found in
unleashed like existential dread or the
mutated mouser. But in the shadow isles,
a monster lurks supporting Vex, giving
her near unlimited defensive and
offensive possibilities. Enter Vimmore.
The spider god has ambush, meaning it
can be played offensive and defensively.
With its powerful eight might, it jumps
into a battlefield that you are
attacking and crushes any unit smaller
than it without taking a single hit. If
your opponents doesn't manage to push it
out of a battlefield, an additional draw
for holding is a free bonus. With these
cards in your deck, you're going to be
able to keep all the others away from
your battlefields. Keep holding, rift
bounders.
Welcome back everybody to day two of RQ
Futract. Um, we have a couple minutes
before we get into our next round. As
I'm sure you can appreciate, uh,
everything tidying up with the round is
these are my favorite behind the scenes.
Oh, that we just get to talk.
>> They're free and we can talk about the
things we love.
>> Okay. Uh, what do you love first of all
about Riftband? It's an open question.
>> Here's the thing.
I just love that every time I get to
look at more than three matches, I'm
usually caught off guard by at least one
of the decks. Okay.
>> How they are either building upon
previous iterations
>> Uhhuh.
>> or completely
in a like scrapping the board and
building it back up from scratch cuz
they saw the new angle and it always
feels like I'm so hungry to to to really
get into the medium to what they have to
share.
>> That's fair. We do get a lot of
innovation. Uh we've seen some
innovation for this event around like
the the loop lux, but we've also seen uh
some of that uh deck building
interration kind of pan out within each
legend. People dropping cards, moving
them around. Uh when we look at the
cards that are being played here in RQ
Utri, um a couple of cards do keep
popping up. I mean, I think it is fair
to say uh a lot of the body cards are
popping up. The Rengar kind of keeps
ambushing everybody and like making an
appearance,
>> right? uh vexes to build on top of that.
And that is in my opinion fine cuz every
good house needs a foundation to be
built on top upon.
>> Yeah. Uh and if you don't want a
foundation, you can just bounce it back
with things like the star cross. But
yeah, there is the Vex apathetic. Uh
scuttle crab. Another unit that we're
seeing a lot of and one that we we
haven't seen too too much of because
it's mostly in the sideboard is
disarming rake. Basically every single
calm deck is going to bring options
against the likes of Aurora. Also helps
in your matchups with like Aurelia and a
couple of the other ones. Azia just
targeting out some of the gear on the
other side. Down the side you can see
Tide Turner Aan again ashan for the
gear. Fizz has just been uh an
unstoppable unit since release where
it's just like wow you actually just get
access to your entire trash for spells.
And that is really just the the identity
of chaos so far is keeping it flexible,
keeping it unpredictable.
One could say chaotic. Exactly. Uh a
card that we haven't seen in the meta
too much was the thousand tailed watcher
up until now. Again, Origins Mattera
absolutely was like the game winner and
now has coming back in while we we have
decks like Yei who they can present a
big threat but you know you need a a
finish against it to get over the top.
Uh when we look at at spells
specifically, well then we're looking at
Gust as one of the remaining postbwave
chaos spells that is still run so
prominently again. Slows decks down,
denies early uh showdowns especially.
And we can just say no, actually I'm
going to I'm going to stop you scoring
this point this turn. And it it actually
it's only been getting better, right,
with the ch with how Leblanc interacts
with it currently, but also on open
battlefields where certain cards will
not trigger their assault clause and
they remain gustable,
>> it opens up so many options. And because
a lot of the chaos decks out there are
paired up with mind as well, the
combination between Gust and Stupify
just opens up the door that if need be,
you can get those four might units off
of the board as well. Yeah, we have a
lot in there that was green and uh
purple and a little bit of orange
sprinkled in there as well for domains.
From domains to the battlefields, we
look at Arena's greatest having the
highest share. Um I think as people have
kind of seen the way that uh the decks
pan out, getting that fast out of the
gates way through some of the later game
decks like the Aurora uh is one of the
decks that doesn't like to play against
Arena's greatest so much. Same with like
the Lux deck. I imagine you probably uh
don't love when your opponent gets an
early point. So many of the decks here
can benefit from just playing out a
bunch of units and getting those points
early on, just jumping up towards a win.
And I I like that in the top five
Battlefield, you can really see, all
right, I see Yi Battlefields, I see
Diana Battlefields, there is a little
bit of Lelanc in there with Aspirin's
Climb in certain ways. And then the drop
off to Sunken Temple is quite sudden.
>> Yeah. And there other half of that as
well with Aspirin's Climb. We're talking
about the decks that don't like playing
against arena's greatest typically the
ones that want to play Asperence Climb.
They're like, "Hang on a second. Can we
just can we just agree to play to the
number I want to play to?" So, nine most
of the time if you're on it, but it's
always funny when you get an arena's
greatest game and an aspirin climb game
at the same time. And you're like, "So,
we're playing to eight, but we're
actually not playing to eight. We're
playing to nine, but you started one
ahead." Ah, foiled me. Uh, sideboard
cards. Um, nothing surprising in the
actual like cards listed here. I would
say the usage that
every deck is basically going to be
running one of these cards.
>> I think the the most surprising part
here is how diversified the sideboards
are. Like where we we previously saw
numbers around 30% of all decks are
playing it. In the sideboards, people
are getting a lot more creative and you
can really tell that their read on the
situation varies a lot from deck to deck
where the most sideboarded card is
coming in at 7%. But it's anti- Aurora
disarming rake, anti- Aurora Ash, anti-
Aurora Action, anti- Aurora Salvage,
Sabotage hits it as well. Turn to dust.
Like all the way down the the top 1 2 3
4 5 six six sideboard cards and slots uh
across all decks are basically saying
yes, I don't want to deal with mostly
Aurora. And as said, they do help in
other matchups, too. But that tells you
how afraid at least people are that you
have to pack answers to this deck
otherwise it will just wipe you off the
table. And the added benefit to this is
with, you know, the success that Azir
has been seeing as well.
>> Yeah.
>> All these cards will do tremendously
well into that as well. And we had some
discussion before about like
for example with the acceptable losses.
>> Oh, how efficient is that really into
the Azir? But keeping the Azir on the
back foot and contained is such a big
part of not allowing them to snowball to
have hit those five six gear arise
spells. Yeah, which h we have seen Azia
a little bit today with Squirtle's big
win staying undefeated. Yesterday I was
like Allan's undefeated streak it's
going to last. It's going to last for a
long time is no one's going to beat it.
And then I walk in today and everyone's
like hey Squirtle's undefeated by the
way. He beat Allen and is now
undefeated.
>> And and that is really the the magic of
it. Like there are so many talented
players out there. There are a few of
them really have that character and
claim up that that spotlight. But
throughout it all and we saw it in
previous as well in Vancouver as well,
right, where Sami Sherman reached the
finals and it was like, oh yeah, we were
so occupied with what Dewali and Allen
were doing that we kind of forgot about
that these convention halls are filled
with champions.
>> Yeah. Yeah. filled with contenders. And
that extends as well to a little bit of
news. While I was I was looking through
the results of the last round, I believe
Allan has a second loss. If I read
correctly, it's uh challenger TCG
Villionaire on the Volibear.
>> Oh my.
>> Villionaire's tweet from what I saw and
looking through the results seems to
have handed Allen the second loss. We
know historically at an RQ being X and
two at the end of Swiss is not enough to
make top eight. I will not say that
definitively until we have run all of
the numbers and see how it's outside of
your hands, but it is typically too
little too late at that point. Uh we
will revisit the uh stories officially,
but you know, as we're kind of in that
end point of the round, I think it's
always good to to keep an eye on what
exactly is happening out in the playing
space. Um, always, as you said, enjoy
seeing different decks, different
players. What I what I what I don't what
I don't have so much in my heart is the
flavor. Uh,
I'm my the cards for me kind of end
after the rules text. Sometimes I'll
like look down at the artist and I'll be
like, "Yes, you did a great job on that
one. Thumbs up." But what I don't know
>> is this one. I'm gonna guess this is an
easy one. Actually, I think irresistible
fate. This has to be irresistible fate
book, right? I I'm like,
>> "Wait, no, no, no. It can also be the
the one that you hide. The the one that
you hide and then when you that's played
in Rangbar, it's the hab."
>> Oh, the uh Yeah. Yeah. Packer. Is that
Is that a cup? I'm going with Okay, I'm
going with the obvious choice and saying
irresistible fa. And uh I'm I'm Let's
play, you know, Jeopardy. What is
Irresistible? Ah, you were right. See, I
don't know it. I'm glad you're here for
this. Okay. like fa folk. I got charmed
in. I I the fa folk ran by and was just
like
>> even when they're not there, they're
still in your head like oh
>> living rent free to be honest that Fay
folk does live rent free in my head. I
do think it is one of the best things
but Pakub not something we see very
often.
>> No it non-meta cards. It was a for a
while I ran it in rankar lists
>> and uh my opponent was taking really
long so I was starting to read the
flavor text on my cards and I was like
oh that oh it is really cute and
>> it it stuck around. It was a memorable
flavor text. A head full of bravery and
not much else.
That sounds to me like a noxious
hopeful.
>> Okay. Okay. I was just going to make a
joke about Set because it's all of the
energy goes into the aesthetics at that
point.
>> You're telling me that he took over an
entire Syndicate ring cuz he has oily
muscles
>> and
>> stranger things have happened. Stranger
things have happened. Um,
>> honestly, now that I'm saying it out
loud, I do see how that
>> you can see how that happens. Yeah. Uh,
I you know, I actually don't know. My My
law is so bad. you you wouldn't know
that I've worked on like League of
Legends for like 15 years on and on.
People are like, "Here's a really simple
layup law question." And I'm like,
"Uh-huh.
>> Yes, that's that's what that is. Knoxus
Knox." So, you're saying
>> Nox is hopeful because cuz I feel like
they they they do have that naive to
them to be like, "Oh, for the greater
good for Nox strength."
>> Okay, let's see if you're right. I'm
knocking behind door number one. A loyal
parro. A that I we were way off.
>> I I had set in my head and it was
actually a parro is a very different
>> very much like the irresistible faith.
You just couldn't get it out of your
head.
>> No. Exactly. Exactly. All right. Let's
take a look at uh what the last one is.
Okay. I'm wondering, did we get baited
here? Cuz it's okay. Yeah, it's changing
over. The guitar isn't the only thing he
shreds. Oh, I can see the art on the on
the
>> Oh, that is that is not good.
>> I can see the art in my head. But the
art we are a team I think we are a team
on this. So, are we?
>> Yeah, I've decided we are a team on
this. Uh, welcome to the team.
>> Well, I'm 0 and2. Do you really want to
play 2v2 with me as your your partner?
>> Well, I mean, I'm one on two.
>> That's one one for now. It's better than
me.
>> A shared loss is only half a loss,
right?
>> And a shared win is double a win.
Well, a draw in Swiss is only one point
and a win is three. So, I don't think it
works quite quite like that. See, you're
giving over way more points.
>> Damn. I think we maybe got to
>> I think we can only buy so much time
before we realize we don't know this. Do
you have a guess for this?
>> I mean, when you go down to musical
champions, I'm just I'm just going to
say this is alt arta where she joins a
metal band.
>> Well, uh, a lot would have to change for
>> where they join pentacill. I'm kind of
down for that though.
>> Let's let's go for the reveal if it's a
pentacill. uh uh uh champion. Ah, I was
going to say something punk. I was like
I couldn't remember. I should have I
should have gone with my with my
instinct is that the artwork is so so
like synonymous.
>> Yeah, that that's useless.
>> Yeah, it is useless. Uh secret to to
being on broadcast is you just say
useless things for a little while until
you say something
>> Don't expose us here.
>> Until you say something useful and then
you're like cool, we uh we get to get to
move on.
it is that we're teamed up. Otherwise, I
we'd have to separate ways from here.
>> Okay. All right. So, we glad to have you
here.
>> Three points out of out of three rounds
on that one. Um, not the best points
total for us. So, let's take a look at
some people who do have a good points
total as we take a look at the current
standings from round 11. Squirtle 11 and
zero at the top. Bias 101. Uh, and then
we hit our X and 1's through the
bracket. So, big names. Prismaticism
still in here. We saw Puna there as our
Diana player earlier picking up their
first loss but still in contention.
Colin's there. Collins there.
>> Yeah, I was about to say he is pulling
through in a big big way. And
>> the only maybe downside on this one is
the fact that he did lose to Allen who
is now losing as well. So that might
influence any tiebreers if he gets
unlucky. But losing against Allen is
also kind of an upside cuz what are the
odds he'll lose three times in a row?
Some decks here though that you might
not expect. Uh Diamond Hat from Mellian.
Uh Darius in current third place in that
10 and one one spot. There's all of the
players of course have tiebreers. We
have a Rex eye in the mix that we've
seen a little bit of and a Victor for
Red Knax at the bottom. Yeah, primarily
the Rexi is something that really
catches my attention time and time again
because I feel like we're finally
starting to wake up to the power of a
wellpiloted aggro deck. a deck that can
really mount the pressure up early and
if you are too slow and you're too
you're spending too much time and
resources developing your board that you
that can leave you in the dust
effectively. Yeah, it it can I was
talking actually totasio, one of the the
players from Spain that has you know a
following and and some good results was
talking about their Rex eye build. Um
unfortunately didn't pay off. It it
happens. Tournament structure, it can be
really difficult. If you hit just two
bad matchups in a row, it can kind of
unsettle things. But talking about how
important that aggro is and that build
coming through. If we do end up seeing
Rexite, we will of course go through
that. I saw the Victor at the bottom. I
I actually believe we're getting Victor
on screen uh for our next matchup as
well. I mean, that would be very
exciting because I feel that both the
Victor and the and the Rexai do have
similarish game plans. not necessarily
what they're trying to do, but in the
manner in which they are doing it.
That's overloading the board, presenting
too many threats to be dealt with
efficiently to the point where you
either have to give in or be run over.
>> That's very fair. We've we've seen so
many wide board states come from Victors
and Aziz in a in a like a slightly
different way is more focused on the uh
the equipment. So, Victor doesn't have
access to that. you do get the the spell
package from Victor, right, that lets
you deal with bigger units.
>> And not only that, but to build on top
of that, just the efficient manner in
which you can always use your energy cuz
if you'll never be si sitting with one
random energy as Victor, cuz that will
always go to making another recruit,
which will always ensure you can
pressure the battlefields early on,
which means even if you don't have the
perfect opening hand, you can either
keep up or buy yourself time. So
important to note, Wtech was the
Bologonia best of Master at that point
slightly out of the meta like not not
completely out but definitely was
represented less than the likes of the
Kaiser that we were expecting back then.
The interesting part here that you have
to you have to talk about is the fact
that a regular matchup between Yi and
Victor is heavily favored for the Yi.
It's so hard for the Victor
efficiently
with the exception of the Trafarian War
camp. However, when you adjust for the
players, it becomes a straight up 50/50
which speaks tremendously about the
skill in which this victory is being
piloted. Yeah, we uh we talked there a
little bit and I was mentioning best of
bologoney. Of course, that was when we
were expecting Draven in the meta and
more Kaiser was there, but uh watch tech
uh has the I will double check the list
as we go through. You did just see it on
screen as well on the other side. I'm
interested to see what our
Victor list looks like. So, has this in
that we we've seen iterated on a couple
times
>> and the the new parts from Unleash that
are coming through with the sprite
fountain with the extra draw coming
through. You don't mind too much giving
your recruit temporary if that means you
get to draw two cards any day of the
week. Now, the card that has been seeing
more and more love in the order domain
>> is the Zenzou.
>> Yes.
being able to to come out ready while
still having a pretty attractive might
package attached to it whilst also being
that tank threat which can really
protect so many of your recruits if need
be.
>> Uhhuh. Makes it that you are getting
more efficient trades than you have any
right of having. I know Leo in Bolognia
was was telling me he was like Zia is
going to be a thing in Victor. But we're
going to see it a little bit and people
were 50/50 on it at that time. I think
that it's as you said, people have been
like, "Yeah, okay, maybe that is the
right best way to play."
>> And not only in Victor, we've seen
Darius's run it, we've seen Rexai run
with it. Even it's really a
complimementary card to a more
aggressive strategy.
So wondering how things for instance
like color week end up panning out in
this matchup. Uh when it comes to you
know yei if you get a yei to not have
units if you can keep them on the back
foot with units sometimes that very much
is able to take control. Uh Imperial
decree also another one where you know
the going through a big unit is not
always about having more might.
Sometimes it's just about having the
right scalpel there with the Imperial
Decree. You're right on the money with
that one, James. The only issue that you
might run into where we saw the same
with like unchecked power,
>> the Yei is very incentivized to keep
units in base,
>> right?
>> So, I am very curious how we will see a
Victor pilot the matchup, one that he
should be absolutely the underdog in,
but has been doing incredibly well so
far. It's a very interesting uh setup as
we go
>> into our first game of
>> you.
>> Round 12.
>> If you're looking as the victor for what
are we trying to get done in the early
game, redundancy to come through is
incredibly attractive in this regard.
Having a unit you can throw out there,
get a quick conqueror, and if it dies,
you're not losing out on tempo because
when you get the turn back, you'll have
a ready bird ready to go.
>> Means you get to chain your place
together without ever having to take a
breather. Yeah, that that's that's fair.
That way of just saying, "Hey, these are
expendable."
>> Uh some ways
>> conquer for one.
I'll play a recruit
uh over here and bust to you.
>> The other thing in this matchup, the
forbidding waste likely to have uh an
impact. It kind of neutralizes Yi's uh
you know, legend ability. Uh have to
keep that in mind because Yei wants to
>> get it two might higher
>> and that is incredibly beneficial with
the Ye field being as large as it is.
But a Victor will rarely ever hold it
with a single unit.
>> Okay. Okay. So maybe saying like, "Hey,
this is a fine one because I don't know
that
>> it's great." And in any other matchup,
it's still good
>> here. Yep.
>> The other ones are rock full path and
arena's greatest. So I wonder whether
that does change things there based on
>> first or second.
Hold for two.
>> Channel two. So you were talking about
is it possible to CI
>> bring things back to base. Would you say
it's a little early in the game to to be
looking into that strategy? Cuz an
Imperial decree is a big turn normally
later. You need units to to kind of
replace themselves and expendable. So
for now is the game plan. Just try and
hold the battlefields early on. Would
you say like try and post up and do ye
things for the next turn or two? Every
point that you can scrape by with a
let's say a more of a throwaway unit
like the pit rookie is going to be very
beneficial because everything they have
to spend to get rid of the chaff so to
speak
>> are tools that they then cannot use on
your Rengar that they cannot use on your
ruin runner.
>> So the you can get ahead the better it
is. And I pass
>> sprite going to attempt to take the
trade.
>> Uh discipline
>> of course because of the Marci legend
abilities. It's going to balance that
out. Force a
>> reaction.
>> I'll do Eclipse.
>> Okay. Sure. Yeah, that resolves.
>> I'll do the predict.
>> Now the question is how much is it even
worth holding this battlefield at this
point?
>> A punch first. brutal to the economy. So
I think you just kind of let it go from
here.
>> This is such a wild investment for to
keep around a chaff unit, right?
>> Rookie.
>> Yeah,
>> there's a lot more yet to come still.
And the turn where I'm looking out for
is how well can they hold on?
>> Do we put the markers? So you're uh
>> Yes, please put the markers.
>> So
>> it's going to be plus two minus two
minus four. So yeah,
>> that's the might ones. No, that's the
dumb.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the sprite will obviously win this
exchange from here
>> if they are letting it go. They are
putting down the puncher. This is
wreaking havoc on the early economy.
>> Yeah, that's the problem. Yes, you win
this fight, but are you damping too
much? That's a question we won't be able
to answer for another couple turns and
see how this goes. We're going down to
three and then back up to the next turn
is is rough.
>> Yeah. And it only takes care of a sprite
>> which next turn there'll be another one.
>> And that's the thing. Expendable is the
right word here for red axle. So many of
their their tokens. Their units are just
like, "Yeah, I'll get another one.
That's fine. I'll just It's okay. It
doesn't matter." Dramping your your two
orange runes now coming over to your
next turn. How impactful could that end
up being? Because now you you at most
you can kind of afford Rengar if you're
holding the ambush. It's it's not really
how you want to play.
>> Your turns become so binary.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> And where Diana flourishes when she has
options and he does as well and you are
either going to commit for a larger
impactful play or you can't. And even if
you do manage to hold on in this regard,
at most you're going to go up to three
in your turn by holding and then maybe
conquering the the Starring.
Is that
>> is that really all that much to write
home about? I feel that you're losing
out, especially so early on in the game.
>> That is a great question. I I wonder if
there's any anything you can kind of
glean from that. I was wondering whether
Wak was low on units in hand, but there
actually is is is a couple in there. We
saw a lonely power earlier.
I know there we we saw a challenge, I
believe, as well. And um but the
priority is clear. They want to stay in
the race and preferably start overtaking
their opponent from this turn on. But do
you run out of gas too quickly? Cuz even
if you do manage to beat them off the
Starring, they will be untapping with a
sprite and with the bird.
How how fond of you are holding on
because that will go up to four
and then the the the follow on from that
is like what what is the replacement if
you are expending units here. Here is
the the look at the hand. We can see
that there is a punch first that is not
something you can play only one body
rune. Uh so it's not an option in any of
these combat. So you know that you can
kind of go
gung-ho this turn if you want to. The Yi
of course is another option and they're
talking about the the units in hand.
Never forget your chosen champion from
the champion zone is also essentially a
card in hand too
part of the team.
>> Yeah, exactly. Here is really the
painful point for the Yi and also where
the Victor gets to shine
>> because the interaction pieces that
these players have access to are usually
geared towards larger more impactful
threats like let's say a let's say an
elder dragon, right?
>> The challenges work wonders in that.
Yeah, the challenge feels horrendous
into victory.
>> Okay. Yeah, that's fair. You don't want
to challenge a recruit, right? Yeah,
it's so hard to get an efficient trade
out of that deal.
>> And that is why Victor can catch you off
guard because a lot of decks are not
geared towards dealing with this type of
problem.
That that's a very fair point. And as we
looked at the deck list earlier, there
are a few bigger threats in this deck.
Um the Vi is there uh and also there is
a thousand watcher uh run in the main.
Now, right,
>> very rarely do you get that uh ability
to challenge a watcher very before that
watcher kind of decimates you. So,
>> before the watcher watches.
>> Exactly. So, it's more of on the back
end uh that you can utilize that.
>> And here is that clapback that we were
talking about where the Victor comes out
swinging and just retakes what he wants.
Now it's once again the Y that is a bit
on the back foot here and is going to be
heavily rellyant on getting a second
body rune to even claw their way back to
a battlefield
>> shadow call temporary. You might think
well why not just put it on a token
unit.
>> Well you get a unit out of it if you use
it on the the carry
>> that will be ready on next turn.
Exactly.
>> Exactly that you are able to maximize
your your unit efficiency.
>> So the situation ye has in front of him
right now is all right. Will I take
another moment to
recuperate some of my strength, gather a
bit of a larger army or is it pedal to
the metal, commit right now? But if he
does and does invest a punch first or
the challenge
>> punch master and
>> it's going to be very tricky to get that
done efficiently. Now you have an in the
Victor is stepped out
>> and is that a second body rune hiding in
the in the calm runes? Can you verify
that? I believe it is. All right. So,
the punch for is ready if you want to,
>> but once again, you're trading into
tokens.
>> Go here with the petrui and pass two.
Importantly, Wtech needs um you
>> needs to use the forbidding waste here
to give the minus to the sprite to win
the combat, but couldn't go with the
master
>> because it had already taken damage from
the challenge and no heal happened.
>> Those two.
>> Oh, face breaker trying to push the Y at
least back down to base.
>> Uh do we need the do we have stun
tokens? Okay.
So I passes.
>> So he can't get uh the showdown one. So
has to be routed back to the base. And
this is another turn where you want to
be clawing back, but you're falling
further and further behind.
>> And importantly, red noting about uh the
stun marker, of course, if if there was
one for for the Y. Uh that's because if
there was for instance a first mate to
ready the Yi, the Yi would not deal
damage in uh this turn because of the
face breaker being stunned. It's not
just for the showdown that you're in.
It's the entire turn when
>> combat damage in general. A challenge
would have uh been more interesting, but
>> and there is the first mate. That's
exactly what uh Red Knox was just
>> playing around making sure. Yeah, that's
what that's going to be.
>> Okay. And here you see everything. how
awkward that position is that G is
forced into to play around the
forbidding waste. Now has to commit two
units to get a respectable amount of
might out on there which is a rare
occurrence
>> for the Wument
>> and draw for turn.
>> Yeah, it's never the optimal play
whereas as you say if that hadn't been a
stun first mate may have wanted to ready
the Y and and and go like bring him
probably back to safety would have been
the thing. It would have been conquer
and then then safe conquer cuz we talked
about how with Imperial decree in the
mix, you don't want to leave units
unnecessarily at a battlefield even
though Yei wants to leave units at a
battlefield.
Here we have the syn. We were talking
about it earlier. Being able to come out
ready is
a pace of play that you don't often see
from order mine combos. This deck gets
out of the starting blocks a lot quicker
than you might expect. Why is that such
an issue for the Look at the gap that
has been created already by a cut here
and a little shove there. We get Yi out
of his rhythm. That means that we are
not benefiting from the Yi bonus because
we have to overload battlefields now. We
are only trading into sprites from
sprite fountains which will spawn once
more in the next turn. And you can
really tell that they're now struggling
to keep up with the tempo train that
Victor is driving.
Do we trust Victor to drive the train? I
watched Arcane. I don't know whether I'd
follow Victor.
>> Uh Machine Herald forever in my heart.
>> Ah, I see. Okay. I'm the other side of
the the fandom.
Jace lost in the
Yeah, that's all I'll say. Those that
don't know. You know,
>> I I I Here's the thing. He gets a little
curious after that. It's like, oh, okay.
It's like, you know, maybe uh an
intervention was needed somewhere.
>> An intervention might be needed in this
moment as redaxel is going to pick up
the uh
>> put into play. Ready?
>> Eight over to your five. And keep in
mind there is a second punch rush
available but not a second body.
>> Yeah, exactly. Will pass priority.
>> So that's six.
>> Yes,
>> it does feel like tech is starting to
run out of options cuz the week's coming
and with Y being the only unit here.
>> Uh the week, sorry. Yep.
>> And this is how the Victor chokes you
out of the game.
>> He takes away any and all oxygen. And
we've seen plenty of times before how
much he struggles to get back onto
battlefields or even get ready units out
without the first M.
>> It I I've done that so many times. What
Red Axel just did where you look at a
card in your hand. I'm pretty sure he
has one in hand. Uh and you play a
different card. the card is the one you
mean to play and you say the name of the
card in your hand and you're like uh
nope
definitely don't have one of those.
Yeah, we I believe we're just going to
the next game, right? Yeah, that's going
to be worth check.
>> Just ran out of options. Tried to to dig
a little deeper. Knew there was no way
out anymore and Victor takes it. Game
one. Just keeping the units down from Y
and saying no, you actually can't get to
a battlefield. And now is the time for
the sideboards to shine. All right,
you're caught off guard by the victory.
Fair play to you. But how will AE really
adapt to this situation because I feel
like they're so geared towards either
dealing with gear strategies that are
coming out there? There is not a a real
bailout card in the way that let's say a
Bellow's breath or the likes would be
helpful. Sure. Uh so there are some
options that get you a little bit there,
right? Um, we've seen Marci's
sideboarding alpha strike as one of them
where if you have a one big might unit,
you can go, hey, alpha strike and then
one damage to everything that's one
might and you know, we'll distribute it,
whatever makes sense. That's one way
around. I think one of the other
directions you can go is like attacking
some of the kill spells, right? Sabotage
is great at saying actually, you know,
I'll trade that for whether it's kill
week or or or whatever version. Imperial
decree is always a big one to hit,
right? Historically, it's like if you
can sabotage Imperial decree, you will
take that in most matchups any day of
the week. And you also have to take into
account ye will be relieved a little bit
now that the Forbidden Waste has been
out rotated.
>> Yeah, you had to you got to have your
fun. Now I get to play the game again.
On top of that, he gets to go first. So,
by no means out of the series just yet.
plenty of times we have seen claw it
back from the brink of defeat.
>> Yeah, and these are two of our players
in the top 10 currently. All vying for
that top eight spot. We do not have our
top eight locked yet. Have to imagine
they're in a great position for top 64.
We'll have to find out about the math on
that one. Now, we talked about the
Watcher a little bit. We mentioned it
like left some breadcrumbs in game one
and it looks like it's coming out.
It looks like he's like, "Yeah, I'm
never going to get to doing that."
>> Yeah, because I I feel like the game
plan that has been working so well for
the Victor is flooding the board,
mounting the pressure early, like that
early comparison we drew with the Rexai.
Make issues for the G early on. Make
sure that they can never get fortified
onto those battlefields and you will
have a grand old time. If you can weed
out some of the chaff and call the weak
the rest, then you are in an a- okay
spot. And it's not just the call the
weeks that the victor has access to.
There is call the week on a stick. Yeah.
Uh I don't know how safe it is that
safety inspector is causing things to to
die in that. I He's inspecting, but I
don't think the standards are up to
code.
>> It's It's like maybe a a a controlled
demolition. Yeah, that's a very
different. That's when Ziggs comes into
the game.
>> Oh, that is when you know I mean you you
just know that that Victor and Zigs are
all buddy buddy.
>> Yeah, exactly. It makes sense in in in
some regards. Again, law not my forte.
>> They both they both went to the same
school.
>> Ah, okay.
>> Well, Zix got kicked out a lot, but
>> Okay.
>> Cuz he kept blowing up the school.
>> You're going to have to send me the like
their yearbook and I'm going to have to
study and
>> Oh. Oh, I will I will I will do a
narration for you.
like in in 30 seconds where it loses all
of the nuance.
>> As long as it doesn't lose the audience,
that's the important thing. Thank you
those of you joining us here in the
venue. Uh and those of you at home
watching on stream, we've had some fun
games.
>> We've been absolutely spoiled with the
games that we've seen coming by. And I
thought that the bar was already high
after day one, but my expectations have
once again been surpassed. Yeah, we had
uh some very fun matches and some
educational matches as well. I think
this one is straddling both of on that.
I'm enjoying seeing a Victor back
>> on our top tables. We're used to it
being ghosted driver.
>> This is right.
>> I wasn't really expecting the arena's
greatest to come out already.
>> Okay. Because I feel that feeds more
into Victor's game plan of of rumbling
the board. Finish the game out early.
Right.
>> Sure. rather than than the he and
>> I feel like the emperor deis yeah it's
not the best cuz you allow the the
recruits to double up in a way.
>> Yeah, they they they go through military
training and become sandolds
>> if they get promoted.
>> Uh but the other half of that is we
might have had the quickest game ever if
Red Axel had uh been putting us on
double arena's greatest at that point
because Arena's greatest is the
remaining battlefield there as well. So
card chop opens things up on red nex
side of things gets the token
>> and I love that the philosophy around
card sharp has been
>> going here where earlier in the year
>> there was the the yes I will always be
taking the gold
>> sure
>> and now we've see a lot more of a
conservative approach as a call the week
will be kicking the ye down once again
>> and that is painful because no early
drop into Mari out of the chosen
champion zone getting called the week is
exactly the interaction that watch would
not have been wanting to see. Wow. Is
that all body runes?
>> Oops. All body. Which means that even
from now, you know that there's like no
defy coming.
>> It makes life a lot more easy for
Retaxel to come through. Sabotage is one
of those cards we talked about and so is
Imperial Decree. There's safety
inspector there as well. Um,
>> oh, that's painful. This is a hard that
you pro a hand that you
>> feel pretty rough with.
>> Probably the saddest decree take we've
seen in a while.
>> I I want to take the decree, but you
know, this still isn't
>> I will take the decree, but I will
complain the entire time.
>> Yeah, exactly. Um, we saw Face Breaker
doing some work to kind of slow down in
the last game. Um, it's not on its own
the best uh card in hand, but again,
it's just another utility to say, "Hey,
until I have the resources and cards
available, I'm going to let you do
nothing for a while."
>> And it is the the the same situation as
why challenge is such a profitable card
as well. It is really efficient at just
keeping off singular targets that carry
a lot of might that are proper bombs
keep him at bay and also good to know
when you uh launch it onto the quay he
won't be getting a extra move from that
it's a recall.
>> Sure. Yeah. Okay. That that
>> so like it it's it's not opening the
door for more move shenanigans against
teleorners and the likes.
Trying to think of what the outs are for
WTE here. Got to establish a board. The
fact that Red Knax is already up to
three now. Building the board in base.
That wages of pain could hurt could hurt
a lot if it's just
the pit rookie
>> going in without any additional benefit.
You're you're essentially just like
trading up on resources the entire time
while ahead.
Yay. In dire straits first wave will be
a second body, but once again both of
them definitely within that wages of
pain range. Defy ready to answer that if
need be, but that is still so many
resources to keep alive. Chaff units
that that is not the way you want to be
going. Does have the resources available
for pretty much everything in hand.
There was a Rengar in there as well. Uh,
how much you spend on this turn I think
is
>> mana punch first Petroi.
>> Yeah.
>> So here's the thing. Why do I like this?
In contrast to the previous turns, we
need to make a drastic change in our
game plan. We need to catch up.
>> And that is coming at the cost of
future.
>> Yes,
>> I mentioned Rengar. Rockfall path not a
viable uh way to play cuz it prevent
units being played there. So this
>> showdown it is not an option.
>> I'll try to stun us both.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh defy that.
>> Yes.
>> There is the exchange you were
mentioning with to fight for the face
break. That would have been
>> to eclipse.
>> Brutal.
>> But the brutality is not done just yet.
Oh, he he you can tell that Vocheek is
kind of fed up with that. He's
>> repeatedly walking into wall after wall.
>> He has the resources for the Rengar, but
you can't on rockfall path. The rest of
the cards in hand. Yeah, there's one
floating, right?
>> Oh, yeah, I see it. I see.
>> Um
>> uh defy at Yes,
>> another defy. So,
>> has to drop down in resources. We'll end
up
>> two. Yes.
>> Scoring to two. This is the most spoiled
pit rookie I've ever seen.
>> One.
>> It has been fed four runes to get the
job done. But they get the job done.
They managed to get stuck on a
battlefield.
>> Yeah.
>> Can they remain? And we know for a fact
with the safety inspector. All right.
>> Here on top do a little bit to alleviate
some of the pressure. But the other half
of it is Red Axel has such a much better
economy on on the side of resources
available. Both access to a unit every
turn, the recruit token, plus just all
of the runes. We know that wages of pain
is there in hand when it needs to
potentially be used as well.
>> And it, like you said, the the tempo
that is coming out from Victor, the
units that he's able to spawn, it is
relentless. every single turn chugging
out one after the other if they have the
room for it. Meaning that every turn
they can threaten a play. They can
threaten a battlefield.
However, the one downside is it's been a
while since they've drawn any cards.
>> Yeah, that that is very very fair. Uh
Red Knox though is refilling a little on
their units there. the deck that's
getting the the use
>> four
>> already up to four as well
and again fighting around the rockfall
path saying okay next turn I don't want
to give you the opportunity to put
Rengar on a battlefield I I I want to
force you to commit more if you're going
to end up playing the Rengar by putting
a unit into for instance Arena's
greatest or um you know having to play
Renar out slowly which is not ideal it's
never ideal when you play Rengar in
base,
>> this is not the way you want to be
going. Preferably, you want to surprise
him as a surprise defender.
>> Y,
>> but that seems like a ways away still.
>> Let me consider that.
>> Rarely do you see Victor
>> actually coming out from the chosen
champion zone. Uh a lot of victors I've
spoken to said if I'm doing that I'm in
dire straits. But actually I think the
opposite might be true here where you're
doing it because you want to use your
your uh economy. You want to use the
resources you have per turn. It is a
valid play. They have bought themselves
to
>> breathing room to be more
>> to be more open-minded to more expensive
plays like this. You can afford to take
a day off, relax a little bit, treat
yourself.
having spring break uh at this point as
Victor
makes an appearance
>> here.
>> Get that full arcane makeover
>> again. Now it
>> no Rengar available in this moment.
>> And is that
we knew there was
>> one in hand? Go three.
go here and pass
do this.
>> Sure.
>> Wages is a uh very fair response to that
and saying I'm not even going to give
you the opportunity
and adding effort to the economy of the
victor.
Once they hit a little top up on the
cards in hand, they can really start
racing away with it. We are channeling
currently, winding up our spring, and
when we get to unload,
>> yeah, sky's is the limit. There was the
opportunity
for, you know, red axel to play a
different way around it. Maybe wait and
bait out the Rengar uh like on a
subsequent turn, but just saying,
actually, you know what? Kind of just
want you to to stay in this situation.
And you have to feel like the the pace
attempt in this tells you that the hand
is not as simple as just like playing
the units out from hand and and passing.
And I I think to add on to what you had
to say by pushing Ye to either into the
the the split of I'm going to allow you
to run away from me
>> by not conquering the battlefield or I'm
going to
>> have to invest into once again these
very binary choices that he is left
with. Oh, and
>> I feel it's just vulnerable if you wages
of pain into safety inspector is just
such a killer play.
>> And now the other thing is the wages has
gone, but you've also got a unit and
you've got an eclipse that just came off
the top. So it's the same thing is you
can eclipse with the recruit go in
maybe, you know, whether it's the victor
or the recruit, take control of the one
battlefield, safety inspector comes in
and yeah, sure, that's fine. I don't
mind. I'll just I'll trade things on
you. And usually usually
the option the the way he plays is he
gets situated, he throws down the
gauntlet and says, "Go and fix that.
Pick that up. Challenge me." And the
challenges that Yeah. you're throwing
out there. Not very impressive.
>> Uh minus four. Uh yeah, it goes.
>> Yeah. And and just to be clear, it can
go to zero at this point. The game will
snapshot it and say, "Well, it's zero
now." And let's bring this guy over
here.
>> If it
>> there are things later.
>> And that explains also why then the
extra might that it gets from the ye
legend is not enough to get it. Exactly.
Yeah.
>> Um now you get to safety inspector,
>> which this is the the the trade that
every Victor is like is like a recruit.
I can get rid of I can can I make one
first? Is that is that how I do it? Oh,
a tap to recruit. And I get to make a
recruit. And then
>> I don't blame it. That's a damn good
deal.
>> Yeah, it's a very, very good deal.
>> Recruit in the back.
>> Oh, yeah, sure. Recruit in the base.
Sounds good.
>> This guy,
>> uh, it doesn't last very long. Okay,
takes that one. Okay. Of course, cuz you
want to deny the Rengar to follow. If
there is another one, you want to say,
"Nah, actually, I don't want you to be
able to see that."
>> Yeah.
>> Here we have Red Nexel threatening the
game. He will be taking it down two to
zero. And that is how you deal with the
most plate legend in Utre. Renaxel gets
past Bologna's best of master
and advances. That's got to be a really
good position for building towards top
eight. We'll now have to see exactly how
the end of this round uh works out with
the standings. But Red Knox just saying
yes, if you don't have any units, uh
that's fine. your your legend doesn't
work anymore. Uh, and I'll just I'll
make small units and just get out onto
the battlefields and and that's fine.
I'll take control of the the middle and
late game. And here's the thing, when
your deck time and time again feels like
it always has the right answers for
everything and it just feels plainly
unfair, like, oh, how are you getting so
lucky every time? You have always have
all the answers. That's how you know you
made a good deck. It did feel like Red
Axel had many of the answers as uh
taking just a look at I was going to say
highlights. This is the opening turns.
>> I Yeah, I mean
>> as far as a highlight every frame of
painting in this series.
>> Do we already have confirmation on our
our second feature map?
>> Uh I don't yet. I will as soon as I hear
as soon as I get whispers.
>> I'm just so excited. I can't wait cuz I
want to see kind of more of the Victor.
I really hope they do make it to the top
cut. One more round left to make sure
that they're not missing out at the very
last minute. They're not safe just yet
with 111. Do really need Maybe they can
squeeze in with 11 one.
>> Maybe is we've had people just be on
that the precipice to do that. And and
>> you need a very good loss, so to speak,
against a very good player to be certain
you'll still make it through.
>> Definitely depends on the math in in how
that goes. um bracket math and and Swiss
maths of of this many rounds. I don't
even pretend to put it in my head. Uh
the good players are all like, "Yeah,
can we are we through? Is that okay in
the last round? If we're if we're good,
are we able to make it for sure?" And
I'm just here like I I'm Yeah. No, I
have no idea. This is is at this point
the the bracket math is way out of
contention. It it does depend on
tiebreers. Honestly, you you kind of
have I do have respect for people who
say, "You know what? I don't really care
about EV. We ball, we play, and if I
lose, I lose." Of course, we will
continue to update you on uh the
standings as we go through the rest of
the day. We'll also update you on the
meta and how things are panning out. my
um I'll take you back to the beginning
of the show and I kind of put out that
that that thing in the way of I think Yi
was due a big day one and a whisper of a
day two. Individual games don't prove
it. I'm waiting to see the stats by the
end. I would have be happy to be wrong
as somebody that does play Ye.
>> So are you willing to to go out there
and say not a single Ye will make that
topic?
>> Oh, I did not say that. No, I'm I'm not
saying that. saying, "Are you willing to
make that statement now?" Honestly, it's
even easier now cuz we've we've already
gone through almost half of day two.
>> I can answer your question quickly as we
go to ask some more questions. And the
answer to that is no, I'm not willing to
say.
>> Barrett, what is our winner willing to
say?
>> Excellent cast once again from both of
you. But I have an excellent looking
legend pilot over here, Redneckil on
Victor in a dominating performance
there. You have all but locked in your
top eight for here in Utre. How do you
fail?
>> Um
yeah, it's it's strange. You know, I
didn't come here with Victor hoping to
get uh this high. I was actually hoping
to get 64 at best, but I guess uh you
know, luck was on my side.
>> More than just luck. You said top 64
aiming for that championship obvious
invite but you are not only piloting a
legend that we had have had a chance to
uh highlight but a legend that is now
going to make another sort of hopefully
a top eight performance that we haven't
seen since Bolognia.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So it's just so interesting to me
because the tools and the the choice on
Victor because the representation going
in I mean you can you can check the
tapes. I was surprised that it's like
the sixth most represented deck going
into this event, but a lot of people
have talked about the sort of aggressive
potential now of this deck. And you
know, we talked about Sprite Fountain
and how much it how much easier it is to
get on the board while still being a
menace with order in mind, being able to
remove a lot of your opponents.
>> Yeah.
>> Why do you think that's being so
successful right now in the game? Well,
the the combination of having the
consistency of Victor, you know, that
one certainty of a unit every turn in
combination with, you know, the chip
removal like Calvo week or uh hidden
blade, any any of the any of that. Um,
it puts a lot of pressure on the
opponent. They need to stop you from
conquering. They need to put their units
at risk and Victor can capitalize on
those units uh being vulnerable and take
them out. Um, and it can be played in a
few different ways. I've chosen, you
know, a build that doesn't allow room
for the player to find his cards
because, you know, even with Imperial
Decree, they can still abandon it or
hard bargain it or whatever. So, I'm
just hoping to end the game as fast as
possible before they before they find
their probably better cards than Victor
ones. And I really do think even cards
like Ash Focus that we've talked around
for, you know, it's was one of the
highlight rares I think coming out from
Unleash and not just your deck, but all
the other order decks that we've seen
high representation of even this card in
the sideboard. But it just information
is so important in this game and having
access to that with a deck like you said
that is so consistent on having those
units on top of being able to fight
against your opponents. But I'm just so
glad the deck has shifted toward this
sort of aggressive nature now. But once
again, congratulations on your win here.
You must feel amazing. I
>> It is. It is.
>> And I can't wait to watch the rest of
your journey because we only have so
much left here before we move to our top
eight. And of course, I hope to see you
there. Now, we're going to send it back
to the casters cuz we might have some
more action to get to.
>> Thank you, Barrett. We do. We do have
more action to bring.
>> You don't know the half of it.
>> It's such a good match. When we got told
when the whispers in my ear told me it's
not just the voices. I promise. I
promise there's actual people.
>> There are also little birdies flying
around.
>> We are looking at more players from the
top of our Swiss standings. And we're
going to have challenger TCG Colin, the
basically best of set going up against
Prismaticism, the best Annie. Like these
two are both like undeniably I would say
at least the community's opinion and and
with results to back it up, the best of
each of these champions.
>> Masters in their discipline. This is
these are the players that people lock
up to when they are trying to dip their
toes in. Now Colin we have seen before.
Rough loss against Allen completely
recuperated from that and is looking to
get himself mixed up in that top eight.
It's going to be
not the hardest I feel like because I
remember an earlier Colin match against
an Annie and that one did not go well
for the Annie.
>> Yeah, it definitely one of the
archetypes that Annie can struggle
against and a player especially as uh as
well practiced, well versed in in the
set as as Colin. You have to imagine
this is a matchup that has been tested
as well with this kind of meeting in
mind. Prismaticism on the other hand uh
absolutely one of the best players right
now that we have across the board. Um
this list, anything that you want to
pick up on the the the two cards that
immediately come to mind when we're
looking at this list is first of all to
a lower extent the grim apothecary.
>> Okay. just whenever set is trying to
land a haymaker, try and bail out your
units whenever possible. Second of all,
overzealous fan, a remnant from the past
for some back when Draven was uh still
kicking it around. Now, against a deck
that has so many resources tied up in
single units, this can be quite a nasty
position to be from. However, like most
situations for the Annie deck,
>> every situation, every card you play
feels situational. And once
>> the problem in front of you has gotten
so big, it feels like there's no way
back in for you.
>> Just to note, we are going into game two
of this. So, this is a post sideboard
game. And to reiterate the stakes here,
if Prismat loses out here and he is
fighting for his life currently going 10
on two
with some exceptions is a death sentence
when it comes to top eight cut.
>> Yeah, exactly. And that's one of the
reasons why we say that like top
eighting an event is a significant uh
accomplishment and an achievement. So
when you look at the the history of both
of these players, you're like, "Wow,
these are literally two uh players that
we expect to be in contention for that."
Now we'll see what prismaticism has as
we'll be going first in this matchup. Of
course, game two of this series.
Prismaticism has been counted out in
times before at least, you know, like
has has flown under the radar and then
just kind of had a monster performance
that uh I mean we've seen the
performance um in Atlanta.
>> Exactly. In Atlanta bringing the Rengar
to the to the dance. So, we'll see what
can happen in this one. you. The only
way you know you've won from
prismaticism if you've shaken his hand.
>> Exactly. Once that concession has come
through, Lucian comes out for for Colin.
Is there an answer there? Nope. Just fan
into Nox's hopeful going to develop
units. Gets the untap as well from the
Annie legend ability. That's the danger.
We've said it since release. The danger
of Annie is can never be counted out
from having resources and options
available going into the opponent's
turn.
>> Yeah, as a as an child, there's some
mischievousness there. Little bit of
unbreakability. Lucian will be readying
itself after the conquer looking to run
away with just a little bit. One thing
is for certain, you don't want to be
leaving it around there. Won't any
longer. And if we're fully committing,
if we're fully tapping out, that will be
the entrance of Fiora getting buffed up
here.
>> Yes. And because Fiora is buffed
becoming mighty, now you get the the
keywords that Fiora brings online. And
the important one, at least at this
stage about Annie is the deflect. Uh you
just want to punish them for targeting
uh a unit like Fiora, which already
takes resources to break.
going over the options just
a little bit more for prismaticism
will be taking the turn. Now,
here's where it gets a little tricky.
You want to keep up with points without
taking unfavorable trades. That Lucian
>> dooming and glooming in the background
makes it a lot harder. now giving them
the punching bag of affairs forerrunner.
Is that enough of a anchor to keep
prismaticism tied to that battlefield?
Yeah, that that's a really great great
question. And people that perhaps
haven't seen Annie in a little little
while may say, "Hey, where are the
damage spells? Like where are the things
that that just kill the units in front?"
Um, this kind of build that prismaticism
has been running recently is a lot more
unit focused. That Ferris 4Runner still
has massive value. Um, and to be fair,
outside of um of Starcross, the meta
doesn't have too too many ways of of
getting through a ferris 4runner still
without giving you the units on the back
end that the death nail breaks.
Starcross is really the only way that
you're like, "Yeah, get out of there."
>> So hard to trade efficiently. Yeah.
>> Into that. And that is what the Annie
deck is all about. Efficient trades. And
that is what set is so good at ruining
because oh, we're going to trade. No,
I'll just pay a power and recall my my
big strong buff boy.
>> That's something that we'll uh we'll
keep an eye on how many times that
legend ability happens. Set does have to
expend quite a lot to get over a
battlefield like this. So, the question
is how do you break it?
>> And you have to be mindful that you're
not overinvesting. Yeah,
>> cuz you every time that you're going to
come out, swing it with a punch first
and then you get flashed away,
>> you're kind of like, yay, I won here.
Oh, stacking the uh second battlefield
as well. I I I wanted to say one thing
that normally we we uh need to keep an
eye on is hard bargain is one of the the
spells that can be cast with Annie's
untap ability. Like you're having that
two is always important.
>> We're
kind of just telling Annie, all right,
you can sit there all you want, but I am
in the lead of points. when it comes
back to me, I'll be going up to four
>> and you have to deal with my battlefield
rather than me having to deal with
yours. And if you want to deal with my
battlefield, well, there's two very
large bodies on there and I can save one
of them. So, trading efficiently is
simply not going to happen. That's a
play pattern we don't often see. All
right, that deck is stacked, stacked,
stacked, stacked with the amount of
times Prisma's had
>> stacks upon stacks
>> had options uh to to use that. That's
something we don't often see. And you
know what's better than three stack
decks?
>> Oh, but where I'm playing her,
>> this is really a a cause for alarm.
Using your Annie to get the stack deck,
sure, it's working as intended, but it
really signals my hand is not good
enough. I need to dig more. And even
though there's still some time left, if
you get to move one of those units from
sets battlefield, the Fiora or the the
set back to your base and then shows
stopper it into the arena's greatest can
be disaster.
>> What what's the dig for? Like I I I'm
looking through the deck list, thinking
about it like what if you're
prismaticism, what what options look
good for you? Is it Starcross? Is that
one of them that that you're looking I
feel like Starcross, maybe Rengar. It's
just so much might you get to get to
introduce with Rengar pouncing.
>> Anything to just clear out these
battlefields and stop this murderous
momentum that has garnished for him.
>> It it does feel though that like even
drawing that into hand, Prisma has to go
into the next turn and be like, okay,
well, if I am attacking, I have to have
the units available on six runes. Kind
of tricky. Kind of tricky to play
anything that's quick enough to get in
there. And this is what we mean by every
play that Prisbat makes is costing him
something and it's just not getting a
whole lot done on the board. If you look
at the economy sitting on set side, they
have a stacked battlefield, a base with
two units in it that can punish any
overextension if they want to, and a
hand chuck full of cards, runes for
days. They are rolling in it, commanding
where the game will go, leaving
prismaticism scrambling for answers.
>> I'll pass focus.
>> I'm really interested
>> to know how testing has gone. Who's been
playing uh playing Prismat's role of
like we'll just we'll just jam the Annie
match up again and again and again.
>> Yeah.
And now you have Colin at a
cross-section where you say, "All right,
will I mount the pressure upon the
enemy's battlefield?"
>> Or am I going to let it fester? Give
them like not punish their their their
position currently, but just establish
my own board even more. And with the
first mate untapping the irresistible fa
folk, we are whittling away at that
previously wellestablished arena script.
>> And Prismat doesn't have the resources
available for the Rengar that has become
synonymous with his win. Only has access
to two runes.
>> He has a flash in hand, but is that it's
really surviving currently, not
thriving.
>> I'll flash her back out. Does that
however set up Prismat for the next turn
for uh going offensively?
That's a stacked battlefield though. Is
it even possible from here?
>> Has to be.
>> The good news is if anything
Prismaticism currently has a little bit
of time. We talked about about Seth
before the boss how he has a titanic
momentum. It is really like navigating
with the Colossus. Not very nimble.
They're only scoring a single point per
turn currently. And if they want to
start really pressuring the other
battlefield, they either need a
showstopper or they need to invest a
turn to correct course and set up the
next assault. Annie on the other side a
lot more nimble docking and dodging
staying on their toes. But how do you
overpower a set? That's a great
question. And this Oh, another
forerunner.
There are some big units on both sides
of this. This is a an escalatory
moment in this game and even though
Prisman is in a tricky position right
now where a lot of his turns are very
>> high on the commitment that he has to
put through.
>> Sure,
>> you also have to keep in mind he is
currently keeping up. He's not that far
apart in victory points. If he manages
to find an opening, exploit it, blow the
game wide open.
>> Okay. and then I will play it. Okay,
just keeping track as Prismat took back
like reounder for a moment for the
4Runner for the stack deck first just to
uh look for a different option perhaps
and then ends up playing it out anyway
which if you're calling you're like oh
okay that means your your option wasn't
better here does give you maybe more
options for the next turn with stack
deck to set up it really reiterates that
prismatism is scrambling he's digging
looking for the solution to an ever
growing problem in front of them. But
I'm starting to feel like we have
crossed that point where Andy can find
efficient answers into a Fiora buffed up
into set that is growing bigger with
every friendly unit that is getting
buffed there.
>> Ready to pass.
>> Is there a way to pick it apart? I mean,
if if I was going to put my money on on
anyone doing it, prismaticism on the
Annie for this matchup, I'm like, that
would be the player I'd think.
There's just so many moving parts to be
keeping track of on the side of
prismatism because every turn you wait
every other turn that that fay the
irresistible fay folk will be trying to
lure another one of your bombs straight
into the waiting arms of well this
cacophony of buffed up units.
And this is essentially
>> essentially four top eight
>> here at RQ. So a lot on the line.
>> Come in here and pass focus.
>> I'll decline.
>> So we know for a fact
>> that Colin will
>> let's see what they have to say. of fan
floating in energy.
>> Pulling back the kingpin back to the
base with the first mate readying it.
looking to seal the fate of Prismaticism
on Arena's greatest if they can separate
right now. He's in a
>> for a world of hurt. Two runes only way
out. Oh, Vi on top of it as well.
Ganking with the Fiora.
>> Brings the Vi out from hand looking to
break the hold that Prismaticism had.
And we were talking about how does
Prisma break Colin's hold. The
turnaround is the other way of Colin
saying, "No, I'm not actually going to
let you do it. I don't need to weather
the storm."
>> And it's so impactful that with the
first mate and the mighty Fiora that you
get to bypass some of that rigidity that
we talked about earlier. Oh, set's not
too nimble. This is how they get around
that and this is how it catches even the
best in the world off guard.
And Prismaticism now scrambling for
answers. one and zero down in this
matchup now has a bunch of mech tokens
>> Harris 4unner and an Annie and you got
to keep in mind he's fighting for his
life because currently Colin is
threatening the game if he manages to
hold they can gank over there's plenty
of units to row around anywhere
prismatism goes there's two irresistible
fay folks to make life miserable slowly
but surely
it has to start to settle in that this
might be a position you simply do not
come back from.
>> And Colin, this is going to be a massive
potential scalp on the way to a top
eight. Potentially
putting Prismaticism in a situation
to not make it to a top eight. And it's
not just the win,
it is the fashion in which he's looking
to claim it. dominating two to nil,
making one of the best players in the
world look powerless. They're putting
everything to use to find that one way
out. And you, as you said it, Colin
already has the so so much utility on
the following turn. I haven't seen
what's in hand for a little bit, but
there's still cards there. You got all
the fa folk, as you mentioned, the gank
ability from Fiora and this board state
for prismaticism. you'd say, "Oh, well,
yes, okay, I've got units, but it a
couple of mech tokens not really what
you want to get pulled around the board.
Ferris 4Runner on its own is not that
great." But Prismat has to at least
mount some attempt at breaking this
board from Colin. But with everything,
you know that Colin's going to be able
to keep one unit alive at least with the
set legend.
>> How restrictive it feels even if Chris
Madison goes out for the hold. The fact
that there are two iris fay folks that
can pull away the strongest units out
there into their own demise by moving
them to the arena's greatest
>> makes it that you really are stuck
between a rock and a hard place. I
wonder if there's a way out with
Starcross and potentially um like
looping it with Annie if there's enough
resources there at least like playing it
once then getting it back in hand or if
there's anything else as Prismat's going
to go forward
>> to set
>> switcheroo
>> comes out of the sideboard targeting set
>> now
>> that will have to make it then
>> so I have against your
>> 14
Okay. Um, we will kill the ferris
4runner.
It's going to highlight the readyied set
that has now been put to use to keep the
kingpin himself alive.
Is this the way out? All the faith folks
are still sitting ready. And this is
what we mean by the the crushing tide
that set is bringing to a match where
it's so hard to answer a problem once
and for all. And and that's the thing is
it looks good on breaking that
battlefield for prismaticism but
>> has to be able to to maintain this hold
>> and even can get into the situation
where you break open a single
battlefield with let's say a set kingpin
>> then move your faith to that same
battlefield one by one picking your uh
the the valley of idols clean opening up
the gates to just simply walk in,
>> claim your victory.
>> And Prismaticism even taking the
opportunity to say I need this Rengar
one extra might. Maybe that's it's not
likely to do too much, but just every
little counts at this point, right? Like
have to do it, have to try.
>> If there's one way out, I'm representing
four energy available and and both
battlefields held, which does mean Colin
has to answer both.
>> I think you did.
>> Okay. Oh, that's fine. I can cast
everything in my hand anyways.
So the real value of a showstopper in
here is now you can play a unit and then
it's pseudo ready.
>> Yeah.
>> Targets uh
>> with the monk coming out giving two more
buffs to units on the board giving
insurance policy.
These are my targets.
Five up. Yeah.
>> Yep. Okay. Feels like this
passage of play Colin is just dotting
the eyes, crossing the tees, and saying,
"Okay, what
what is the line
that is best for prismaticism, and how
do I avoid that? How do I pick my best
line
through this situation?"
>> I'll come in here and pass focus.
Just the first mate goes wanting to
>> eat through the Annie first.
>> Says, "Let's see what you got. Can I
bait you in to give me anything?" Now
trying to just go one over the top with
Lucian.
>> And you're covering off angles for being
blown out the water by a a star cross in
this case by just
>> landing little jabs, seeing right when
will you say enough is enough? And up to
this point, prismaticism is taking the
hits and getting bruise in the process.
>> And the thing is, prismaticism is
looking at a hand and saying, "If I if I
long sword, I can't starrust. If I star
cross, I can't do anything else." And
that means I'm running out of options.
There is a set. There is two
irresistible fave folks.
>> The line, the line is has to be there.
Fa folk is going to look to pull
potentially. You would think it's going
to be the the token
>> over here. And that Rango will be, if
that is the next target, will be getting
all of the assault bonuses. But that is
a small price to pay if you're looking
to secure yourself into the top eight.
Colin thinking about it, thinking, do I
want to even do that? Is it better for
me to just go over the top while Rengar
doesn't get those bonuses? Is that the
best way? Will
thinks about it, takes it back, actually
is going to pull Lucian away cuz he
doesn't need to win the combat. It's
fine. And Rengar's just got to get out
of there. If you're Colin, you've
already scored the first battlefield and
you score the win over Prismaticism
knowing both conquers would come
through. Colin will win against
Prismaticism and again look to move
forward towards that top eight. Berading
himself into another top eight. Here is
a set that I want to see go further and
further. Sadly, it means we most likely
have to say goodbye to not only Alan
from an earlier round, but now
prismaticism as well, which
the competition is being thinned out and
even the best of the best are struggling
to get themselves secured in top eight.
Yeah, we we're figuring out we're
running all the numbers to figure out
who is going to be making our our top
eight. You still have one round left of
action as we're getting ready for
a video. In fact, it's an interview
first with our winner
Barrett Bryant here and I am absolutely
thrilled to be joined with another
player who has all but locked in their
top eight until I see it on that piece
of paper. But Colin Kaiser, now we had
you on stream earlier, so first of all,
we have to address that. Of course,
>> you did lose to Allen's EQ in a great
match. It was It was phenomenal. Game
one and two, whatever, but game three
was so fun. So, and I had the pleasure
of, of course, talking to him after
that. So, you've been X and one going
into the rest of the tournament, but
that win against Prismaticism decidedly,
powerfully.
How does it feel to maybe solidify or to
basically solidify your second top eight
now with Set the Boss? It uh honestly
feels incredible to be able to have my
favorite legend and just be able to play
it at the highest level and be able to
beat Prismat, one of the goats of
Riftbound, you know. Um and it's uh
yeah, there's no feeling like it.
>> Don't sell yourself short. Not only are
you goated playing people or playing
legends like Set the Boss, but the
liftbound trend coming in, of course,
you know, and I I've got to I've got to
tell you as well cuz I I want to update
you cuz you just got out of an
incredible match. But what if I also
told you that Challenger TCG is really
showing up at this event. Challenger TCG
billionaire has all but also locked in
his top eight appearance on Volibar.
>> Volibe Bear. That's my goat. first first
time appearance in a top eight
essentially is this close to happening
and you both hopefully of course don't
find each other if that ends up but
>> crossed
>> it's got to feel amazing right you put
both of you just in general putting the
spotlight on you and this sort of and
even prismaticism your opponent these
specializations of these legends and
really showing that anything is possible
in Riftbound if you put in the work and
you put in the hours because frankly as
someone who we talk a lot I also love
set but I'm not playing the same deck as
you. I play the brawler version. And
granted, every time I watch you play, I
know that your deck is so much better
for the the format right now. And you
have been stuck on Kingpin for so long.
Literally the champion of the Kingpin
deck.
Why? How did it start? It started all
the way back even before we got to
Houston. And you were just showing the
world that there are different ways to
play these legends, and if you put in
the work, it really pays off. Why
Kingpin and why has it come even now all
the way to this point of just like it's
just the better deck especially for you
and your play style?
>> Yeah, I mean obviously at this point
I've certainly proven it's the better
deck than the brawler variation. No
offense,
>> no taken.
>> But uh yeah, I honestly just fell in
love with the play style all the way
back to set one when I was still uh in
its infancy. I was playing primal
strengths as a three of instead of punch
first as my way to win combat. And
honestly, more so than anything, I just
fell in love with the style of these
hold decks that really have to predict
what my opponent is going to do on the
next turn. And that's what sets all
about is knowing exactly what my
opponent does before they even know what
they're going to do, right? And then I
can math it out in my head with all my
cards, how my cards interact with their
cards, and it truly is one of the most
difficult play styles in Refbound, in my
opinion. So, uh, yeah, and I just love
any sort of deck that can give me a hard
time, that makes me think constantly,
gives me a headache at the end of the
event. Uh, that's what I'm looking for.
You don't know this, so I'm going to
tell you this now live on air or I I
applaud you every single time I talk
about you to other players and other
people because the way that this deck
plays, the way that set in general
plays, you have to play your runes and
power management and recycling so tight
that you make people wse when you play
being so comfortable playing at only
five runes, six runes in a game. But
that's how the deck and the way that
you've piloted it has been for so long.
I remember when you were playing a
billion four drops in your deck because
that's how important it was to find the
key ones that mattered and the way that
you keep them alive with sets ability
and you know in you know especially back
then when you could conquer and then
ready set again and have another use
where you could aggressively trade into
your opponent but playing with your
runes so pre with such precision is a
true skill that I think you show off
more than so many other players in the
world. So,
>> I applaud you
>> and congratulations
>> on your win.
>> I hope to see you in top eight here
shortly. Of course, we have one more
round to get through, but I hope you
might have a little bit of a relaxation
break to prep for that, but we're going
to go ahead and send it back.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Allen's first rendevous with
league-based card games was in Legends
of Rune Terror. His commitment to become
the best in the world paid off when in
2021 he won the inaugural Legends of
Rune Terra World Championship. Four
years later, Allan makes his debut in
regional qualifier Houston, ready to
show the world he still got it.
>> There were no believers in my version,
but it's been proving and proving back
and back running undefeated scrimmage
back here yesterday being undefeated
again. And Allan not only makes it to
day two, but pushes eventual champion
Dewali to his limit in their top eight
match, narrowly losing out in game
number three. Regardless, Allan secures
himself a top eight finish and the best
of Kai'Sa. A feat that for many would be
their crowning achievement. But not two
months later, the beast from the east
shows his true colors as a flourishing
partnership between Allen and Ezreal
starts. Allan's loyalty to the legend he
knows better than anyone else pays off
as he steamrolls the opposition at
Bolognia. Starting not only the longest
winning streak in competitive Riftbound
ever witnessed, he also becomes the
first undefeated regional qualifier
champion.
>> Alan ZQ.
>> 24 official matches in a row. Allan goes
undefeated in Las Vegas. He secures
another top a result that he mirrors in
Atlanta where he claims his third best
of Ezreal. The dedication is unmatched
as are the results. But Allan wants
more.
Unleashed releases and with it Allan
creates a new deck. Staying true to the
chaos and mind domain, he runs a
spell-heavy Diana list that rivals the
consistency of his earlier Ezreal and
secures him yet another top eight in
Sydney. Having found his footing on the
lunar legend from Unleashed, Vancouver
is ripe for the taking until a familiar
foe rears his face in the top four.
Dwali is once again in the way of
victory. This time around, Alan's EQ
gets his revenge for Houston. In game
three, he outpaces Dwali and finds
himself standing in the finals, closer
to a second title than anyone ever
before.
Or is he? Because in the final, awaiting
Allen is no one else than the final boss
from Vegas, Sam D. Sherman, also on the
hunt for his second trophy.
Two titans clash and Alan ZQ's dreams
are hanging on by a thread as the pride
stalker strikes first and takes game
one. Game two has Sam two points away
from greatness. But Alan ZQ gets to it
first, equaling the score. Game number
three is a statement. The best Diana in
Vancouver ramped up through the entirety
of the finals match. Allan ZQ rises
above rivals, charges past champions,
and becomes the first twotime regional
qualifier champion. Mate Yajinski, Alan
ZQ, a 100% day two conversion rate. Six
top eight appearances, five best of
medal cards, two regional qualifier
trophies.
Welcome back to Quick Decks at the RQ in
for Riftbound. Welcome. I'm joined by
Jabin. At this format, players are going
to have 30 seconds to explain their
decks to me. Jabin, what deck are you
running? I am playing Pike, the Blood
Harbor Ripper. I'm just really obsessed
with this play style. I've tried a bunch
of decks in Unleashed, but the discard
mechanic that Pike really abuses is just
too satisfying a loop to play.
>> That sounds great. I'm going to start
the timer in three, two, one, go.
>> Okay, core cards of Pike. Obviously,
this is the big one. Bewitching Spirit.
There's something particularly evil, I
think, about making your opponent choose
what they want to discard that is so
much more fun than like Mindsplitter.
So, that's a really satisfying one.
Obviously like the champion unit. I
think a lot of decks like the champion
unit is kind of an addendum, but this
one is really really significant.
Accelerate out, get points like that,
steal points, really really valuable.
And I think the last big one for me is
Baron Nasher. I think Pike is probably
the second best deck behind Diana and
playing it. But ramping to this, getting
it out and using it as a windcon really
stop. All right. Wow, that was really,
really loud. Okay, you hit the 30se
secondond mark. So, let me summarize
this a little bit for you. You like to
discard cards from your opponent. You
like to bounce those cards. You steal
points, you steal their cards in hand,
then you bounce them and you do it all
again. Is that about right?
>> That nails it. Yeah. Bewitching spirit
number one.
>> All right, we got it. Thank you so much
for your 30 seconds of time, Jin. And
we're going back to the action.
>> That's right. There we are getting back
into the action here as we have our last
Swiss round to get to get involved with
before we get into our top cut action.
I'm Sha Burton joined by Leo. Leo, we
are getting to really to the
nitty-gritty business end of the event.
>> We have so many players already locked
in. Basically, we have a Volibar. We
have a set. And of course, Squirtle. I
think he broke Alensq's undefeated
record. Now, I think he's still
completely undefeated in this tournament
as well. Has never dropped a game. That
is absolute madness. So Volibear, Set
and Azir, those are already three decks
without the Chaos Domain. When has that
ever happened?
>> Can't imagine that's happened terribly
often. A couple of those decks a bit of
a surprise as it were. So I'm excited to
see how our top cut pans out. But there
will still be some players jostling to
try and get in and amongst that top cut.
I'm sure we're going to try and get some
of those matches up coming up soon.
>> I think we have also some other decks.
Maybe we are going to see a Rexai.
Actually, I can see that it is also
already locked in.
>> So that that's a guess. That's a guess.
I think I've heard something like that,
but I don't want to make any false
promises. However, I would definitely
love that thinking about the predictions
that we made earlier where I went with
the Rexi Void Borrower. What a deck. It
is so much fun to see an aggro deck also
relying on the top deck. So you have
this little value engine that you can
always rely on every time. You are
ramping up the steam, right? You are
still putting some fire on your
opponent's seats and you also get free
top decks all the time.
>> Yeah, I know it's quite fun to see that
aggro deck playing out. That rack site
was per motion when we had it on stream.
One thing I want to have a look at
though is our most used gear and what we
have been seeing so much here in Utra
and it looks like that Za hourglass
coming in at 20% guardian angel there at
14 sprite bouncing there 14. Anything
there anything there that jumping out
and surprising you there?
>> I don't hate it that dazzling aurora is
only at 10%.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm very very fine with that. Last
rights is surprisingly low there. has of
course also some of these Aurora
situations has lost its impact in most
of the other decks before that was
sometimes also played in some kind of
dianalist maybe Ezreal that kind of has
shipped away heart of dark ice kind of
strong presence and the pack of wonders
of course in all these Ezreal pike heavy
decks
>> yeah just so many there pack of wonders
we did actually get to see that on our
stream and that can honestly start
ripping cards out your opponent hand in
used in combination with that bewitching
spirit. But yeah, I think looking at
this, no realistically big surprises
there. Thought long sword maybe could
have been a little bit higher. We see
that in quite a few of our decks now.
But yeah, I think the biggest surprise
to me was the dazzling Aurora only. I
say only quote unquote speech mark at
10%.
>> Yeah, it's I mean it's it's quite
healthy, right? I think people who have
played Aurora previously because they
said it had a good spot in the meta game
might have shied away from it a little
bit because some decks like Hook Leblanc
are around. This deck outscales Aurora
sometimes which is crazy to say and of
course an infinite Lux loop which you
really can't stop because you need a few
turns before you can start conquering
yourself and then you're also still not
very fast at that. You're just going to
lose those matchups very likely.
>> Yeah. So I think we have something else
we can look at here next. going to be
unit or spells. Let's have a look. And
it is going to be spells. Okay, Gus
there at 42%. Now, you did mention a
little bit as we're talking about decks
that could be locked up if our top cut
and beyond. Haven't actually mentioned
any chaos yet in theory. Don't don't
hold me to that. But G still our most
used spell.
>> I mean, Gust is a spell that the decks
that we are seeing already being locked
in. They can play around those quite
nicely, right? Trifarian war camp is a
battlefield that is utilized a lot. And
of course also buffing cards with set
sometimes gets you out of this gust
range. So I think the matchups into
those chaos decks that are running Gus
that are trying to abuse other decks
like Leblanc those matchups become a lot
better. Also defy is a centerpiece of
the meta game for Origins. Spirit forge
and unleashed. And if you're running
these crazy aggressive decks like Darius
that is also locked in now I got it. I
think it was Darius not Rexai.
>> Maybe it's both of them. Who cares?
We're going to see soon. People do care.
But you are finding yourself with so
many aggressive units. Your power plays
are ambush units as well. And Defy loses
some of its flexibility. Usually against
most of the decks, Defy will have some
targets,
but those targets are not as impactful
against
those Fury and Order decks or against
Fury and body or order and body. all of
these different options they play around
defy so well.
>> So yeah, we're looking at spells there.
I think nothing too surprising, but
let's have a look at the units. Let's
see what there is. And to no one's
surprise there, I think that Vex
apathetic when you see uh Gust as our
most used spell, it's not it wouldn't be
crazy to think that it would be a chaos
unit as our most played there at 37%.
But for me, the biggest surprise there
though, Leo, that disarming rate coming
in at the place there at 30%. Now, we
know that gear hate is rather good right
now. But 30% disarm rate, that is
surprising.
>> Yeah, people just want to get rid of
dazzling aura, right? I kind of kind of
like there's also decent versus a trying
to target those BF swords. What I really
like to see is 19% on Ash Focus and on
VIP peacekeeper because those cards are
phenomenal. VIP peacekeeper. Another one
of those heavy cost combat tricks that
plays around cards like Defy that does
not get irritated by counter spells. And
also, of course, the other cards in
there as you can see, Vex, Apathetic,
Scuttle Crab, Titer, Fist Trickster, all
those utility decks, all of those those
chaos decks with Scuttle Crab also come,
you know, Aurelia the top dog of the
meta together with Master Yi. Then Diana
of course as well abusing that Vex
Apathetic. Those decks are phenomenal.
We have seen them succeed already in
unleashed season, but
order is on the rise again. Vi
peacekeeper really showing that she is
one of the strongest cards in the game.
And I wonder when Vi is going to have
the biggest breakthrough as a legend
because constantly having access to this
legend, this chosen champion unit as
well in the V peacekeeper can assert a
lot of pressure on your opponent, right?
So
>> you try to stall it out as much as
possible, not use it for the longest
time that your opponent every single
time they are defending has to be super
afraid of a VIP peacekeeper and then
therefore maybe lose trades on purpose
and you can get points, more points,
more points, more points.
>> Yeah, only a couple percent there behind
that V from the Rengar. And let's round
off the list and looking at our most
used battlefields. No, I find this very
interesting because you got the sort of
tempo battlefields there of like Arena's
greatest and the Targon's Peak, but then
you have, you know, the sort of
defensive ones there in Aspirin's Climb
and Abandoned Hall as well.
>> Yeah. And I I wouldn't even call
Abandoned Hall necessarily defensive
because in decks like Diana, if you're
playing versus something
>> like a Y or a deck that likes to double
hold in abandoned hall, if you can
somehow force them to sit in the
abandoned hall, this is where you get
your value trades. This is where your
stack deck when you have a Raven Bloom
student becomes a plus two might spell
in Diana in Urelia. When you try to
overwhelm your opponent with those
spells, you're not paying a lot for
them. You are getting so much value out
of those. And which decks can rival
that? In mirror matches, okay, abandoned
Hall is a 50/50. It just makes the game
way more complicated. But in decks that
have less spells than yours, Abandoned
Hall is just an absolute menace. and
basically in some situation kind of
fixes the disadvantages that you have
from going second.
>> And Arena's greatest there. One of my
favorite battlefields. Basically giving
you a free point if you remember. Got to
remember that trigger there for Arena's
greatest. But while we're getting ready
for our next Swiss round, we do we did
actually manage to catch up with Dvali a
little bit earlier. Let's hear from him.
Barrett Bryant here joined with an
absolute pleasure for Dewali, one of our
reigning regional qualifier champion and
I still got to say it to this day. It's
always a pleasure talking to you because
you're the first one like and that will
never be taken away and so
>> but not only just that but you are the
epitome of you know other players like
Allen and Prismat and we'll get to that
in a second but of this game is hard and
the skillful ones continue to do well.
You just came off of a semi-finals in
Vancouver.
>> Yeah.
How are you doing? That was a rough
match. I mean, it's that's a that's one
of the strongest players of this game,
if not the strongest player.
>> How's your mental going is really where
I'm at.
>> Uh mental is good. I mean, like uh we
both, you know, not to take anything
away from Sam, but we thought, you know,
whoever won our match is most likely to
be the first two time just because we
think we have a good match up in Dengar.
Um, and you know, that's a lot of
pressure, I think, for one match because
I'm thinking, you know what, if I win
this, I'm likely to win the whole thing.
Uh, obviously it was a really tough loss
and I wish I'd won, but at the same
time, you know what, Allan's super good
and uh, you know, I've been talking to
him and he told me, you know, in in our
match after he beat me, he's like, if we
played 100 more games, we'd be 50/50.
So,
>> that's such an awesome thing to say.
>> Yeah. So, I I got to play a few more
games against him and then, you know
what, maybe I'll get to 50/50 and beat
him next time. You say 50-50, but
>> Dewali, I was there in Houston when you
beat him.
>> And that was also an incredible match
>> going into your eventual win in Houston
because like let's be real, like I mean
the finals I thought was pretty fast.
Your semi-finals was a grinder and then
you had to play against Allen as well.
So you won there
>> and now there's this, you know, you're
playing you're both playing Diana. You
were playing different versions
obviously. So I I kind of went, how
about that? you know, like do you think
that version is better specifically when
it gets to that top cut situation? Cuz I
I think the Frigid Touch or the Frigid
Jewel version is much better for the
field.
>> Yeah, it is.
>> So my question though is that I mean to
win these events, Dwali, you have to
beat those
>> players that are playing the more
specialized versions. What's the game
plan right now? Do we kind of still
tailor to that or have we made some
changes maybe?
>> So it's it's kind of like a give and
take like you're mentioning, right? you
have a better shot at doing well on day
one and like maybe the early rounds of
day two if you have a more general
version with Juul. Um, but my goal when
I come to these things is to win, right?
So I think like for example this
tournament I brought one that I think is
better for the top tables and I hope to
get a little bit you know fortunate I
guess during the Swiss in terms of not
running into anything that's like a
really bad matchup. Um, and then when I
get to the top tables if I can get there
then I should in theory have a better
shot. So that way, you know, if I play
against Allen again, I'm not slightly on
the back foot. At least I can make it
closer. And I think we're on the same
list this time. So
>> So, okay. So I I do want to pay for that
cuz to me that's like one of these it's
I I say the word rivalry, but at the end
of the day, respect for each other,
incredible players.
>> What about the rest of the people in the
room? you know, there are obviously, you
know, we talked about Sam a little bit,
prismaticism, you know, like I there's
this there's this
>> pillar of players right now and you you
are one of the players on that pillar,
but there's other people as well and
it's like I don't know how much, you
know, you obviously you haven't really
ran into him in the tournament setting
necessarily a ton, but
>> what do you think it takes when I fast
forwarding a little bit when we get to
things like a championship? Yes.
>> What's gonna happen when you put all of
you in the same room and you can
actually start getting paired against
each other in rounds one, two, maybe
like three.
>> That would be wild. So, you know, of
course, it's not just me versus Allen. I
think it's a bit of that dynamic because
we played in top eight now a bunch of
times and we're playing the same deck,
but I mean, we have Prismat, right? Uh
we have the challenger guys. They have
multiple top eights. You have Colin, you
have Daniel. They're all great players,
honestly. Um you have Sam, right? Sam's
a repeat top eight. He's one. Um so, you
have these great players. you have, you
know, there's Chinese players like Rico,
for example, that's incredibly good. So,
there's a ton of amazing players and
when you get to that championship level
where each round is a grind, you know,
round one you're against Prisma, round
two against Allen, I think I need to
maybe up my endurance because it's it
really is a grind on the mental when you
every round you're getting put through
the ringer. Um, but honestly, hearing
that makes me super excited. Every round
is going to be a
>> banger and I can't wait to see that
happen. But for now, we still have some
regional qualifiers to go through and I
expect to see you at basically all of
the
>> That's my goal. Yeah, that's my goal.
>> Making a name for yourself here in
Riftbound, and it's just the first year.
So much more to come. Dali, an absolute
pleasure, and I wish you luck in your
Riftbound career in the future to come.
>> Thanks so much. We're going to send it
away.
>> With me, I have a very special guest all
the way from Sweden. a familiar face to
the league connoisseurs out there. Dad
of the dudes, it is no one else than
Spooky. Spooy, how you doing?
>> That was good. That's how I want to be
introduced everywhere.
>> It is my pleasure. Now, we are at the RQ
and I'm very curious. What is your
schedule looking like this weekend?
>> So, I went in to this event. This is my
first RQ and this is my first TCG, so
I'm a bit of a noob, but I wanted to
have as many fun events as possible. So,
I'm only going to do sides. I'm going to
do a little bit of sealed, maybe try out
draft a bit. There's some creator events
that I can take part in that I'm kind of
excited. There's like talks of uh draft
where you can play like a booster from
each set which seems kind of cool. So,
I'm just going to be doing that and then
roaming around. There's a lot of things
to see here like you know all the
vendors have some cool stuff. Uh there's
some photo booths I want to check out.
There's the wall over there where you
can like uh write your signature and
stuff. So, that's what I'm going to be
uh jumping on. There is plenty to be
looking out for. And any any highlights?
I'm really excited to get involved in
either this one or that one.
>> I mean, well, first off, highlights for
me is always like meeting people that
has watched my videos back in the day or
are watching them now. That's always
like the best thing to go to any of
these events. But uh I think I'm really
looking forward to playing a lot of the
um uh games where you open packs. So
whether it's draft or seal uh or maybe
even that box draft thing, that seems a
bit that seems like a lot. But yeah,
like opening cards and then playing out
of what you get seems really really fun
to me.
>> Yeah.
>> I honestly I can't wait. A box is a lot
of cards to be going through.
>> It's pretty intense.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> However, you have been putting in the
time locally at your local game store
with a streaming setup.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I haven't encountered like that
anything like it in the wild. What was
your local's reaction to you introducing
that to the store?
>> It was the best. So like Alpha Scale
Stock where I where I play every week,
they're they've been really supportive.
Uh and uh you know, I always wanted to
strike a balance of making sure that
everyone that goes there cuz not
everyone that goes there might want to
be on a live stream. So we always make
sure that everyone is comfortable with
it. And if you sit down and you get
matched with me, you don't have to be on
stream. I just go to the pause screen.
Uh, but that's only happened once I
think since I got there because it turns
out everyone is just so awesome and
loves hanging out and like everyone is
we're all nerds so we're a bit
introverted most of us but we're also
really social at the same time. Uh, so
it's just been a blast. Uh, and we've
been steadily growing so now we're about
like 50 people every week who just comes
down and plays uh place mound. Yeah,
it's awesome.
>> It sounds like a real treat and I mean
as any new project there are some
obstacles to overcome. What is the next
iteration? What is like ah if I can
change that or I want to update to
really pull it to the next level. What
what's on the menu here?
>> Okay. Well, let's let me just first say
that if you're doing rip bound content,
the glare, man, the glare is like the
devil that you have to overcome. No
matter what light you put on a card,
it's just going to glare out the whole
car. So, what I do is I come like 2
hours early early before the event
starts and I put like, you know, paper
bags over the lamps and I like cover
everything up and it looks like a weird
grotto cave in there, man. When I'm done
and then, you know, we get the game in.
But yeah, I think um something that's
more interactable would be cool as an
upgrade. Like maybe that you can hover
over cards while you're watching the
stream, they can pop up and you can read
about them. That'd be cool.
>> I like that. Just to get more in with
the viewers themselves. So in your local
scene we you have been seen playing many
a legend. Now just talk me through what
makes you stick by a legend just that
little bit longer.
>> Usually it has to be a legend that not
everybody plays that isn't the meta and
then I play until I win basically. So
right before I got here I
>> that that does explain why why you're so
long on a jack.
>> Yes, it is true. But before I got here,
I got 40 on Kha'Zix on my Nexus night.
And that was like the highlight of my
Riftbound career, I tell you. Uh, so now
I might be ready to move on to something
else. I've been playing a lot of Kha'Zix
the past weeks. Any teasers maybe?
>> Oo, I wonder what that could.
>> You can figure it out.
You can just go on that.
>> Now, I'm very curious, right? Because in
my experience, you're always going into
new games with friends. Which CG members
have been accompanying you on this new
Ripon journey, if any?
>> So, none, because I haven't reached out
to them about this because uh it's
always been a little bit hard to
schedule because I play games during
work hours and they work during work
hours and then, you know, we we're all
grown grown up now. So, it's like a
little bit hard to schedule, but uh not
many of them live in Stockholm either
where I am. So, it's a bit harder to
sort of like get it going. They live uh
basically across the whole world but
also like different parts of Sweden. So,
but I'm going to have to do that. I'm
going to have to reach out to them a bit
more
>> for the next CG meetup. Is that
>> Yeah, for sure. For sure. Sure. But I I
will say the one thing that is so
phenomenal about CCDs, which I
understand now, I get it now. People
have been doing this for years, is that
you get to go out and meet a bunch of
new friends, which honestly, like I'm
sporting my 40s soon. It's kind of hard
to find new friends. Like, you know, I
don't know what people do. I guess they
have normal jobs and they meet them
there. But like I have going here
traveling here. I went here with 10 new
people that I call my new friends. I and
I didn't know them a couple of months
ago which is so cool. So you know a one
of a kind experience. Now to close it
off that I've I've been the people have
been clamoring
hypothetical situation. Planty is now a
playable legend.
What domains is Planty in and what is
the legend ability? I mean, it's
probably it's green. Obviously, it's
probably green yellow. Uh, so we're
we're probably thinking some sort of
jungle theme, creating a lot of sapling
tokens, flooding the board, swinging in
for good damage, something like that. I
like it. I like it. Riot, you listening
that. Get on that. Get on that. Subie,
thank you so much for joining me. Best
of luck in all of these side events and
more more to come. Back to you.
>> All right. Thank you so much for that
band as he catching up there with people
here, there and everywhere. I'm Sha
Burton joined by Leo and we are starting
to get towards our top cut action. But
now we're going to have our last round
of Swiss. We're going to have two
players battling out trying to get their
spot in top eight.
>> Yeah, it's getting tighter and tighter.
If you are new to the TCG world, top
eight is where you want to be. That is a
massive achievement. Out of almost 2,000
players, I think we're somewhere over
1,800. Yeah.
>> Being in top eight is absolutely crazy.
This is where the big prizes are and
this is where all the prestige is. Of
course, top 64 gets you the invite. That
is a massive accomplishment on its own.
This is also what people are really
playing for. But top eight, immediate
legend.
>> Yeah, immediate legend. You get you say
that increased prize in the money as
well. And to be honest, just a little
bit of bragging rights as well when you
say, "Oh, little bit." Huh? A little
bit.
>> Yeah, true. A massive amount of
bragging, right? That's what our players
there are going to be gunning towards.
And in our next match, we will be fe
featuring two players where it will
almost be a win or go home scenario. If
you win, you're in top eight, then you
can be in top four finals and beyond. If
you lose though, your tournament does
end there.
>> Yep. Still, if you are playing for a top
eight, you're if even if you lose,
you're going to probably get your
regional championship invite. So that is
already great. Also top 64. Nothing to
scoff at. Many of these players are also
still in contention for their best of
legends. Also local of mine still in
contention for the legends. So that is
that is pretty pretty sick. Pretty
excited to see how that is going. There
are so many games that have high stakes.
Now I have just checked out all of the
legends that there are in the tournament
still left in and there's so many match
games in this round. Everything is on
the line. And it's those heartbreak
moments, the high emotions. This is
where you can make or break your
weekend.
>> And what do you think, you know, as
someone who has, you know, got these top
eight placements in car games and
beyond? What if it's going through your
players heads here where, you know, your
top eight isn't confirmed, so you need
to win this next match there? What if
it's going for our players heads?
>> And that I think heavily depends on how
many top eights you've had before
because I think some people are
strutdded with confidence and they are
just waiting seeing ah maybe it works,
maybe it doesn't. But other than that
you are sweating. You have already had a
great accomplishment but it is a moment
of you know you got to keep it together.
This is the highstake moments. Not many
times in life will you face the
situation where you can achieve
greatness or just very close to
achieving greatness
fail and those stakes you you got to
have the nerves to play perfectly
through it. In the end rift bond is also
a game of mistakes. You have seen this
time and time again in the last few
tournaments. Even the best players in
the world will make mistakes in the
later rounds. There is fatigue as a big
factor as well. You cannot play
perfectly through three entire days if
you're also playing the pre-rq, but you
have to make less mistakes than your
opponents. And that can get you those
metal cards, those top aids, best of
prizing overall, just maybe a title.
>> Yeah. So much so interesting thing you
mentioned there about the pre-qualify
the pre- regional qualifier event as
well on the Friday that you know if
players did compete in that and now they
find themselves in this sort of last
round of Swiss that is essentially like
3 days of just non-stop riftbound action
and and if you're anything like me you
know trying to play riftbound for that
long where you kind of consider you know
reaction chains and triggers and all
that stuff might just come down to as
you say just making less mistakes in
your opponents something I want to draw
attention to as well when you are on
those feature match tables you've got
lights point in at you multiple cameras.
It definitely adds another layer of
complexity.
>> Definitely the stress is a lot higher
and then it comes down to can you focus
more than your opponent because the
stress also applies to your opponent.
They are also in their win in match for
top eight perhaps and then you will just
have to see who makes less mistakes, who
can handle the situation better, who can
play cleanly and then of course still
playing card games. You might have an
advantage if you're going first. So you
also need a little bit of luck. cannot
you cannot miss your two drop there.
>> And it looks like we can get our last
Swiss round started now and head down to
our table.
Both of these players will need to get a
win to have their march into top cut and
beyond. And the loser their Utre
regional qualifier run ends here. As Leo
did say, still a fantastic achievement.
they can hold their head up high, but
I'm sure if you ask both of our players
here, they're not satisfied with this
potential top 64, they want to get into
top eight. Let's consult our players
deck. So, we have Bakora, who will be
playing that Master Y, our most played
legend here, I think, this weekend, but
rightfully so. Did rather well in our
Tanging event as well. And look at this
list, Leo. Anything jumping out of you
in the main deck? Everything to me seems
rather ordinary. feel like I've seen
that list before. I think that uh many
things in life are true and sometimes
houses are big. That is that is a list
that is very very familiar. Might be one
to one copied from another event from my
best of if I remember correctly. One of
Grim Resolve, the one of Primal
Strength, but one one sabotage in the
main deck that strikes out because many
players have opted to play two or three
>> in the main deck. I'm a big fan of that
because information in this game is so
important and we have seen this before
as Colin has played I think it was
versus Alenzq sabotage not always if you
use in the right spot only takes away
one card from hand sometimes it forces
your opponent to respond with everything
they have.
>> Yep. And sometimes you know games can be
made or broken just of the oneoff
sabotage clinking the right card out of
the hand. But then we do have Lauria and
they are playing Civ. Everyone's
favorite deck in format. That dazzling
Aurora, hate it or love it. It is rather
strong. And here it is warming away from
the top cut trying to cheat those big
units into play. Elder Dragon mind
spplitter and just make life hard for
your opponent. One pack of wonders in
that deck list as well together with
three treasure trove. You can loop some
of that extra power, but it is a little
bit slow and you want to get there as
fast as you can. Catalus of Aons always
a little bit dicey versus Master Y. It's
a card that you sometimes are not
allowed to play if they leave open one
rune. That is a possible lose condition
for the deck.
>> Yeah. So therefore, people have started
to play this pack of wonders treasure
trolls package again because they know
if I'm playing versus calm decks and
they have one rune left open, my second
play cannot be catalyst of aons. I might
get incredibly punished for that. So you
rather try to build up other resources.
But other than that, the matchup seems
fine for Civer because Master is not the
most aggressive deck. Even though with a
first mate in Starring for example, you
can run away quite quickly.
>> No,
>> Catalyst of Elms will be a big one to
see as you rightfully say if it goes for
going to be the double mulligan. They're
not too rare actually. Let's have a
look. Okay, here we go.
>> Double mulligan there for the Aurora
player again. When you're Aurora,
mission number one is finally Aurora.
Mission number two, get the runes in
play to use it.
>> But we are going to get here we go our
Swiss round 13 feature match here. Let's
make some noise please. The winner of
this match will advance to top eight. We
are going to see the pit rookie come
down and it is over to dazzling Aurora.
What can they do? Shay, are you seeing
what I'm seeing? There is a catalyst of
aons in hand and no other play for the
first few turns. If Bakura finds a Defy
plus a first mate, he can exert
absolute huge amounts of pressure. That
is one of the ways you win these games.
Puts it in the seat of power.
>> Well, there is a defy in the hand as
well. You know, there's the cost. Could
be baiting out something.
>> Oh, that is
super dangerous here. If you do not
respond to that, you of course lose that
point that you want to score. If you on
guard that, you kind of cannot play the
first mate because one of your win
conditions again in this matchup. One of
the best ways to use defy is to steal an
entire turn from your opponent. So you
do not want to go down to okay.
>> He just accepts it
>> or we said it's fine to something else.
Yeah, I think we still Yeah, we are
going to on guard there. That will push
the pit rookie out of gust range.
>> I think that is completely correct. And
then you are not playing that first. M.
You can still use that in the next turn.
You can then just hold. Okay, you can
also play the first mate and then you
don't have the defy back up
>> and that is going to be punished by a
catalyst of aons that is just going to
resolve if it is played. Maybe the river
finds a different cut. He also has the
sabotage that could do a little lookie
in hand. However, that DMs you and that
is not what you want.
>> Nope. Game plan number one for See is
rather simple. Get to nine runes so you
can play that dazzling Aurora. That is
where the deck unlocked. Elder dragons
and mind splitters can come out of the
deck. But that is mission number one. We
have to get there.
Four runes being tapped there. I imagine
it be the catless of a new channel an
extra two exhausted.
>> Mhm.
I believe in you.
>> I believe in you.
>> The mind games. Looks like that cat is
going to go through though. Leo back
over to Bakura now. First mate in play.
Pit rookie in play.
>> And for Bakura, it's just going to get
points on the board.
>> Bakora has one of the win conditions
>> in hand as well. He still does have the
Axan is going to go into Sigil of the
Storm and Axan could steal a potential
Aurora if it
>> happened to be played and that is a
funny
>> funny steal.
>> That would be disastrous that Axia
mischievous. If you pay too extra, you
can just swipe a gear from your opponent
and bear in mind that's a unit. You
can't sabotage that out of the hand as
well. We are going to see a double
conquer here. Of course, you know, no,
we can't issue a response here if we're
Lori.
>> That will suck because whatever I play
now will
>> First of all, Yuriva needs to find the
Aurora.
>> War is in hand.
>> Is it?
>> Is in hand. It is in hand.
>> I'm sure it is. I'm sure I saw it. No.
Guess when we consult when we consult
the hand, we'll have a look. I think we
did.
>> For now though, it looks like champion
ye.
It looks like
>> it is going to come down and going to
get played there to the sigual of the
storm as well.
>> They tempered. I like it that we are
playing too into that battlefield
because if an elder drake was happening,
you still keep it there. You get to hold
there and you don't have to play another
unit into it. Now we're playing a third
unit in to the sigil of the storm.
>> Okay, let's have a look at this hand.
There is an Aurora there. Is Aurora
alive right now?
>> I don't think it is. We are at exactly
nine.
>> And there is
no Yeah, you're right. It'll be coming
down if he did have it.
>> As soon as we activate the ST deck, I
think Bakura is really chilling.
>> Yes.
Now, you do have, you know, a small
window for Dazzling. can get one turn
off it I'm sure but you don't want to be
falling into like two or three turns
especially he isn't to know that Bakar
has an answer in hand as well especially
with that hand argument that you could
make is flurry of blades you have two of
those you can kill off the both pit
rookies there
>> yeah you could but I don't have access
to two I'm not sure their stat deck so
baka can be a sire relief no aurora this
turn
that Aurora of course at the end of your
turn and you reveal the top card of your
deck until you find a unit and you can
play it for free that unlocks Aori's
deck.
The second pitch rookie that Bakura
played is really interesting for me. I
would love to know what his thought
process behind that was because that's
not really protecting anything from
Elder Drake anymore. You already have
two and you are again closing your
window on a defy. If your opponent
doesn't play Aurora on nine and then
starts with a stack deck, that is
something that I would love to defy.
Silver Mercenary gets into play
and a challenge.
So, we can go four onto the three of the
first B. They're going to remove that
from play. Remove it off that
battlefield.
Slow down the ramp as it was. I said the
ramp the aggronos I should say of the
points from Bakora
but yeah Bakora gets a turn of relief it
feels like no Aurora
and Bakora back on the board now let's
see three units in play let's consult
this hand though we know that one of
them was the action
>> draw
>> action unfortunately very dead right now
>> yeah this is not the turn for action
>> I don't don't think he's going to hate
that though
>> no Now, what are we looking for? We try
to find a first mate. I'm very sure of
that. Scuttle crab would be really,
really strong. I think in those
situations where Aurori doesn't get
going, scuttle crab is also very
valuable. And now we almost immediately
wanted to exhaust our runes and then we
realized, oh, that's one too many that I
need. So, we do have quite a few options
in the hand there. discipline defy charm
all super helpful right now. So we are
going to move a pit rookie back two pit
rookie back.
>> We leave a master y there that will
activate the master legend ability of
course plus two for what it's worth
>> putting it to an effective six.
>> Another big question that you'll have to
ask yourself now is do you charm in the
civil mercenary into the master y
>> I quite like that idea. You know your
opponent's already missing Aurora. If
they miss it again, you could just
remove all options, but we are just
going to see the pass.
>> I love that because I don't think that
the civil mercenary is doing a whole lot
of work for your river.
>> If you get to conquer the seat of power,
so what? But if you have a charm later
on, you can push out a unit from a
battlefield and then perhaps get a
gamewinning conquer if your needs more
time. But he found
>> top deck of the dazzling Aurora.
>> That is massive. We cannot understate
that folks how important that top deck
was. I think if we didn't see an Aurora
this turn, the game could have slipped
away. Do you ever Oh no, we're going to
preemptively use a sabotage. We can't.
So we are just going to have to free
rain. Put the Aurora down. That has
stock by the way. No response. See will
advance the seat of power. And here we
go.
>> End of the turn. Mind spplitter or elder
dragon.
>> I think he needs a mind spplitter to be
completely honest with you. If
>> that would find the action that would be
huge. Oh, I love this.
>> What? It was
>> massive find. The answer of the action
will get discarded from the coming into
play ability on the mind spitter. Yeah,
I mean, easy choice there. All of a
sudden, I thought Pakora was going to be
in the driver's seat able to steal
>> that
Aurora, but without the action, this has
become a very different game.
>> That is so huge. the oneoff mind
spplitter hitting that battlefield
ripping the answer out of the hand of
Bakura. And right now the elder dragon
effect wouldn't have done too much. Plus
>> this was the the cards from the couple
and put it down
>> barely matters.
>> Wow. Okay, this is a very different game
here folks. Quite honestly I thought
Pakora was going to run away with this
and action away that Dazin Aurora and
that would have been all for game one.
However, now this is extremely
different.
>> How much XP are we at with the master
tempered? Because this one has been
sitting there for I imagine
>> I think now two turns, right? It held
two turns at four.
>> That sounds right. Yeah.
>> So, not able to gank just quite yet.
Discipline is a card that I could see
happening just soon. You know, charm
over that mind spplitter. discipline
your master Y and try to find an action
before
>> discipline the
>> yeah I think you you dig first
>> is there any other gear removal in this
deck um
>> thank you Idra
>> doesn't look like it you know
>> okay we keep digging
>> it would have to be action again
>> like to play a crab here
>> I said I keep digging
>> okay that's it
>> my heart stopped for a second I thought
he found the action but I do think it is
a ranga trophy hunter.
>> Yeah, it was a trophy hunter.
>> And now I think once you committed the
discipline, you do want to get the
maximum value out of it. So I think a
charm taking over the mind spplitter is
not absolutely unreasonable. You would
go down as a defender would go up to
eight might. Therefore beating that
mindsplitter. Then the big question is
can you get rid of that civer? Throwing
two pit rookies into it and then
conquering with a scuttle crab is a
possibility.
And that is a statement.
>> It is a possibility.
>> That's putting it lightly. There is the
charm. They're going to move over that
mind spplitter.
>> And that will be an easy eight to seven
due to that master y legend ability.
>> I don't think.
>> No, I would like to send this to here.
>> Oh, it is such a tough spot. You can of
course trade those off. You get a draw
with the scuttle grab. That is huge.
Maybe we find Ashan. That would be a
huge huge out here. Massive top deck,
but one is already gone.
>> Another unit is being fought because we
know the next card is going to be the
Elder Drake. I can imagine that Master
He might retreat here.
>> That Elder Drake is devastating.
>> Will go back.
>> And you put one damage
on each of your opponent's units at
different places. And remember, with the
Elder Dragon in play, any amount of
damage is enough to kill an enemy unit.
So, it's basically can wipe three units
at the same time if they're spread out,
which is why we're going to see the
Master U retreat, just to make that life
a bit harder.
>> Play a photo here.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah.
Trying to hold in that seat of power
versus a potential Elder Drake.
>> Play. Yeah, your turn. I mean
potentially pretty much guaranteed elder
drake at the end of the turn.
>> But with this scuttle crab counter, we
got up to six. And that is our game shot
for the next turn.
>> It is. Yeah. Okay.
Do I have flurry of blades though?
There's a catalyst of aons.
So you get to channel one, draw one cuz
you couldn't channel the maximum of two.
sabotage going to come in. I don't know.
Well, I can get rid of the defy. I get I
think defy is the only target actually
that sabotage.
>> I don't think you use that because then
you're just damping yourself for
nothing. However, you're concealing
information and that can be quite
crucial.
>> Oh, yeah. It doesn't matter, I guess.
Yeah.
>> Yep. You can only take this. Uh, do you
want to load it?
>> That one gets
>> should get recycled and get sent to the
trash.
>> Can be rather impactful when you think
about cars like Fizz, for example.
>> Yeah.
>> Here we go.
>> Classic body fizz.
>> But I know what you mean.
>> Yes.
>> That is already the turn. Not much more
that can be done. Elder Dragon.
>> The big, the bad, the scary. Elder
Dragon hits the field.
I imagine Master Yi
>> Lonely Porro will get sent to the trash
now.
>> Honestly, the sabotage quite impactful
>> because now
>> you cannot defy the flurry of blades and
you only have two pushes into the sigil
of the storm. You're going to hold up to
seven. It is
>> Yeah, these dice
>> and you show me your hand from crap.
>> Okay, another flurry challenge elder.
Okay.
>> This is a flurry
>> probably.
>> Oh yeah. Takes out of course. Go ahead.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Can Bakura
score the extra two points needed.
>> Iori what has weathered the storm has
got an Elder Dragon in play. Now this is
what the Dazzen Aurora deck is built to
do is a comeback deck. Can Bakora
weather this Elder Dragon storm?
big question whether you want to
actually try and conquer here because
you just know the card is going to be
traded away immediately and getting one
extra point doesn't really cut it. It's
actually an argument to be made to keep
that scuttle crab in base instead of
hastily conquering. Perhaps playing a
porro and a ruin runner might suffice
there. You have this charm which is a
nice pickup for future turns. doesn't
help you now immediately, of course. But
you have at least a little bit of time.
So, but the Elder Dragon clock has
started though. Once an Elder Dragon
does stick, you haven't got a lot of
game left to quickly try and close it
out because once it gets rolling, Leo,
very hard to stop.
>> Yep. That is why it's so important for
the Aurora opponents that the Aurora
player do not find. the Aurora. I said
Aurora a lot of the times now in a row.
>> That is what happens when you're casting
an Aurora game.
>> Gotcha.
>> Here we go. We are going to see some
runes being used here. It's going to be
ruin runner
>> or could it be Rengar? Oh no, it's going
to be ruin runner plus the lonely pora.
>> And we don't push the scuttle crab.
>> I don't mind it quite honestly.
Okay, what has Leori Leori got here?
top.
>> That's an elder dragon. Uh-oh.
>> That is catastrophic. No,
>> that is that is the last unit.
>> That should be the last unit in deck.
That is absolutely catastrophic because
now
>> we have three in total. We've seen one
elder dragon. Are there two in hand now?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, there's two in hand now.
>> That is crazy because now you can't put
another elder dragon into the seat of
power to protect yourself from charm.
You only have one flurry of blades. So
if next turn Bakura just pushes back
that Elder Dr. I mean you have full you
can play another one just from hand
right?
>> Yeah you can play one from hand
okay all right
>> to say
>> sorry
>> I mean it's obviously costly but you can
do it and I think if needs must
>> sorry
>> that's okay we'll let you off. You've
been pretty sharp this weekend. We'll
let you off this time.
>> I try
>> you do a fantastic job.
>> Let's play to base.
>> Oh
>> did play it to base. You are correct. I
>> mean you can obviously remove the lonely
porro there. Can't target ruin runner.
Of course
>> if he can't find anything else that
should be immediate game. Two points
left to go for Bakura.
>> It was charming hand for Bakura.
>> Okay. So I have nothing.
>> I have nothing. Shuffles the deck. Of
course Bakura can now make that read
that there is an Elder Dragon in hand.
Once you got
>> I think he's revealed it in hand, right?
Just to show you. Yeah, you can see it
face up there on the back. Once you got
through all the cards,
>> you have to shuffle the deck when you
recycle it. And now completely tapped
out. The river did not push the elder
dragon into that battlefield. That could
be a possible charm to base.
>> Conquer charm in hand. I don't think I
saw it earlier. Let's have a look. Charm
would be get charm is in hand. So yeah,
you can just charm back an elder dragon.
Conquer with one crab. Conquer with ruin
runner.
>> Are we missing something? I I do
understand absolutely that you're taking
your time with this move. This is a
>> Are you on? Nothing. Oh, you're on zero.
Here out.
>> Yes. Okay.
>> I think he's just making sure. Okay.
>> I don't mind it when you're in a winning
for top eight.
>> Like to
>> Here we go.
>> Charm the dragon off
>> and we are going to see the immediate
concession there for Miori. The core was
able to weather the Elder Dragon Storm
and has one game up here with double
thumbs up to the camera. We love to see
it.
What a win there. Aurora got going top
deck the Elder Dragon. How good is an
Aurora? If you draw all of your units,
you don't have any last traits. You
don't have Lunar Boon to discard them.
>> You're just sitting on a gear that
doesn't do anything. I mean, it was
still good to discard that Axan, of
course, because then otherwise Yei just
gets to accelerate all of those units. I
mean, accelerating is a key word that
means something completely different,
but you know what I mean.
>> You know what we we know what you mean.
>> Oh, and that is some nice side decking
info. Not only the disarming rake that
is going to be able to destroy gear,
>> Yeah.
>> but also unyielding spirit to protect
yourself from the elder dragon, from
flurry of blades, more importantly, even
more ways to counter that card. There is
so much hate for Aurora
in Bakura's heart.
>> Yeah, it's interesting cuz we saw on our
most used gear graphic earlier on that
what what dozen Aurora was 10%. So not,
you know, the greatest amount in the
world, but every player it seems in this
hall has a side deck and will have
answers for it. They do not want to lose
to that dazzling. And it looks like
we're going to see some of those cards
coming in. Already dedicated two copies
of the Action in the main deck. So
already a decent amount in the main deck
to be honest.
>> But yeah, you know, looks like we can be
maneuvering at least well up to two
disarming rake there and that unyielding
spirit as well.
>> What I find really
>> nice more sabotage or you can just snipe
out the hand with that as well.
>> What I really like about this tournament
is that we are seeing so many Aurora
players also not immediately going
mobilize catalyst of aons or on three. I
think in the last few Riftbound regional
qualifier broadcasts that I've watched,
plenty of games were that way, that
Aurora just happened on turn three. But
the deck does have consistency issues.
If you need to find one card by turn
three, you're going to have games where
it just does not happen. Then you of
course have to play to your best
capabilities to play with the other
cards that you're having, but your
deck's just not powerful. And it's also
nice to see the other side of the coin,
right?
>> Mhm. Plus, what we are seeing is even
though it is not the best deck in the
room, it's not the most played deck in
the room, people know how powerful
Aurora deck can be and therefore every
run is running so much Aurora hate. We
see Ash Focused Sabotagees to snipe
cards out of the hand. Salvage,
disarming rake, ashan, all of these
cards, turn to dust, acceptable losses,
>> losses. Yeah,
>> everyone wants to get rid of dazzling
Aurora. And who hasn't been there? Going
to a card game tournament, playing a
deck that you think is really powerful,
maybe the highest ceiling in the room. I
don't even think that's that's
necessarily true for that deck, but
maybe you think it's the highest ceiling
in the room. Then you realize, oh, other
people thought so, too. And they are
side decking so much hate against me. I
barely get to play the game. I barely
get to play my strategy. And you are
getting cooked by your own meta call.
>> Yeah, cuz imagine had that, you know,
mind spitter not come down. It was an
elder dragon instead and Axan just
swipes it. You now just have to get
through I say you just had to get
through one elder dragon. It's not the
easiest thing in the world to do of
course but that be it though.
>> This is why and now I'm of course just
saying that because we already have a
Volibear in top cut locked in in top
eight. This is why perhaps Volibear is a
better Aurora deck than Civiver. Now
don't necessarily quote me on that
please. But you also have other
strategies, right? You have cards that
reduce the energy cost of your other
dragons. You have Ferris Forrunner,
those mid-range units. You have pushes
in the mid game from Rengar. If you are
with this Aurora deck
>> on the rune, so you are going second. On
second turn, you can drop a Rengar. That
is already quite powerful. That stops
your opponent from rushing through you.
And I think that's why Villionaire is so
incredibly successful with the deck.
Volibear might be on to something here.
>> Yeah, it's just it's not so one-trick
pony, right? like you can actually put
your units down for cost. You have many
tips and tricks. We saw it in our
feature match B earlier on, didn't we?
And might I say it's actually the deck I
play as well. But here we go. Swiss
round 13 feature match game two getting
started. If wants to win and get into
top cut, he needs to win this game two
and needs to win a game three. For
Bakora, it's simple. Whatever just
happened in game one, have it go again.
No, no Aurora in that hand. We do have
our mulligan of course and the stat deck
to get there and the Luna. Is that the
Luna Boom as well? Yep,
>> that is quite the hand. That is the the
scrier's Bloom.
>> Skyers Bloom I should say. I apologize.
>> The Luna Boom is the
>> Was that the action hand again?
>> Yeah,
>> I think he's trying to hide it from us
as well. Surely you hold on to that
though.
>> One very very specific thing about Rift
Bond that separates it from other card
games is that your deck does not get
shuffled during the game at all. Well,
basically, unless you go through your
deck entirely once, like we have just
seen with the dazzling Aurora, Bakura
barely finished the Mulligan and Fiora
immediately slamming down those runes.
But it's very interesting is is that
once you mulligan a card in the
beginning, so you mulligan away your
Axan, you're never going to see it again
basically in Master Y.
>> Mhm.
>> And now you basically know if my
opponent hits a Mind Splitter again,
this action goes. Yeah, that's the same
thing with the stat deck there as you're
putting cards to the bottom. That was
quite a good stat deck. I think I saw a
ghost. I think I saw a catalyst of a
didn't actually quite get to see
>> what we took there. Squire boot bloom
going to come down is over to Bakura.
Let's see what we have. We see a defy
first mate sabotage to defy actually and
the axe. That's a stacked hand when
you're playing against a wara.
>> Yeah, you're not getting the most use
out of that first mate. Usually you want
to combine that with another card and
then make it ready to get some extra
pressure on the conquering front. Also
does not have any calm runes for a
possible defy. So that is not in the
cards right now. So I think with this
hand with double defy you are just
really scared of a catalyst of ions
happening now immediately. But your
river has other plans. develops a civer
mercenary dramping himself but getting
some pressure on the board all of a
sudden the the tempo is on the side of
Civer what is happening in Utria I think
it's one of them you're thinking I am so
far away from a dazz I don't want to
just let Bakora get some easy points on
the board but when you do have that
master yi buff you know the first mates
what comes in at five currently that's a
bit more than the four.
>> Yeah, I'd like to go here.
>> That's is going to go in there. Points
on the board there for
>> Bakora.
>> And I think if you're Eori here,
>> thinking about the trigger.
>> I just need to draw cards.
>> I might be grossly overestimating the
impact of catalyst of aons in these
games because in game one, I said Bakura
needs to really play around it and then
didn't and it was used and he still won.
And now you could play the catalyst and
his opponent tapped out and doesn't
>> for three.
>> We're going to see that Emperor Deis
there going to get the sand soldier in
play and return the first mate.
>> Ready this
>> going to ready up the sand soldier. I
assume it's going to stay there. You
just want to try and force the civ
>> to do something. So it is just going to
be Yep. the pass over. All right then.
Are we going to see the dazzling? Oh the
top. Nope. Was that flurry of blades?
>> Flurry of blades or something.
>> I mean, we're not even halfway there.
>> We going to have to find it at some
point though, Leo.
>> That is true. But we are only at five
runes, so we can chill a little bit.
>> But then again, I guess if you hold it
in hand for longer, it's more time to
get sabotaged away. So, there is that to
think about.
>> That is a very good point. Also, I kind
of the more I think about the civer, the
more I like it because if you do not
have the Aurora, it does make sense to
put some civer pressure on maybe deny a
few holding points.
>> Yeah.
>> And then later on play around sabotage
potentially
to just be able to ramp up so much that
you can use draw cards and then draw
into the Aurora on the turn you want to
play it. But we're going to start
digging with the treasure trove using
the gold token. Mobilize
was found.
>> Yeah,
>> another trove and we're going to
>> Okay, so that means a civ will get the
uh the plus two boost now and we'll get
ganking for what it's worth.
>> Trove.
>> Super needed. Well, I guess it is needed
to go over the top of that sand soldier
with the master actually
>> here. Right.
>> Moving past.
>> Mhm.
>> Yep. It will die.
>> You got a point.
>> The civ applying that pressure just as
you rightfully said. Well, if I haven't
got a war yet, I'm not going to let you
just sit on that battlefield.
>> Got that plus two might and ganking for
what it's worth.
>> The suns.
>> Mhm.
Sky Bloom is now going to be used to
just take a little look. See, I'm
finding I think it was a stack deck
perhaps.
>> Don't mind that stack deck. We'll take
that.
>> Next turn, still no Aurora turn.
>> Nope, you're right with that um energy
being used. We're not quite at the
Aurora yet.
>> However, the hand of Bakura is also not
the strongest one so far. So
>> he's just
>> the civer is a doing a really really
decent job at stopping Bakar from
>> first mate here
>> to ready it up to ready the master yes
going to go swing it in with the with
the yei buff that is going to be a trade
I should there's no buff it's not
defending I apologize but that is going
to be a trade there so Iori's pressure
from that civ immediately lost and a
first mate is going to conquest in the
bottom and get a second point for bakora
but I have a question for you Leo
>> has bakora have taken enough points
here. Needs to get points on the board
quick. Ooh, did top deck an elder dragon
there.
>> Yeah, that is
>> so that can be impactful.
>> Necessarily the greatest, but a stack
deck. Are we finding the dazzling or I
think that was it.
>> Now this is interesting. It's been a
mind game start now as we are getting
towards the dazzling or return. Do you
try and fire off a sabotage?
>> I think after a stack deck
>> on eight runes. I mean, before that,
Yoriva never even threatened to play the
Aurora because he wasn't at the right
runes yet. I think the turn your
opponent.
>> Yeah.
>> Before your opponent hits nine runes,
this is where you sabotage always,
especially with a hand that big and then
you're just hoping that it is not going
to be a hand with double Aurora. Just I
also like that the forgotten monument
was conquered last turn by the first
mate because first mate really is a card
that you need versus Aurora. You can
conquer the Emperor's D. That's two
sabotage in hand. So you can actually go
for it twice if you want. Obviously you
just play the first one. Then if you
want to see a double or you go for it
again that would be devastating. Surely
one of those sabotage is going to come
down. We are going to see one and the
energy play. There is the sabotage and
that means that dazzling Aurora is going
to get sent to the bottom of the deck.
Are we seeing putting that down? Doesn't
even care to read more of these cards
there to write them down. Actually,
yeah, we do. Next turn could be Elder
Dragon turn if I'm not mistaken. So,
there's four three. So, Elder Dragon
could be just played there.
>> What a turn though from Bakora.
>> Think you are very much fine to
>> Do we go for a rune runner here then? If
you know that dragon could come down.
>> Yeah, I think you can go for a rune
runner and then first mate, bounce that
first mate. So, you have it in hand.
here.
>> So, you get to conquer here and you get
to put that card back to your hand as
well immediately just so that the elder
dragon can't really hurt you anymore.
You're safe here in hand and you are
already at four. So, with
>> this next next turn is going to be a
little bit harder to conquer two turns,
two points.
>> Looks like 1 2 3 4 5 six. That is going
to be a ruin runner. cannot be targeted
by enemy abilities or spells.
>> Will be safe from an Elder Dragon ping.
>> I think we're going to play this into a
battlefield perhaps. No.
>> Yeah, com.
>> Now, if the Elder Dragon was dropped
next turn, you could have it in a
battlefield and then when it gets
readyed at the beginning of the turn,
first mate, uh, push it back. First
mate, conquer the other battlefield.
>> This one
might be de exactly where to play it.
I don't think it matters at all where I
put
>> Y looks like we are going to go for the
battlefield spotting that play there Leo
that you rightfully said
>> the elder you can top Aurora but that
would suck
aurora that would be very rude of you
um yeah I will play it over here
>> the forgotten monument even then you can
next turn when the elder dragon if it is
played. Yep. Immediate Elder Dragon here
trying to remove most of what could hurt
you.
But next turn, a possible double conquer
or hold plus conquer
>> from the rune runner. And I think Bakura
is at a point with runes.
>> If he has 10,
>> he can actually just bounce the Ruin
Runner and play it to base so it doesn't
get combat killed by the Elder Ring.
That is crazy.
>> That being a fantastic turn there. What
do we have? Sabotage the fire times two
pit rookie
first mate. And is that action? That is
the action. Okay.
>> H
I mean the obviously defy is nice.
Sabotage is nice but
not quite what we're after here.
>> The big question you have to ask
yourself
>> as play
to drop above this
Where was here?
>> Okay.
>> Oh, maybe we are just going to first
mate and push the pitch rookie into the
emperor's dest.
>> I like that play.
>> No, I love that play.
>> Go here.
>> Six.
>> Yep. Six point.
>> You go to six. You bounce the piter. You
push back the ruin runner. And then you
have two defies open for the opposing
turn or for your next turn to stop your
opponent from pressuring you. I love
that from saying I love that play. So do
I. To be fair, this is looking rather
good.
>> Got to pay an energy for that though. I
think we play pit rookie and first mate.
>> Yeah, we do need correct. Do we get the
sand soldiers? Come down though.
Y worth knowing that ruin runner that is
getting up there in regards to Mike was
that seven nine with the Wu Blademan
buff that's almost taking on elder
dragon on its own.
>> Go back.
>> That's eight right now with one buff.
>> Sorry. Yeah, you are correct.
>> Replay the buffing this.
>> That is a
>> buff the first mate.
>> Huge setup in base. If Bakura was to
find something like a punch first turn,
>> could set up a possible game shot at
six. There is an Aurora found. That is
exactly what your rea needed to maybe
get back into this game.
>> You're on 11 find there.
>> 11 runes.
Let's listen and hear what our players
are thinking.
>> Oh, the dragon moving in.
>> All of this bluffing a possible
>> change it for a
Yeah, you could just Worth a try, right?
>> We're not having any of that banter that
Bakra is offering here,
>> but it's worth a try. You're absolutely
right. I also like that he loved punch
first plus on guard.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> So, one treasure.
>> Now, what I want to see next is an axon
grabbing that dazzling aurora. Are we
going to see a mind spplitter again? Or
is it going to be an elder drake? Elder
Drake wouldn't do too much.
>> Is the mind spplitter?
>> Wow. Okay.
>> Action surely being discarded there of
the effect of the mind spplitter again.
The monster coming up at the perfect
time.
>> However,
>> no. No. However, that is actually really
really clutch. I was about to say I
think that was
>> the perfect find there.
>> Cor is going to look at the rest of the
deck, get some information,
>> but this is something that he didn't
manage to develop in last game. Two big
units at the same time after sighting
the deck plays a little different,
right? You have multiple minds to take
those answers out of the hand.
Lord knows who has how many mind
splitters he has in his deck right now.
Tries to devel develop it in base. That
would be losing to a charm top deck
again. He knows there is the five.
Flurry of blades is not going to do
anything. That is the draw that could
bring Bakura directly into the top
eight.
>> He wouldn't do it, would he?
>> No, we haven't decided on the placement
yet.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay.
>> It's going to be in the base. Okay,
Charm, the top eight
regional qualifier. Here we go. No way.
No way. Off the top. Ask and you shall
receive. Charm will get Pakora into the
top eight here at a Utre regional
qualifier.
>> He blows it away with a kiss. And there
is a flurry of blades waiting in hand
sabotage. It's going to take a look see
here. If I can't steal your Aurora, I'm
going to beat it. And there's the
handshake. Bakar takes this 200 in such
a tough match up. 11 1. What a menace
off the top. That charm. Can you believe
it? Pakora.
Unbelievable.
Charming in game one. Charming in game
two. And he secures himself a slot in
top eight. Head in the hands. Cannot
believe it until quite honestly. I can't
believe it. You can't see Leo. He can't
believe it either. Wow.
Absolutely unbelievable.
Absolute master class as well. Getting
all of these important points. finding
the right choices in terms of
positioning your units, putting that
rune runner into that battlefield,
stacking the battlefields more and more.
There's not too many things you can do
differently versus Aurora, but the
moments he had a choice, he found the
right one. You are correct. You have
sort of break points against the Aurora
decks, right? Sure, the early turns,
you're free to do whatever you like in
theory, just get points on the board,
but you have those break points, as you
say, to close games out. and you have
break points to try and swipe and stop
the Aurora and Bakora was able to
capitalize exactly when he needed to.
And I want to appreciate the sort of
difference in play there from Miori
there. Sort of saying, "All right, if
I'm if I'm not going to have my dazzling
aura, I want to put pressure on with
Severe." Forced the issue a little bit
there from Bakora. But Bakora was able
to snipe away
the dazzling Aurora. Elder Dragon came
down paying the cost. Another Aurora did
come down. I find the mind spit and we
thought that would have been enough for
Yori to win this game. However, with
that top deck right there, slamming it
down, but Cora gets 7, gets8, and that
is all he needs to secure himself a slot
in our top eight here at the Utre
regional qualifier.
>> Just amazing. And I want to point out
the difference in, you know, player
style, conversational style there. While
his opponent was rather quiet, which is
also of course fine. You want to be
focused in those matches. You want to be
fully concentrated. do not get
distracted. There's also on the other
side Bakura who's here to have some fun.
Also always there with the correct play
at the correct time, but also knowing,
hey, we're playing some card games here.
Let's have a little chat. I think you
are correct. I loved hearing the bakor.
I think my favorite thing from him when
the elder dragon moves into the emperor
day says you going to pay one to turn
that into a sand soldier. Obviously not.
But now we can hear from Bakur in our
winners interview. Let's kick it down to
the lounge with Barrett.
And I have the absolute pleasure to be
joined with one of our other lockedin
top eight finalists here at the regional
qualifier in Utre Bakura with Master Ye
Bladesman, the most represented legend
in the room. And you could be could be
>> the only one in top eight. How do you
feel?
>> Uh you mean I locked eight to top eight?
>> Like like you like you
>> I am in top eight.
>> You're in top eight.
>> Yeah, that's cool. So, I don't know. I
feel awesome. Honestly, I never won
against an Aurora of Mastery in my life.
That was the first time. And I to him.
>> That's incredible.
>> Yeah. Like, honestly, I have no idea
what I'm doing. I to almost every
opponent I played against today. Pretty
easy. Not knowing how to play my cards.
>> How long have you been playing
Riftbound? Uh I started
even before it came out like playing on
proxies. Yeah. But there weren't that
many product in my area. So I skipped
the entire set one. Then I played
something like during set two. Yeah. And
I play a bit during this set but not
enough to be in top eight of original.
Like I never expected to be here. Like
well you are right now. And there are
people out there that of course are
other Master Yi believers. again the
most represented legend here in the room
and you could be the only one that
represents them in top eight which would
mean a best of ye could potentially
headed your way as well. One of those
coveted trophies but you're also still
in the running of this tournament. This
isn't your last round according to other
you know for other people like there are
in the room. You could be the Utre
regional qualifier champion
>> and I'm excited to see it happen. So
we're going to
>> that would be so cool.
>> It would be amazing. I mean, like you
said, you had no expectation to get
here, but proving that just playing the
game, getting in the hard work, taking
the time to do so, and you proved it
right here. You saying having never
beaten a dazzling
>> I never like I lost against Lori, the
guy I played against right now. I lost
to him one week ago at an Nexus night. I
got stomped to because like we are
friends. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> I It wasn't even close. He just stomped
me and he was like, "Yeah, I'm just
starting playing the deck. I don't know
what I'm doing." And yeah, now I won
somehow.
>> And here you are. And with that, we of
course still have much more to unfold
here for Utre and figuring out the rest
of the players in our top eight. So,
we're going to go ahead and send it
back.
>> Mine of an interview. That legend.
>> Yeah, man. Didn't even realize that that
was a win in top. That was a surprise to
him. But I think my favorite part has to
be last week at Nexus Night. They played
that matchup. Those two, they were
friends. He said, "I lost to Wo." But
this time, he returns that favor when it
matters most.
>> Yep. I think you take this over playing
at a nexus night and they're winning
two. So, I think Bakura is going to be
more than just fine. But we of course
have as always a second featured match
ready for you guys. And I cannot wait to
get into the details of that because if
you like Aurora, today's the day for
you.
>> This is true. But this as you as we did
mention a little bit, this is a bit more
of a spicier little bit more options to
play with. So that's going to be fun to
get kicking off. I think we actually
have to join that one in game two, I
believe.
>> I think we are even going into game one
a little bit. It's going to be CTCGaire
versus Micus Rameno. So we're going to
see some Rexai action once again. going
second on the rune. Playing out a Rexai
breacher.
And you can see, of course, the
misaligned timer here.
So, you are going to see when the
players have made which move at which
time.
>> Yes.
>> And I can imagine that this matchup is
rather rather scary for a Volibear
because
>> stabilizing once you have Aurora is a
thing that works against aggressive
decks. Yes. Yes,
>> but there is also the problem that in
decks like Volibear with so many
different units, you don't hit Aurora
that often. So, I think the ceiling of
the deck is
>> very much higher
>> than other Aurora decks, but
>> sometimes you don't have it.
>> We are going to have the Noxus hopeful
coming down thanks to the Legion. But
yeah, you are right. You're not going to
hit all. We are going to see a Ferris
for though. This is a fantastic card
against those aggro decks cuz on this
death kneel you can get two mechs in
play and we are going to see the volley
bear legend ability there. Whenever you
play a unit that has mighty or is mighty
you can channel a rune.
>> Almost impossible to to remove that card
>> without of course throwing multiple
units into it and then seeing your
opponent get more stuff out of it. The
cuts like blood rush in this matchup
versus something like the ferris
forunner are quite helpful because you
can just,
>> you know, trade up. You don't lose a
unit with it if you repeat it on the Rex
eye for example on attack
>> and then yeah two tokens a bit annoying
but still.
>> Okay.
>> Oh,
do we call that
>> of the legend ability?
>> Yeah, I'm going to play.
>> Okay,
>> cycle one. take this.
>> Oh, so does get to play cold week there.
So immediately going to see that death
kneel.
>> Yes,
>> I like that though. You said it can be
hard to get around the ferris 4unner.
How about you just cheat a colder week
off the top.
>> That gets rid of it.
>> Yeah. And now you're giving your
opponent no option for big trades. Three
points ahead. Rexi doing Rexi things.
Two mech tokens established in base for
Villionaire. Pavilion can't really go on
the offense here, but he can just keep
developing big units. I mean, which
point you just play another Ferris for
give your opponent two more points.
You're still an aspirin climb, right?
>> Yeah, I don't mind that against a deck.
You're just swarming in those mechs. I
saw a gentle gemstone gemstone dragon in
the hands that readies up two runes when
you play a dragon. I just count itself
for what it's worth. That's like we are
going to start getting some points on
the board. This is an aspirin climb
game. We are going to nine
>> one.
>> That mech is going to go in on the
aspirants climb. Villionaire's first
point on the boards. Are we seeing a
4Runner played into that battlefield now
though?
>> Because that is going to make it super
tough for Ramaniano to conquer that
battlefield while still keeping up the
pressure ins.
>> There's that fear.
>> Yeah. And I love that you don't even do
anything else with the other mech in
base because your opponent is going to
get around nine might. Maybe he's going
to have to sacrifice a lot of stuff, but
they could also get around the mech.
>> It's clever going into the aspirin's
climb. You don't want to go into that
war camp. That would give all those
little guys an extra might. So making it
as hard as possible.
>> Also, since we are in an aspirin climb,
you're really aiming for those uneven
points. So if you're just offering the
Trifarian War camp to your opponent and
they take it, they just go to four. What
is four? Four is nothing except for Jin.
Jyn loves four, but in this case, four
is not really dangerous. Not even
threatening to be dangerous at any
point.
So I think with the ungodly amount of
Ferris forunners that the CTG
villionaire has to his name, like one in
trash, one on the battlefield, and one
more in hand. I think that's actually
quite decent in this matchup.
We are going to see the car and dredger
going in.
>> Yep.
>> Oh, Inferna and the dashing porro.
>> Daring.
>> Daring poor. I apologize. It does look
like it's dashing quite a lot as well in
that artwork.
>> It's dashing a little bit. Yeah,
>> inferno's interesting. That could be a
good one, you know, with that assault to
help trade up into these bigger units.
But I think if you want to develop
something in base, the daring porro is
almost always better just because on
defense it also has to and the ambush
you're not really profiting from
anymore.
>> This is true.
>> But maybe Romeo is contemplating if he
at all wants to play those cards. Yes,
>> porro for free is a porro for free. I
mean not exactly free, but you know it's
a card off the top a little bit more
value and those might be needed. those
valuable single cards that you can get
off of your ability because this game is
already looking
>> like it is going to go late. Okay, under
Titan really big unit also supports your
other units. So that is one of the
bigger pushes that the deck has and see
that is the magic of the ferris
forrunner.
>> Yeah,
>> your opponent is going to throw some of
their units in there.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow, that underworld under Titan giving
all my units plus two.
>> Yeah, it's okay. I'll take this one.
Yeah,
>> that means we can actually do a complete
wipe there as it were.
>> The mechs will come down of course, but
the ferris have been dealt with rather
swiftly
by
>> that wasn't too costly actually.
>> No fine.
>> Yeah,
>> the mechs are there of course, but
>> tapped out. Yes.
>> Yes. Yeah. Take the gold.
>> Yep. They're
>> tapped out. Well, I can throw him up
then that mech. There we go. Clearing up
the aspir token over there, judge.
Thank you. Oh, they're saying we should
have our gold as well. Met's going to
charge in there. That is going to
replace itself.
>> Wonder if we're going to be dazzled here
just like in the first featured match.
Dazzling Aurora is going to hit that B
>> tiny even though there is very little
draw engine there. You sometimes you
just got to have it right here. And I
like that putting the Aurora down now
when you know that your opponent's
tapped out.
>> What's it going to hit the Aurora?
>> Not guaranteed to be a big unit here in
the Volair deck.
>> Rengar. Uh
>> Rengar.
Interesting. You can pair that to a
battlefield, right? If you like. Yep.
There we go.
>> You saw these.
>> It's okay. It's okay. Okay.
>> At this point, you are just starting to
get more and more units for free. So,
why not just put them into the
battlefield? make it harder for Rexside
to conquer to access those cards from
the top of the deck.
>> Just chill. You don't you don't have to
go crazy for
>> every single develop stuff in base.
>> Y
>> as long as you get good units for free
the entire time,
>> I think it's fine to just start
defending yourself.
>> Uh yeah, I think he's in a great spot
here. That base is looking stacked under
Titan Rexi. Well, that's what uh eight
between those two, right?
>> There's eight might in the Trafarian War
campus.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, there's the void rush spell.
>> Yes.
>> Going to find the pike
>> or another void rush. You can put that
pike to hand.
>> The rush. Sure.
>> Then pike to the hand. Yes.
>> Two.
>> Yep.
>> That's not what you want to find. Nah,
>> don't think about this. Um,
>> sometimes Rexai gives, sometimes Rexi
takes. In this scenario, I think you are
much more likely to develop the honest
broker because you could use the inferno
from hand technically as plus three
might or plus four in the Trifarian
Warham.
I like how all of these fury decks, they
just
>> tap out every turn. You just you just
fully exhaust your runes, do all of your
place, and then you kill.
>> Take mats.
>> It's okay.
>> Just debating on exactly what you want
to play there.
>> I think you're right. I think I prefer
the broker. That was me.
You could throw the under titan and the
into the
for sure. So,
>> oh, we accelerate with the Rex eye.
>> Yes,
>> that makes a lot of sense.
>> Yep.
>> Um, that base is looking stacked. That
inferno will have
>> salt. This is
>> Here we go.
>> That is a good way to trade into this.
We have five on Rexi and four on
Inferno.
>> Okay. Like this.
>> That's a
five.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, it looks like that is going to
be the trade with the mech into the Rex
Rex eye there.
>> Now, we get to use the legend ability.
>> That hidden blade. And is that an honest
broker?
I think that's an honest broker. Yeah,
honest broker.
Now CTCG Villiona is a little bit
further away from using sky splitters
for basically three
>> cycle one.
>> Yeah, draw two.
>> Not when you have any uh units in play.
We are going to see the hidden blade
there. That's going to remove the
Rengar.
>> Okay, pass the bridge.
>> Under Titan's going to slam in there to
the aspirants crime as well. An easy
toppling of the mech. I'm going to play
this into
>> car and dredger being played there.
>> Was that honest broken?
>> Can't quite.
>> Yep.
>> That is going to be threatening game.
>> Yeah. Oh, so it is.
>> Oh, he picked up the elder dragon from
the top. That is something you want to
find of Aurora to relieve some pressure.
>> Can we play that down? Do we have enough
rooms to play that down now?
>> It is going to be incredibly hard. Oh,
the Predator though that can get played
to battlefields that have enemy units on
is essentially got am well kind of well
it hasn't got ambush but it can it can
get played to occupy battlefields I
should say. Oh, we can't we can't play
the elder dragon. So we are going to see
the the blue and predator coming down
>> as eight into six
>> 11. So
>> under titan goes down. I think
>> what he really needs to do now is find
something crazy. do all three to
>> an elder dragon off the Aurora would be.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, it would be interesting. I guess
you could play that to about well to the
battlefield as well. Making sure you
can't take that top one.
>> And no matter what you do, I think you
always push whatever you get off of the
dazzling aurora into that predator
battle.
>> Okay, here we go.
>> Dazzling Aurora is going to be huge.
>> Oh, it was a dragon off the top as well
at the perfect time. letting you clear
away the inferno and the poor porro as
well.
>> Okay, that as climb now is looking
rather stacked to get through elder
dragon. Any amount of damage is enough
to KO kill your opponent's units.
>> 10 might on the dragon. That means
skysplitter only costs a power that is
also five extra damage. It is
>> almost impossible to break that
battlefield. What is the play going to
be for Ramiano? Because
>> don't forget, you can also still put
everything you own into the Trifarian
War camp and then hope for a hold.
If
>> that is the case,
>> it's okay. It's okay.
>> Oh no, Stormbringer only works from
base. I guess you can move something
back and then Storm Bringer it up.
>> Yeah, that works.
>> That does work. That is a signature
spell there off the Volibear. Don't
blame him for not knowing what that one
does. Viewers, us Voly Bear players
though, we know that one.
Now, sky spplitter, as you say, can get
used for just a fury rune, then that can
actually target anything out of
battlefield as well. So, you can also
use that as well to clear something off
a battlefield,
>> dealing five damage.
Great card when you hit those big big
dragons. If you don't hit them, not the
greatest card.
Probably nothing.
>> Neither. Okay.
>> Blaze or anything like this.
>> This looks like another game.
>> Rengar coming down then
>> accelerated.
>> Oh, we are pushing. We are pushing.
>> All might already. How much steam do we
still have left in the tank?
>> Blood rush.
>> Let's go here.
>> Think we're trading off the elder drake.
>> We're at eight.
>> Eight. by buzzo.
>> Okay,
you can there's the sky sky spplitter
though. That's going to do five.
>> It's going to be enough because of the
elder dragon ability. That's going to
stop that pike right there and then.
>> Such a good card that skysplitter when
you have enough might to make it for
free.
>> I like the play. If you can get rid of
the dead bloom predator, you can call
the week later on one of the carry on
dredges and stack more birds in the
Trafarian War camp.
Look at how Villioness smiling. I mean,
the taunt is already going really,
really great for him.
>> This is where you want to be though as a
body bear player though. Those keep
those big units around when you've got
elder dragon. You can just tap things
out the way.
Bear in mind those bird bird does have
deflect though, so keep that in mind. We
got so many runes open though.
>> I think there is call the week.
>> Okay.
Got to be the dead bloom predator,
right? Yeah,
>> that has to go. That is backbreaking.
>> You hate to see those big units go for
stuff like that, Leo. Honestly,
>> but it is back over to Billionaire
though.
>> Going up to five now, I believe. Right,
we have the whole five, I think.
>> I think Billionaire is is very much
fine. I don't think that is too
backbreaking for him.
>> Two in the hand.
>> Yes, in the hand does have access to
sabotage.
It's a Elder Dragon. Now, we can't play
that from hand.
>> Do you see the gentle dragon? Could be
interesting.
>> I think you could either develop the
Ferris Forerunner in base and then play
whatever comes off the
>> Ezling or Aurora into the battlefield
or the other way around. I don't really
even know
what's the best scenario here. I mean,
those are those are like real micro
decisions that can cost you the game,
but it's most of the time very unlikely.
Like at this point, Dazzling Aurora is
really forgiving.
>> Okay, so the sabotage is going to miss,
but it does give you hand knowledge of a
pike and honest broker.
>> Yeah, I think that's all he wants.
>> Yeah, I mean it'd be nice if you got rid
of something good there. It's just going
to be the parts. Wait,
>> that's another Aurora.
>> What is another Aurora? Oh, okay. just
very firmly placed onto the other one.
And now we can start stacking nodes.
Okay, there is not going to be the
biggest push. I can risk a random bad
hit with Aurora. I don't even know what
that could be. Cardigrim.
>> Then you draw two.
>> And you draw for each dragon
>> or mighty. Is it mighty? I can't
remember now. It's been a while.
>> For each mighty unit. I think
>> each mighty to draw. Oh, another one.
>> Yeah. And that is the one that you are
very likely to put into your base
>> so that you can start pushing into the
trifarian war camp. Establish this
double hold
>> form might on the board right now.
>> Form a unit in base. If you're going to
try and utilize that,
>> you have to have a unit there.
>> I mean, Stormbringer is not an action.
So, at that point, we're also tapped
out.
>> I'm not saying for now, I'm just point
you would need a unit there
>> and then draw three. Yeah.
Oh, finds a falling star. That's
>> the falling star.
>> Okay,
that's a lot of draw power when you get
those kadagins
is over to Mice Rakano now.
>> Yes, m is good.
>> Take a draw and
roll first.
>> But how? two.
>> So
>> that hidden blade is hidden blade,
right? Yep.
>> I think the next question that Ramiano
is just asking himself now is can I deck
out villionaire
>> and can I get the point off of that?
I
>> mean the hidden blade is going to get
rid of that elder dragon though. Does
get to draw two. So that means damage is
normal again now.
>> Yeah. But
>> I mean when you've got what was that 18
of the cowins? That's a lot of might
right there.
Yeah, 18 is quite a bit.
>> That's a good number.
>> Yeah,
>> especially considering that he only has
three might on board that can push. He
has pike, dark side, butcher. We know
that from the sabotage.
>> This is true.
>> Uh,
yes.
>> Oh, goes for a void rush.
>> Void rush.
>> True.
>> Yep.
>> Pike and a dredger. That non is broken.
>> And this in my hand.
>> Okay.
Got those artworks at the same form
here.
>> It's for two here.
>> And now he's trying to establish a hold
here.
>> But that does play right into
Stormbringer,
>> but they need to have a unit in the
base. I guess you move something back
and then Stormbringer it up. Yeah, for
sure.
>> That Stormbringer
>> when you move a you can move a unit from
your base to a battlefield and then you
deal the unit you move the the it might
to all the units there.
>> Back.
>> Here we go. I think we're going to see
it.
>> Stormbringer. There's the Stormbringer
>> mind to all units.
>> Yep, we got to read that card. That's
bad news, let me tell you that. That is
going to kill all of those birds on his
brokers and carry on dredges. At least
Carry on Dreger gives us another burp.
>> Good billionaire. Yep, that is exactly
what it says it does. That is very bad
right now. That cowrid is going to come
in and simply bulldoze all of those
units.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. To the trash. Not to the base.
Well, you will get some birds back, of
course. But
>> Oh, we had a hidden pike there.
>> This here.
>> Oh,
>> okay. Oh, didn't see that.
>> And yes. Um, pay for this. Okay.
>> Oh, they were honest brokers, not not
judges.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, but does M's going to go anyway?
And then uh score
>> sure
>> goes up to seven. Now we're threatening
a double hold. Leo.
>> Yeah.
>> And the Aurora can obviously play these
units in the battlefield to make him
harder as well.
>> It's another Rengar.
>> Rengar.
>> Yes.
>> We still have the second Aurora as well.
>> You're getting to a point where you
don't want
>> an elder dragon. Is this Oh, Rengar
again.
You're getting to a point where you
don't want to hit a cardigram because
then this might deck you out actually.
>> True. Yeah. Yeah.
>> But we are threatening the double hold.
Seven points already. Villionaire
staring down his opponent knowing this
is going my way. I can get an even
better seeding after Swiss. And how cool
is that with your favorite deck of
Volibear Relentless Storm?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. And it's just going to be the
concession there. Villain presenting an
unbreakable board. He takes game one.
And as you do say, doing it with my
favorite deck as well. Volibear. That is
my hero. One game away.
>> A top cut contention and beyond.
Villionaire. Incredible. I think he has
four best of volley bears by now.
>> That is absolutely marvelous. that is it
shows that especially in Riftbound the
loyalty that you show to your legend to
your deck gets rewarded
and as you can as you were saying you
know uh not being a one-trick pony as it
were with the award giving you
flexibility you know stormbbringer
falling star skysplitter get excited
these are all ch well I guess we see
challenge in normal decks as well but
these are all ones you don't see
traditionally in
>> the Aurora decks ferris 4runner as well
just giving you more flexibility
in the game.
Even the Rengars as well. That's not
something you see traditionally. The
gentle gem dragon. These are all cars
that just give you a little bit more
tips. The dead the dead bloom predator
as well, only as a cheeky one-off, but
just letting you be a little bit more
flexible in your game plan.
>> I remember when dead bloom predator was
the prime dazzling aurora target for
Master Yi. That was absolutely wild in
set one.
Amazing card. caused a lot more trouble
in set one. It's a very sought after
car. People have been looking for it in
in all sorts of binders. But that was
such a menace. Immediately dropped off
in Spirit Forge was then very rarely
seen in what maybe maybe Misfortune
decks then, but I think most people have
already then in Spirit Forge said, "Hey,
we're basically just playing Mind
Splitter." But it's interesting if you
was to grab it off the Aurora, you could
then play it into the enemy battlefield
and start causing havoc.
>> But if you're, you know, the Rackside
player here, this is like a, you know,
it's interesting cuz this is very much
an aggro deck, right? From the game one
we saw, what learnings would you take
there as a Rex eye player and how would
you potentially try and adapt? aggro
faster is something
>> I mean with this aggro deck you have a
very straightforward strategy right
against Aurora decks you just do the
same thing you do as against the others
but you are having an easier time
usually executing it so you are just
throwing in your early drops you're
trying to get those points you are
basically at the mercy of the opponent's
deck when you're playing versus Aurora
>> against Aurora there's very few big
decisions that you can make during those
games. And if your opponent starts to
stabilize, flipping those cards from the
top of their deck,
it's it's in volar hands if he wants to
give those big elder dragons, if he
wants to find the dead bloom predators,
or if you're going to see a cardigrim in
base that doesn't really do anything
when you're trying to hold for game. So,
it is really, really tough. You're doing
the same things you always do. You can
establish all of your cards. You can
play as efficient as you want. You can
try to have the perfect rune management.
You don't necessarily need to rush. You
don't need to pay power for anything.
So, you have the biggest pushes in case
your opponent has these big turns and
you still have a shot at getting in
there.
>> Ooh, it's just going to be the pass
over. This isn't Arena's greatest game,
though, so both players will be having,
>> you know, one extra point to start this
game with.
>> And if and if you just go faster,
Arena's greatest. That's one way of
doing it.
site. Yes.
>> Carry and dredger there. Okay.
>> So, well,
>> can't use that. Well, I guess you can
use hidden bait if you like to draw.
>> I'm happy to see those go to the bottom.
>> You could have done that on your own
dredger, which would have been
>> okayish, but again, then you're losing
one rune and as soon as your opponent
starts to stabilize, you have less
resources to try and kill.
>> Oh, Rengar coming straight in.
>> Bear,
>> that is what I'm talking about. This
deck can fight back.
on the second
play and now all of a sudden
>> you're kind of almost ahead in board
present at least when it comes to the
might
>> Volibbe throwing these big paws at Rexai
>> and this is why I love Voli belly and
this is why I play Volbe you have more
tips and tricks you're not just your
opponent can't just sit around thinking
oh they haven't got a ward they can't do
anything Rengar can come out of nowhere
interesting here though Cole the weak or
the inferna it's going to be Cole of the
week. Rengar entered the battlefield.
Rengar Rengar leave the battlefield.
>> And this call of the week is especially
fortunate because you can sacrifice your
own recruit that was in the paper tree.
And you don't need to hold when you hold
on the paper tree.
>> Both players channel a rune.
>> So you are with this not only taking out
the ring basically for free, but you are
also stopping the rank of your opponent.
And that is sometimes incredibly
important in this scenario. If you're
trying to play around in Aurora, doesn't
really matter if they get one more rune
or one less because they are just going
to precisely hit it anyways.
>> Okay though the Ferris 4 and we saw that
have its mits all over game one or it's
it bolts I should say all over game one
>> but that's all we're going to see.
Remember that legend ability whenever
you play a mighty unit you can channel a
rune
>> sort of makes using you know power less
>> impactful cuz you just get it straight
back.
>> Already at five points. Paper tree is
open. Another recruit is going in there
that is going to trigger the Rex eye
void barrel legend ability.
>> We're at least
>> or next turn I should say.
>> Finally.
>> Next game is maybe a little bit. Sorry.
>> Sorry. Get a little bit ahead of myself
there. Why was next turn?
>> Not going to play any of those.
>> We think quite a bunch of those
actually.
>> So we are going to see the combat now.
Yep. Saying all right.
>> What's this thing here?
>> Yes. Um
>> tearing pora
>> this one. Yes
one.
>> Oh throwing in a V as well.
>> Oh I like that. Is it hotaded? I think
that one
>> letting you
>> how many cards
>> get DM discard pile back into your deck
and you increase the might. Here we go.
Billionaire needs to present a threat
here. And I think he's going to because
that last card that he just top decked
being pressured so much is a dazzling
Aurora that he just ripped off that top.
>> Thank you.
>> But
>> does he have a better answer to that B
state in hand?
>> To say though, I feel as if we need
>> we need to prevent the double conquer,
right? Aurora. Well, I guess Aurora can
do that, but it's a bit of a risk. It
might not hit a unit you want. But does
he have another unit that does the
trick? I
>> just think it's just a gentle dragon, I
think. Well, gemstone dragon. So, yep,
it is going to be the Aurora. This could
be very impactful. Elder dragon, I
think, is what you want to see here.
>> Yeah, you want to snipe that fire.
>> Raiki is protecting it already. Cardig
comes in.
>> Well, you can draw two.
>> It prevents a big unit
>> at the very least.
>> Trigger and a draw two.
>> You can't just tap that out the way.
>> Draw two is going to be quite relevant
here. So that is not the worst card to
hit because you can find that sky
spplitter and then use it for just one
power. Picks it up again. This is his
fate. Villionaire is getting all the
cards at the right moments.
>> That sky spplitter is huge,
>> right? Cuz you can use it just one
power.
>> Yeah,
he's completely exhausted in runes. But
what does it matter if he has the power?
Okay.
>> Yep.
>> Seven from
>> that's going to go through. That means
Billionaire is going to be playing with
no
>> wiggle room here. Pike or Noxus hopeful.
>> That is an accelerate unit that you can
now use a pseudo accelerate. Even
better. You just have to pay power, not
one extra.
>> Yeah.
>> Energy.
>> Uh two.
>> What else are we having?
>> This one.
>> Call the Call the Weak.
Um,
>> now that is interesting.
>> Have how much might here? Two.
>> Four. Four.
>> Five.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> 9. 12.
>> 12 here.
>> Yeah. I think I win because I sacrifice
this and this token go to the basic and
you tap it. So
>> yeah. Two plus seven.
>> Seven.
>> And this is 11 here. Yeah,
>> Ramchaniano is saying that he's
presenting game, but I don't think he
considered the sky spplitter.
>> Can the spy sky splitter enough might?
Doesn't look like it can. So,
Billionaire is going to give up here in
game two. That means we're going to a
game three. What? And you said if you
are a Rackside player here, what can you
do differently? You said go faster. That
was ridiculously fast.
>> Arena's greatest really helps you in
those match ups. Some players have
decided to play a more mid-rangey
approach of this Rexai strategy. Even
cutting the Arena's greatest also doing
very well in this tournament.
>> However, oh, that is a legend favor.
Holy cow.
Or bear, should I say.
>> Hey, there we go. So, as we're going
into our game three here, do the time
commitments. are only going to be able
to show you the last five minutes. But I
tell you what, that is the business end
of the game, though.
>> And honestly, seeing how fast this game
went, that might be the full game.
>> That is a great point. Actually,
>> if it wasn't Arena's greatest game,
basically it was 5 minutes. Yeah.
>> But yeah, look at these accomplishments
for our players here. They're really
best of best of best offs. Here we go
into our game three. Six. Oh wow. Okay,
six to eight. And we only see there is
no Aurora Leo. There's only the
Calderrin and there's a ton of units in
that base. This is looking a bit dicey.
>> Wow. Still getting 5 minutes off of this
game state. That is
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, okay. Wow. We're going to seven now
with this. Just needs a hold. Needs to
not get elder.
>> But that's why I think they see so many
in the base though, right? Spreading
them out. Only one at each battlefield
to the elder dragon.
Oh, if we see an Aurora in the trash, I
imagine and I see I think I can see a
salvage.
>> We have I think the cardiggram came from
that salvage. I mean, we have talked
about Rob Aurora being locked in or
Volibar being locked in for top eight
before. If he loses this, he goes to
112. That might not be locked for top
eight after all.
So, I think I made that statement
earlier. Redacting it now. So there is a
chance he does not make top eight if he
loses this. So there is quite a lot at
stake here.
>> So I think you're correct as an Aurora
came in that found a cow but that got
salvaged and that is the B state we're
looking at here for Villionaire. This is
looking dicey. Not enough runes to get
an elder dragon into play the old
fashioned way the hard way.
I mean starfall could be nice. We are
going to see the cowan slamming into
that bird token.
>> And the candle sanctum is going to
reveal some cards. Actually, quite the
cool synergy with dazzling aurora. The
candle sanctum there. You can look at
the top cards and say, "Hey, those units
I really do not want to hit off of my
Dazzling Aurora right now. However,
if you don't have Dazzling Aurora, whole
different ball game." But we see
different cards that can interact. We do
see a Rengar trophy hunter in hand. We
see falling star which we could use to
get rid of that Vi. So if we reeng into
the daring Porro, I'm pretty sure we're
going to win that combat.
Kill the Vi
and then we also have a punch first in
hand. That should be 578
energy.
>> Do we have enough to do a Rengar plus
Falling Star combination? Yeah,
definitely.
>> Okay, I think that's what we have to
see, right?
>> Yeah. Plus, we do have punch first in
hand that can be used defensively
against the onslaught of units that
>> Ramiano is holding up there.
>> Pretty sure he's going to get at least
one conquer though. Oh, that is a lot
>> of runes. Dragon
>> trying to go for the defensive route.
>> Wait, there is no Rengar.
>> Oh, there is no Rengar. was probably
revealed off the top.
>> That's going to ready two though.
>> You can channel one and then you can
ready two cuz the general dragon gem
dragon does count itself. Now we're at
four open.
>> That is so much weaker because now you
have to use that falling star onto that
daring poro. You can't even take out the
VI.
That is going to be a massive threat in
the next turn. Yes, you might have a
punch first. We are right now at 917
that Battlefield can push up to 22.
However, that is not something that no
Rexile player has ever overcome. Plus,
Dazzling Aurora is not active. Next turn
is not going to be an Elder Dragon turn.
Therefore, a possible hold
for Ramachiano even though there is like
plenty of cards like the Stormbbringer
that will stop you from doing so. Nox is
hopeful going into that sigil of the
storm.
>> See, we could storm that, but you want
to try and storm that vibe, right?
>> Yeah. Can't go to eight. So, draw
>> and draw a card. But that does help
because that might find you something.
Gets extra energy.
>> That could be huge if you have something
like a hidden blade. Call the weak. All
of those cards could be deadly right now
and could get him the win.
>> Didn't take the hidden blade. We are
going to see two
>> hidden blade. There's the hidden blade.
Going to remove the cowrin. Uh-oh.
>> I think
>> a huge
>> Are we looking at game now?
>> Chunk of might. There's still punch
first in hand
>> for CTCG billionaire.
>> Oh, we got a hidden blade again. I think
that's it, right? That's going to be
game. And Ramiano
wins. Wow. Games two and game three. Big
fist bump there. big win with the Rakai
Rakai deck Rexai I should say
and he looks like is he likely for a top
eight? He's very very likely for top
eight. That was a great performance
here. Of course, Villionaire also still
in contention with an X2 record. Yeah,
one or two X2s might squeeze into the
top eight. So, we're of course wishing
the best of luck pressing our thumbs
there. But that was the pure Rexai
power. very surprised it could have been
stopped in the first game anyway. So
>> yeah, and I want to apologize for
getting a bit tongue tied there.
Rackside of course, but yeah,
the battle aggro versus the ramp. We
know traditionally how it goes, but
Billionaire was able to make it look
like he could have done it with the tips
and tricks that the Volibear can present
with the Falling Stars spplitter, but I
think eventually the matchup did go how
it should with the aggro deck. looks
like potentially locking in a top eight
placement. But for now, after that, I
think we need a little breather. So, how
about we have a little break, but when
we come back, it's going to be top cut
action here at UC regional qualifiers.
Don't go anywhere.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.